Und wir sind jetzt die Nummer eins in der Welt. Jetzt kommen die Spieler aus Ostdeutschland noch dazu. Ich glaube, dass die deutsche Mannschaft über Jahre hinaus nicht zu besiegen sein wird.
Schubwitz, Bulgarien im Halbfinale gegen Italien und der Weltmeister ist draußen. Bertie Pogts als Nachfolger von Franz Beckenbauer.
Steuerpolitik der FDP ist nicht gut für einige wenige, sondern sie ist gut für alle. Wir wollen, dass insgesamt unser Steuersystem niedriger, einfacher und gerechter wird.
Können Sie ihn bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Selbstverständlich kann ich das, aber ich tue es jetzt nicht. Ich werde mit Sicherheit nicht den Fehler machen, dass ich hier in einer Pressekonferenz Koalitionsverhandlungen führe.
Beziehungsweise kann es nur an einem lebendigen Finger funktionieren. Die Erkennung funktioniert auf jeden Fall ganz anders, als das bisher die normalen Fingerscanner gemacht haben, indem man irgendwie auf die Hautunterschichten draufscannet.
Aber ich glaube, die geben auch keine 365 Millionen Dollar für diese Firma aus, wenn es nicht einigermaßen cooler Shit wäre.
Das System ist eine der größten neuen Advancen auf Apple's brandneue iPhone 5S.
So, ja, aber wir waren verdammt pünktlich heute. Was dem gemeinen Podcast-Hörer natürlich ziemlich egal ist, solange die Sendung früh genug rauskommt, aber trotzdem, 20 Uhr und kein Mikrofon ist an. Jetzt hör ich, funktioniert. Also dafür, dass ich noch vor der Sendung hier nochmal so richtig schön im Gedenken an die 80er Jahre so unter den Tisch kriegen musste, um in meinem PC irgendwelche PCI-Karten zu ziehen.
Das war doch ein Mac. Ja, aber jetzt wisst ihr auch, er hat noch nicht den neuen Mac Pro, sondern nur den alten.
So, den neuen kannst du auch unter den Tisch stellen und bei der Kabellei musst du da auch krabbeln.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Naja, auf jeden Fall haben wir es dann doch in letzter Minute noch hinbekommen, ja alles.
Gab es dann in den 80ern schon Hochdruckluftreinigungsspray?
Bestimmt.
Hat aber niemand.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so kompakt. Ich hatte das allerdings nicht.
Das war mit so einem Stecker dran. Und dann hast du angeschaltet und dann hattest du einen langen Schlauch und dann konntest du Druckluft machen.
Oh man, ich stehe auf dem Schlauch.
Das war jetzt nur der Test, Räusperer, um herauszufinden, ob die Räuspertaste funktioniert, weil sie nicht funktioniert. Ich weiß ja nicht, was du unter dem Tisch noch alles gemacht hast, aber... Ich will jetzt auch keine Details dazu, aber... Ich merke das noch gerade. Die unsere Räuspertasten räuspern nicht mehr.
Ja, die Bier-Trink-Taste funktioniert auch nicht.
Und die Vader-Taste?
Und Dennis vedert noch gar nicht.
Ich weiß auch, warum.
Ja, warum vedert denn Dennis nicht mehr?
Hab ich noch nicht eingeschaltet? Ja, sieht ja aus.
Ist leise.
Soll ich dich mal ein bisschen... Bist du vier?
Vier?
Aber hier auf dem scheiß Pad wieder nicht.
Ja, mach ich gleich. Ich sag jetzt erstmal eins.
Du hast ja auch nur eine Stunde vor der Sendung vorzubereiten.
Hallo und willkommen bei der Freak Show. Ihr werdet schon gemerkt haben, dass ihr nicht falsch zugeschaltet habt.
Das ist so bekloppt wie immer.
Wir haben den 16. Oktober 2013.
Wir schreiben den.
Ich schreibe nicht mehr, ich tippe höchstens den 16. Oktober.
Keine Einschaltungen für die Tagesschau?
Die hören alle Podcasts.
Die hören jetzt alle Freak Show.
Der Senat hat sich eh gerade geeinigt, von daher gibt es heute nicht mehr den Grund, Tagesschau zu gucken.
Der Senat?
Die Weltordnung, wie wir sie kennen, bleibt erhalten.
Die fahren jetzt die Regierung wieder hoch. Mal sehen, ob sie auch clean wieder hochkommt.
Oder nur beim guten Händen bleibt.
Ist die Frage, ob die also Shutdown, fand ich ja, war ja dann doch schon ein bisschen überzogen. Also ich meine, wenn sie wirklich mal die USA komplett für eine Woche runterfahren würden, also ich meine so richtig, also richtig, so mit Internet aus.
NSA aus.
NSA aus, alles aus. Einfach komplett entkoppelt, aber auch, also alles, was vom Start ist.
Hatte ich nicht schonmal erwähnt, es gibt doch, so seit einem Jahr, gibt es eine Fernsehserie, die auf diesem Thema basiert. Revolution heißt die drüben. Wo der Thema ist, dass da einfach mal alles, was mit Strom ist, einfach mal ausgeschaltet wird. Erst total mysteriös, später stellt sich raus in ganz fiese, tolle Dämpfungsfelder oder sonst irgendwas. Ebenfalls geht da so richtig, richtig, überall der Strom aus. Die erste Folge ist relativ cool, weil du siehst dann die Leute, da geht dann innerhalb der Wohnung der Fernseher aus und dann das Licht und dann gucken sie so und dann gehen sie vor die Tür. Und während die sich wundern, warum die ganze Stadt dunkel ist, siehst du im Hintergrund Flugzeuge vom Himmel fallen. Weil natürlich Flugzeug ohne Strom heutzutage auch einfach runterfällt. Das ist eigentlich schon relativ witzig gemacht. Und dann zeigen sie wieder so ein paar Wochen später und dann gibt es natürlich Nahrungsmittelknappheit und dann fangen die an, sich richtig zu kriegen. Und dann gibt es so ein paar Leute, die sich da so ein bisschen stark machen und dann so Milizen gründen und so weiter und so fort. Das finde ich eigentlich sehr interessant. Irgendwo bauen sie wieder irgendwelche Love-Romances ein und so ein Quack. Aber das Grundkonzept, sich mal vorzustellen, wie sieht es eigentlich aus, wenn hier einmal von heute auf morgen einfach mal das Ding aus so nicht alles, was mit Strom ist, einfach mal ausknippt.
Ist es das, wo da auch eine Folge in einem Güterzug spielt oder so was?
Ist jetzt nicht herausragend, aber ich finde das Konzept, wie gesagt, mal ganz interessant.
Na ja, wie kommen sie hoch? Also ich meine, wenn sie so hochkommen wie so ein durchschnittliches Unix. Ich meine, ist doch auch so, selbst wenn man Mac OS X heute...
Dann müssten sie erst mal einen FSCK machen.
Aber ich meine, habt ihr schon mal so ein Unix-Computer beim Booten zugesehen und dem kompletten Lock-Fall folgend?
Klar, der Teil.
Irgendwann mal etwas hochkommen sehen ohne eine Fehlermeldung?
Also du meinst jetzt pro Run-Level oder?
Nee, nee, nicht pro, einfach Booten. Einschalten, zack, ASCII dran, zugucken. So, dann bootet das Ding irgendwie hoch und es ist immer irgendwas, kann nicht eingeschaltet werden, kann nicht gesenkt werden, kann nicht gesenkt werden.
Genau.
Ich glaube V, V for Bose. Oder so was, oder ein Apfel, irgendwas.
V ist es glaube ich, oder?
Genau.
Aber auch da kommt immer Fehler mit.
Ja, irgendwas haben die immer zu maulen.
Es ist einfach irgendwie immer alles scheiße. Diesen Computer, dann kannst du nämlich eigentlich nichts recht machen. Und mit dem Government ist es nämlich ähnlich.
Du meinst, es kommt auch nicht ohne Fehler wieder hoch?
Ja, dem kann man es zumindest nicht recht machen.
Es ging ja nicht mal ohne Fehler runter.
Die beklagen sich regelmäßig per Post bei mir. Ja, sie haben da rumgestanden, da zu schnell gefahren. Also echt, manchmal kann man die Republikaner schon verstehen. Was? Diese Republikaner, ich meine, der hat doch diesen US-Shutdown angesprochen. Diese Republikaner sind völlig absurd. Ich meine, wenn sie an der Macht sind und der Staat sind, dann fahren sie das auch so mega aus. Ja, hier mal ein paar Länder überfallen und voll draufhalten. Und wenn sie in der Opposition sind, maulen sie mal rum, dass der Staat zu stark wäre.
Wobei, ich glaube, wenn es um Krieg geht, dann sind sie sich ziemlich einig alle.
Obama ist da kein Cent besser.
Also auch so in der Bevölkerung, die sind alle so gegen hier starker Staat und Föderalismus ist ja super, aber wenn es um Kriege führen geht, dann sind sie glaube ich alle geeint und gehen in die Kirche.
Stay behind our truth.
Das ist merkwürdig, wir verstehen das nicht. Aber darüber wollen wir heute auch gar nicht reden. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau...
Warte mal, da wird über IPv5 und IPv6-Adressen diskutiert im Chat. Das ist ja spannend. Da hat jemand in der Tat mal eine Telekom IPv6-Adresse, die er da hingemalt hat.
Ach, du meinst die von neuen, modernen Anschlüssen?
Die Telekom hat ja sogar noch einen ziemlich coolen Hack drin, wenn du nämlich mal guckst, wo wir gerade so dabei sind.
Es gibt ja... Das ist das Spiel bei...
Nee, die Telekom... Will er ja nicht machen, die faule Sau. Aber die... Es gibt ja diese berühmte Reverse-Mapping im DNS. Das heißt, ich schmeiße eine IP-Adresse rein, und dann kommt ein Name raus. Das ist jetzt für die Leute, die einen etwas größeren Adressbereich haben, wie zum Beispiel so eine Telekom, ist das ja ohnehin schon spannend, selbst bei V4. Die müssen ja für jede ihrer zig Millionen IP-Adressen, die sie haben, irgendwo einen Namen haben. Viel spannender noch ist es bei V6-Adressen, weil der Provider gibt dir ja maximal nur die Hälfte der Adresse und die anderen 64-bit, die sorgst ja selber aus den Fingern. Das heißt, selbst wenn man wollte und das auch dateigestützt machen würde, wie normale Reverse-Mapping, wäre das einfach ein riesen Zonenfall, das macht natürlich keine Sau. Also gibt es da so einen Hack für, ich hab mir auch mal selber einen geschrieben, nämlich einen, der V6-Adressen zu Namen mappt. Und die Telekom hat sich auch sowas gekauft. Die rechnet nämlich einfach den Namen aus, die guckt nicht den Namen in der Database, sondern der schmeißt eine Adresse an den Kopf und die rechnet sich den Namen aus und spuckt den aus, anstatt den nachzugucken. Das macht so ein normaler Nameshow aber nicht.
Management Summary?
Management Summary ist, es gibt, pass auf, das TLDL bitte. Die Telekom bemüht sich, ernsthaft, es gibt Leute innerhalb der Telekom, die sich ernsthaft bemühen, das mit dem V6 voranzubringen. Allerdings werden sie immer wieder von anderen Abteilungen sabotiert. Und zwar sowohl von ihrer Politiktechnik Abteilung in Münster, das sind nämlich die, die so technische Politikentscheidungen treffen, zum Beispiel mit wem pier ich und wann und warum, mit wem, wo leite ich meinen Verkehr lang. Das ist ja dieser Tage auch gerade in aller Munde, weil die Telekom jetzt angedroht hat, wir machen deutsche Routen, nur bei deutschen Netze, oder wie so was war die Ansage. Und da denkt natürlich die Presseabteilung, na da springen wir nochmal drauf. Und die Technikabteilung, die das eigentlich durchführen sollte, ist da eigentlich nicht so... Jedenfalls tun sie es nicht. Wie immer. Wenn die Telekom ein Mensch wäre, müsste man sie wegen Schizophrenie einsperren.
Wollen wir mit dem Thema gleich durchstarten?
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Okay, dann ist das jetzt eine Anquenierung.
Wollt ihr das V klein?
So recht?
IPv6 wird mit kleinem V geschrieben.
Ja, finde ich schon.
Jaja, die Freak Show, wo IPv6 mit kleinem V geschrieben wird.
Mach erst mal deine ganze Mobile Max Reminiscence-Serie, den ganzen Apfelquatsch und so.
Ich wollte einfach mal das Team vorstellen.
Wir haben mal neue Zugänge.
Also der, der immer die selben Nasen hat.
Nee, aber ich finde, man muss sich ja auch...
Was liegt denn an dem viel zu vielen Zucker in deiner Quasselbrause?
Da habe ich ja nichts für. Also, hallo?
Willkommen zur Sendung nach 15 Minuten Quatsch.
Wir sind langsam warm. Also, Clemens ist schon ziemlich warm durchgestartet. Unser Turbo.
Wer hat dir diese Schokolade geschickt?
Genau, wer hat dir denn das geschickt hier?
Du hattest den Zettel in der Hand. Wo hast du den hingetan?
Nee, Dennis hat den zensiert.
Dennis hat den schon aufgegessen.
Dennis hat den zensiert.
Da hatten wir doch ein Paket dazu. Wo ist denn das Paket dazu?
Fassen wir mal über Max. Ich stelle mal die anderen Nasen vor hier.
Also das Paket, das hatte ich selbst ver- selbstständigt auch.
Da ist es.
Letztlich war es wieder da.
Soll ich vorlesen?
Ja, macht das mal irgendjemand von euch.
Also, äh, wir danken dem Volk der Südniedersachsen und dem speziellen Mike für die Übersendung mannigfaltiger Schokolade.
Er schreibt aber nicht, dass er zum Volk der Südniedersachsen gehört. Er schickt nur von dort die Schokolade.
Aha.
Weil sie da hergestellt wurde?
Nee, die hat er aus Berlin.
Das bringt uns jetzt in die Bredouille, aber wir grüßen trotzdem die Südniedersachsen.
Südniedersachsen? Was ist denn das für ein komischer Begriff? Südniedersachsen.
Ich finde das besser als Ostwestfalen.
Ich frage mich bei...
Ich frage mich immer, bei Westfalen gibt es auch ein Nordfalen, ein Südfalen, ein Ostfalen? Nein, es gibt nur ein Westfalen, aber dafür gibt es einen Ostwestfalen. Ich wusste noch nicht, was es in Südniedersachsen gibt. Naja, nun...
Also man kann schon im Süden von Niedersachsen sprechen oder einfach die Wahrheit sagen, Göttingen.
Auf jeden Fall wollte uns der Mike Nervennahrung schicken, damit wir auch bei diesen ganzen verschiedenen Themenkontexten, die wir hier die ganze Zeit öffnen und schließen, nicht den roten Faden verlieren.
Ja, das ist sehr freundlich.
Ich will auch nochmal, bei unserer letzten Sendung, die schon vier Wochen her ist, da haben wir ja auch hier so Schweizer Schokolade gegessen, da kamen wir die große Büsse, die war so geil, da war da Nüsse drin, die man tatsächlich auch als solche erkannt hat. Weil bei vielen Schokoladen sind die Nüsse nämlich irgendwie nicht mehr so doll, die sind so ein bisschen angebittert und dann denkt man sich alle, klar so schmecken Nüsse, aber nie so schmecken Nüsse eigentlich gar nicht, weil wenn die richtig schick und frisch sind, dann schmecken Nüsse eigentlich ganz gut.
Kann man diesem Hörer nochmal einen Flatter-Button auf die Stirn kleben und dann, dass da ein paar Leute draufklicken und er uns nochmal so eine Ladung schickt oder so? Das wäre die Idee.
Normalerweise bei Nussschokolade krieg ich irgendwie immer so einen Jucken im Mund, so kleine allergische Reaktionen vielleicht sogar und bei der war alle super.
Bio-Nuss.
Bio-Nuss. War geil.
Unbehandelt.
Also das war mal seit langem Schokolade, die mir mundete.
Voll auf den Nuss.
Aber die, die jetzt, die wir vom Mike hier bekommen haben, die ist natürlich auch lecker.
Aus Südniedersachsen.
Ist doch die Tatsache, dass Huckeken bitter mag.
Und in Berlin gekauft, dann nach Südniedersachsen entführt und dann räumtig wieder zurückgeschickt.
Unter unmenschlichen Umständen.
Gehalten.
Zu süß.
Ja, ist irgendwas passiert? Ich war im Urlaub, deswegen fiel ein bisschen was aus.
Also mal um zu rekapitulieren, unsere letzte Sendung war am 18. September, zwei Tage bevor das neue iPhone rauskam und genau an dem Tag als iOS 7 rauskam. Wo du Radio installiert hast live in der Sendung. Und jetzt wahrscheinlich voll Happy-Burst.
Ja, ich bin voll happy, dass ich es auf meinem iPhone 4 installiert habe und nicht auf meinem iPhone 5. Ja, happy, womit?
Der Typ, der übrigens e-mails quasselt hat, war Dennis.
Ja, hi, ich bin's mal wieder.
Ja, genau, Dennis. Wir stellen jetzt alle so sukzessive zwischendurch vor.
Dennis Wader.
Ich hab den Brief vorgelesen.
Oh, Update der Netz-Pistole.
Huckel hat den Brief vorgelesen.
Update der Netzbetreiber-Einstellung erhalte ich hier gerade. Das ist wahrscheinlich das O2-Update.
Na, welche Version hattest du denn vorher? Weil ich hab 15.2, wenn du jetzt gleich das Update hast und du hast was Neues, dann...
Bist du traurig.
Dann brauch ich das auch.
Es gab doch vor ein paar Tagen schon ein Update, oder? Genau, aber da war ich gerade im Urlaub. Also da war ich...
Du weißt ja nicht, dass du die Netzbetreiber-Einstellung nicht kriegst. Außer wenn du eine andere SIM-Karte drin hast.
Ich hatte eine andere SIM-Karte drin und fand mich in...
Wie auch immer, ich hab die 15.2 von O2. o2.de 15.2.
Dann kann ich ja mal aktualisieren. Dann kann ich LTE machen mit meinem iPhone, was das nicht kann.
Dann kann ich wahrscheinlich angrinsen und sagen, unter iOS 7 mach ich das nicht.
Irgend so eine Bösartigkeit, ne? Vielleicht mach ich das später. Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Wir wollen jetzt mal gucken, ob der LTE auftaucht.
Auf dem 4er.
Auf dem iPhone 4.
Aber doch, stimmt schon. Das nennt man einen Negativtest. Wenn es auftaucht, ist das wirklich okay.
Aber kriegt man das jetzt nur? Für welche Geräte ist das jetzt?
Für alle.
Warum hab ich das auf meinem iPhone 5 nicht bekommen?
Kommt vielleicht noch, oder? Welche Version hast du denn? Ich hab 15.2.
Wo guck ich denn das nach?
Einstellungen, General About. Genau.
Info.
Ich hab übrigens mal festgestellt, früher. Das ist nur so ein Nebeneffekt. Wenn ich nachgeguckt hab, ist das so wie Schrödingers Katze. In dem Moment, wo du da nachguckst, kann es sein, dass in dem Moment kriegst du eine Netzbetreiber-Einstellung oder so. Sie fragen dann nochmal ab, ob das aktuell ist, was man da hat. War mein Gefühl, ich kann es nicht beschweren. Früher war das so, als guckt man drauf und denkt so, wieso jetzt?
Wahrscheinlich kommt heute live während der Sendung 7.1.
Also 15.2 ist jetzt hier auf dem iPhone 4 auch drauf. Vorher hatte ich wohl 14.0.
Oder so, das ist auch ziemlich alt.
Ja?
Na ja, mit dem 7.0 kam eigentlich 15.0, glaube ich.
Ja, mit dem 7.0, aber das hat ja dieses Telefon hier noch nicht gesehen. Also unter Umständen ist das auch nur unter iOS 7 dieses Profil, oder?
Ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht.
Wer weiß.
Die Betreiber-Einstellungen sind doch eigentlich OS-unabhängig, oder?
Du bist jetzt schon wieder so leise, Dennis.
Da muss ich wieder hier meinen Vader-Dings hier näher ranmachen.
Dennis hat einfach eine hohe Dynamik im Spre... Oder das Netzteil hat dieses... Vielleicht hat er das headset mit dem Wackler.
Jetzt hat der Wackler repariert worden.
Oder?
Ich finde aber auch, ich klingle ein bisschen dumpf manchmal.
Ja, das wackelt. Vielleicht bist du auch kompressioniert.
Wenn wir doch nur eine Stunde vor der Sendung hätten, um so etwas vorzubereiten.
Ja, aber Timme muss ja mit dir über SIP irgendwie hier telefonieren. Jetzt raucht das schon wieder unter dem Tisch.
Die Hörer müssen es wieder ausbaden.
Alles klar, dein Expander war zu hart eingestellt.
Oh, mein Expander ist zu hart.
So, jetzt haben wir es. Aber ich habe jetzt mal dein Expander gerichtet.
Das ist nur deine Fantasie, glaube ich.
So, aber jetzt mal auf den Punkt wieder. Also, i7 hast du jetzt installiert und bist jetzt happier, oder nicht? Oder doch?
Ich habe es auf meinem iPhone 4 installiert. Das ist nicht mein Primärtelefon.
Und du bist noch nicht happy, weil sonst hättest du es ja auch schon auf dein Primärtelefon installiert.
Ja, ich habe es mir halt auf dem iPhone 4 angeschaut, wie schlimm es ist.
Ja, und? Wie schlimm ist es? Ziemlich. Dann leg mal los, aber emotionslos bitte.
Ist doch langweilig.
Er ist mal langsam, das kommt schon später.
Er soll eh ein bisschen Melodic nutzt man jetzt mal.
Das ist ein guter Punkt. Was das bei mir auslöst, ist Emotionslosigkeit. Das nervt mich. Keine Emotion.
Also du hast jetzt noch beide. Du hast nicht so das Gefühl, wenn jetzt dein 5er benutzt, dass du da so ein OS irgendwie so aus dem, ja gefühlt aus dem letzten Jahrtausend, stimmt jetzt auch nicht, aber irgendwie so alt ist und irgendwie so komisch und so wie man es früher gemacht hat und das hast du nicht das Gefühl?
Also, kaum. Ich sehe schon, dass es einiges gibt, was irgendwie okay ist und der richtige Weg ist und so weiter. Das müsste man vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen genauer benennen. Aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die überzeugen mich einfach auch nach längerer Benutzung nicht.
Zum Beispiel?
Gerade wenn ich immer wieder das andere auch noch habe. Naja, also dieses iOS 7, das ist ja irgendwie so ein Blending des Betriebs des Tims in die Hardware. Also in seiner ganzen Gestaltung her sinkt das Teil irgendwie gefühlt in das Gehäuse rein. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen das Ziel gewesen. Na, die Übergänge. Du hast jetzt weniger. Guck mal, hier haben wir iOS 6. Da hast du oben dicker blauer Balken, dicker blauer Button, klares User Interface.
Und sie tun immer noch so, als wenn die Umwelt darin spiegelt, indem sie halt diese Wölbung da haben.
Ja genau, ich will jetzt nicht aufs Geogramm oder so hinaus, sondern einfach nur die Frage, wo fängt das Gerät an und wo ändert sich was? Ist das Gerät, was ich jetzt hier gerade benutze, der Bildschirm und sein Inhalt oder ist es alles? Und beim iOS 6 bis iOS 6 ist der Bildschirm und sein Inhalt und der Rest mehr oder weniger klar getrennt. Dadurch, dass ihr diese blauen Balken habt, das gibt es hier einfach so ein Definitiv. An oben und unten, da endet dann der Schirm auch. Wenn du dir iOS 7 anschaust, allein diese Gestaltung oben dieses Top-Bars, wo die Hauptfarbe nach oben hineinläuft und da irgendwie einfach flachere Übergänge hat, irgendwie, sie wollen, dass sich dieses Betriebssystem mehr in die Hardware einsenkt, dass es noch mehr eins wird. Und das finde ich eigentlich auch ein heeres Ziel. Aber sie gehen halt dabei so komische Kompromisse ein. Also die button, es sieht für mich aus wie HTML 3.2. Ja, blaue Links zum Anklicken auf weißer Seite. Ja, das ist so dieses Internet Explorer-Gefühl.
Aber die Schrift ist geglättet und…
Seit wann sind Browser-Fenster bei default weiß und nicht mehr grau? Welcher Browser hat das eingeführt? Netscape war lange Zeit immer grau. Und ab wann waren die weiß? War das der Internet Explorer auf Mac? War das der Internet Explorer unter Windows schon?
Gute Frage.
Aber das hat sich irgendwann geändert. Also alle meinten, erst mal so eine Seite müsste grau sein, bis dann alle meinten, so eine Seite müsste weiß sein. Das hat sich irgendwie bis heute gehalten. So, aber dieser Appeal von HTML-Seiten, der taucht natürlich hier auch auf und das ist auch nachvollziehbar, weil sie halt von der Schrift her denken. Mit dem neuen Typekit ist auf einmal das ganze Rendern von Fonts sehr viel einfacher geworden. Und mit ihrem speziellen Systemfront haben sie ja auch noch dieses Dynamic Type, wie nennen sie das? Dynamic Typography? Ja genau, wo sie vor allem so eine eingebaute Logik haben, wie wenn ich jetzt diesen Font größer mache, ab wann muss ich in eine andere Schriftart wechseln? Und nicht nur dieselbe Schriftart.
Das ist immer die gleiche Schriftart.
Nein, er wechselt dazwischen Helvetica Light und Ultra Light und nicht so Light hin und her.
Also das ist alles Helvetica Neue, aber das sind halt alles designte Schrift-Schnitte. Also für jeden Raster dieses Schiebereglers haben sie eine eigene Schrift gemacht.
Das heißt, es ist keine, die mal so durchberechnet oder hochskaliert wird, sondern das ist...
Ja, das haben sie bestimmt mal gemacht, aber dann noch von Hand nachgeputzt bestimmt.
Also du meinst, das ist nicht Finn und Ultra-Finn und weiß ich nicht und Light, sondern das sind wirklich ganz speziell für diesen Anwendungsfall gemachte Helvetica Neue Schriften.
Aber was du sagtest mit diesem weißen Hintergrund, ist das erste, was mir auch fehlt. Das ist sehr hell. Ja, nach der letzten Sendung habe ich den Ding den nachts angetickt und habe gesagt, lass dich noch mal nachts laufen, und dann Update machen und so was. Und nächsten Tag gucke ich dann drauf, weil ich habe da meinen Wecker auch drauf und dachte, wow, what the fuck. Das hat mich total angeblendet am ersten. Das hat auch bestimmt mindestens einen Tag gedauert, wo ich mich an diese Grellheit, die ich brauchte. Ich habe auch erstmal meinen ganzen Bildschirm hintergründet, die ich da schon seit Jahren drauf habe oder so, hat erstmal alle ausgewechselt, um mich dieser Grellheit sozusagen ein bisschen entgegenzustellen. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Aber da gewöhnt man sich irre schnell dran, finde ich. Also das war jetzt nicht so schlimm. Es war so ein, wir reißen mal kurz das Pflaster ab, Schmerz.
Ja, wenn man die erste Developer Preview installiert hat, dann war es ein bisschen länger, ein bisschen mehr Pflasterabschmerz.
Ein bisschen cool fand ich ja schon, dass du dir deinen Wecker stellen kannst und der Ding macht, lässt einen Update machen und der Wecker geht immer noch nächsten Tag. Also ist auch erklärlich, aber ich find's trotzdem lustig.
Ist aber gewagt.
War gewagt, ja.
Aber so was, ich weiß, wir kommen etwas vom Thema, aber so war es bei Mavericks auch. Ich hab da ein Update gemacht, dann hat er abgedatet, dann hat er Mavericks hochgefahren und dann gingen halt alle Programme mit allen Fenstern wieder auf, so wie es vorher war.
Das ist schon eine ganz interessante Experience. Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei iOS 7. Also ich hab jetzt hier nicht so einen fertigen Review in der Tasche und mir 30.000 Sachen notiert.
Wo ist eigentlich der John-Syracuse iOS 7 Review?
Macht der noch iOS?
Der hat so wie bis vor einem Jahr gar kein iPhone oder so.
Ich glaube, der hat immer noch keins.
Immer noch keins? Also ich hab ihn letztes Mal gehört, als er aufgehört hat mit seinem Podcast da. Und da hat er noch keins zu sehen. Auch schon wieder fast ein Jahr rum.
War es einfach nur so?
Ich bin jetzt wieder gespannt darauf, weil es ist immer der spannendste Ding, wenn eine neue S-Version kommt, alle immer so, ach ja und der Cursor wackelt jetzt mit dem Schwanz und da und toll und Oberfläche. I don't fucking care. Ich will wissen, ob die endlich mal den Körner in Ordnung gebracht haben oder ein Pfeilsystem gefingert haben und so was. Und so was liest er halt bei Syracuse. Deswegen warte ich händeringt darauf, dass der mal was zum Mavericks sagt. Vorher installiere ich das nicht. Ernsthaft? Weil diese ganze bunte Clicky-Kacke da...
Ich kann ja auch sagen, wann das Review rauskommt.
Genau, er hat es ja schon geschrieben. Er wartet darauf, auf den Submit zu drücken. Also, ist auch okay.
Bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei iOS 7. Der Versuch, irgendwie konsistenz zu sein. Woran kann ich mich nicht gewöhnen? An diese Tabs im Browser. Dieses Rotations-Dingsbums. Das ist voll praktisch.
Das ist doch voll super.
Diese Coverflow-Tabs.
Coverflow, genau, das trifft es ganz gut.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass es Sinn macht.
Man kann sehen und gleich die alle wegklicken, die so nerven.
Ich sehe halt jetzt von allen Seiten die Top-Level-Werbung. Ich schaue also sozusagen an so eine Registerreihe von Werbebannern. Das ist das erste.
Du brauchst die falschen Seiten an.
Zweitens, und das ist ein Kernproblem, wenn du in diesen View wechselst, dann... Ich hab das jetzt mehrmals probiert. Ich weiß nicht, welcher dieser Tabs die Seite ist, auf der ich gerade war. Also, wie sich das Ding irgendwie vor einem ausbreitet. Mal landet das Ding unten, mal landet das Ding in der Mitte. Ich muss immer wieder gucken. Immer wieder. Immer wieder, was, wo war ich gerade? Und das ist einfach so ein Bruch in der Continuity, in diesem User-Interface, das macht mich echt malig. Also, ich find, wie gesagt, ich sag nicht, es ist alles total scheiße und manches mag sich auch schnell so in die richtige Richtung entwickeln, aber ich finde, dass sie noch nicht so einen vollen Hit gelandet haben. Also, da muss nachgebessert werden.
Stimmt, der ist nicht immer unten der Neueste, sondern der, der in der Mitte auftaucht.
Ich hatte ihn aber gerade ganz unten.
Ja, aber dann war er ganz unten auch relativ in der Mitte vom Bildschirm?
Nee, aber es war der Letzte.
Während ihr euch noch am Design aufhängt, ich hab ganz bittere Erfahrungen gemacht mit iOS 7 auf dem iPad. Auf dem Telefon bereue ich es nicht, auf dem iPad schon. Ich hab einen iPad 3. Aber, nö, egal. Nicht bloß, dass es jetzt alle hakelt und ruckelt und so, gerade wenn man Videos abspielt. Ich muss alle anderen Applikationen killen, bevor die Video-Applikation flüssig spielt. Was da auch wahrscheinlich genauso scheiße ist, die haben sich total, die haben, das war schon immer krank, dieses iTunes und diese Video-Applikation. Ich gestehe jetzt hiermit offiziell, ich kaufe Fernsehserien, die ich schaue und bitte unter die nicht, weil mir das doch zu viel gefummelt ist. Ich leiste mir das einfach den 1,99 Dollar zu investieren.
Dir ist was zu viel gefummelt?
Da kann man mal sehen, wie scheiße das ist, aber das von iTunes ist fast schlimmer. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt wahrscheinlich auch wieder umstellen. Das ist einfach nicht so Stevemütterlich gemacht. Wenn Steve das gesehen hätte, hätte er das ganze Building rausgeworfen. Es ist so unglaublich. Es fängt mit ganz banalen Sachen an. Du fängst was an runterzuladen, dann gehst du in diese Download-Liste und obwohl ich so ein breites iPad habe, benutzen sie bloß keine Ahnung, 10 Pixel dafür oder 20, um hinzuschreiben, verbleibende Downloads. Und das, was man wissen will, nämlich die Zeit oder was auch immer, steht rechts davon. Da ist jede Menge freier, weißer Space, aber eben nicht das, was man da sehen möchte. Also sieht man ganz genau auch Titel oder irgendwelchen anderen Quatsch, das passt halt nicht.
Gibt es einen Einstellungen, da kann man machen, dass es wieder passt? Einfach auf Englisch stellen.
Die holen sich die Retina-Pixel jetzt wieder zurück, die sie uns vorher gegeben haben. Die investieren sie jetzt einfach in reservierten White Space. Du hast genauso viele Pixel wie vorher, nur anders verteilt.
Ich könnte in der Tat das iPad einfach wieder auf Englisch stellen. Der einzige Grund, warum ich mein Telefon und mein iPad vor Jahren mal auf Deutsch umgestellt habe, ist, dass ich mal dem versehen gegangen habe, diese Drecks Navigon-Software zu benutzen. Und da kann man alles einstellen, auch wie meine Oma heißt und wo die wohnt und so was. Aber da kann man nicht einstellen, dass ich trotz englischer User-Enterface gerne deutsche Straßennamen vorgelesen haben möchte. Ich kenne ja nichts dagegen, wenn sie wie gesagt Turn Right. Aber wenn du das Ding auf Englisch stehen hast, spricht die Stur die Straßennamen auf Englisch aus. Und das erträgst du nicht.
Ich meine, so eine Navigationsabweisung weißt du auch nicht, in welchem Land du bist.
Nein! Woher sollst du wissen, dass das eine deutsche Straße ist? Aber egal, ich verstehe es sowieso nicht, weil man braucht natürlich gerade Navigationsabsort, wenn man irgendwo hinfährt in ein Land, wo man eben nicht so richtig gut zu Hause ist. Und das ist besonders blöd. Gerade bestimmte Straßennamen aus dem Spanischen oder Schwedischen einfach Deutsch auszusprechen, ist so unglaublich dämlich.
Du kannst ja noch nicht mal jemanden nach der Straße fragen.
Wo du gerade das mit dem Musik-Abspielen hattest. Es geht um Videos. Und dann, pass auf, die verdienen damit Geld. Das ist unglaublich. Du musst mal früher auf dem alten iPad mit iOS 7 gegen iOS 6 einfach klicken. Du klickst eine Serie an und sagst ja, will ich gerne haben. Nee, nicht runterlagen, stream mehr mal. Macht mein iPad unter iOS 7 nicht mehr. Macht das einfach nicht. Ich muss anfangen, drunterzuladen. Dann muss ich die Video-Applikation killen. Was ja auch neu ist unter iOS 7. Mit diesem Ding Fenster oben nach raus schnippen. Doppelklicken und den Fenster oben rausschnippen. Dann kann die Video-Applikation neu starten. Dann kann ich den Download stoppen und dann spielt es. Das ist so unglaublich kaputt. Ach ja, und wenn man den fertig gespielt hat, bietet einem die Video-Applikation ja an, dass man die nächste Folge laden will. Und ich kann so oft auf den SD-Knopf drücken, wie ich will. Ich kaufe nämlich keinen HD-Quatsch, weil ich nichts zum HD-Abspielen habe. Er zeigt mir noch ein Dollar 1,99, will ich haben. Sagt er, ja, ich lade jetzt die 1,6 Gigabyte irgendwas runter. Und du denkst so, wie sie 1,6 Gigabyte, das ist doch HD. Guck ich nach. Obwohl ich auf Dollar 1,99 geklickt habe, für 2,99 die HD-Version gekauft habe. Und das finde ich echt, das kann ich reproduzieren. Ich weiß echt nicht, was sich Apple dabei gedacht hat. Das ist ja wirklich hardcore. Das ist ziemlich ergaun auch. Und da muss ich ganz ehrlich mal schimpfen, denn dann, das haben sie echt kaputt gemacht, das ging nämlich früher mal. Und wie gesagt, das Video ruckelt auf dem iPad 3, das ist jetzt, keine Ahnung, ein Jahr alt, anderthalb Jahre alt, oder sowas. Ruckelt, das stinkende Video von den von Apple selber. Jetzt nicht mal selbst aufgenommen oder konvertierte Scheiße, sondern das, was ich für teure Geld bei Apple runterlade, ruckelt, wie die Sau bleibt stehen, dann läuft nur der Ton weiter. Und dann so diese Effekte, die man von Skype vorher kennt. Ich rede von SD-Videos. Und dann dieser tolle alte Skype-Effekt, weiß nicht, ob ihr den kennt, die ja Sprache per TCP übertragen, als wenn, oh jetzt musst du das aufholen, dann fangen die plötzlich an, ganz zu schneller zu werden, rumzuzappeln auf dem Bildschirm, oder die Sprache, schnell! Das ist unglaublich, das ist abgründlich, was sich Apple damit erlaubt. Und wie gesagt, nicht nur, da ist ja auch ihr Kerngeschäft und da brüsten sie sich ja mal mit und alle Welt guckt ja auf ihren iPads eh nur Videos und so was, aber nicht mit dieser Applikation.
Das ist wirklich abgründlich. Das klingt jetzt für mich aber nach so einer Sache, die sich schon so mit den nächsten DotDot-Releases dann sukzessive... Ich sollte vielleicht keine Vorhersagen über Apple Technologie machen.
Wenn's schon jemand aufgefallen ist bei Apple.
Ja, irgendwie, ich halt's maul.
Du kannst doch in dem schnuffigen neuen Bugreporter mal...
Diese Applikation, die du angesprochen hast, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Die Musik-Up ist auch geil.
Die Musik-Up.
Die hatte ich das letzte Mal genannt, dass ich die Scheiße fand.
Hatten wir da auch schon das mit diesem Wiederholen zufällig?
Ja, ich hab gesagt, dass ich's nicht verstanden hab und dass es komisch aussieht.
Hier auf dem iPad, wie du gerade sagst, hier ist riesiger Weißraum, aber sie können das Wort Wiederholen nicht ausschreiben, sondern müssen wieder H-Punkt machen.
Und dann alle wieder H.
Das ist auch so windlosig. Das weiß ich nicht.
Von mir tut das weh.
Vor allen Dingen, es gab mal so ein schönes Icon dafür. Mit Pfeile in der Runde und so weiter.
Und Pfeile in der Runde mit einer kleinen Eins.
Wo einfach sofort klar ist, was Sache ist. Hier wiederum.
Habt ihr euch in der letzten Sendung beschwert, dass ihr nur Symbole voll blöd findet und so?
Weil ihr das nicht?
Wir gehören zur Generation Icon.
Das ist für mich das, wo ich skeptisch war und immer noch bin. Ich verstehe, warum sie auf Text gehen wollen. Und sie haben jetzt auch eine Menge gemacht, um das mit Text auch irgendwie hinzukriegen. Zum Beispiel diese Skalierung. Jetzt müssen ihnen aber noch was anderes gelingen. Jetzt müssen sie dieselbe Button-Fidelity erreichen, die sie auch vorher hatten. Wobei das ja nicht garantiert ist, dass der Text in Buttons immer gepasst hat. Also ich meine, dieses Bearbeitpunkt, das haben wir natürlich auch.
Eigentlich hat doch Apple dieses Auto-Layout, und dann sollte doch jetzt alles automatisch gehen und so.
Ja, aber wie das immer so ist mit Automatiken, die brauchen eine Weile bis hier.
Die bei Apple schon nicht hinkriegen.
Aber hier ist auch irgendwie so eine logische Nummer drin. Hier steht jetzt wiederholen, also abgesehen davon, dass da nur wieder H steht, steht da wiederholen. Und dann mach ich das auf, und dann kommen diese drei HTML-Zeilen.
Dieses komische Menü.
Genau, dieses komische Blase, was irgendwie aussieht wie ein Menü-Blatt.
Genau, und dann kriege ich das erste Mal einen Button, der so aussieht wie ein Button.
Ja, wenn du auf Titel wiederholen gehst. Wenn du auf Titel wiederholen geklickt hast, dann steht da auch Titel wiederholen.
Ja, dann steht Titel wieder H.
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade mal ignorieren. Also, es ist doppelt bekloppt. Also du klickst auf Titel wiederholen, dann steht da Titel wiederholen. Dann klickst du auf Wiederholen aus, und dann steht da Wiederholen. Also ich klicke auf Titel, also ich klicke auf A, und dann kommt da A, und dann klicke ich auf B.
Ich finde ja viel schlimmer, wenn du Titel wiederholen anklickst, dann steht da Titel wieder H, und dann sieht man, also für das Wort Wiederholen wäre eigentlich genug Platz. Aber sie schreiben trotzdem wieder H-Punkt.
Ja, aber ich wollte jetzt nicht so sehr auf diese bekloppte Text-Layout-Problematik mit der Abkürzung, sondern einfach nur, du hast da ein Pop-Up, du wählst A aus und kriegst B. Du wählst C aus und du kriegst C.
Du hast hier auf der einen Seite diese Buttons wiederholen neu zufällig und du hast auf der anderen Seite diesen Play vorwärts-rückwärts und dann hast du, also mein Daumen passt da dazwischen, also zwischen dem in der Mitte, der Text, der nicht ganz drauf passt, dann diese kurze Balken, wo ich scrubben kann und noch dieses Ding, wo ich lauter und leiser stellen kann. Und wie gesagt, rechts und links davon ist zu den anderen Buttons so ein Daumenplatz. Auf deinem Mini.
Was meinst du, was da erst für Daumen drauf passen auf einem echten Pad?
Ja, ich hab ja einen zarten Daumen.
Wie klein auch das Icon ist für das Album-Cover, so ein riesiges Album, das besteht im Wesentlichen aus Weiß. Das ist furchtbar.
In der Downloadliste kannst du nichts lesen, weil sie alles füllen mit ihren Keywörtern, aber den eigentlichen Content nicht mehr hinkriegen.
So, was probieren sie denn jetzt eigentlich? Sie versuchen jetzt in die Zeit zu kommen, in der wir immer mehr Tabletgrößen haben werden. Auch Apple irgendwie. Weiß ja gar ja, was sie vorhaben, ob sie jetzt irgendwie noch mal so ein riesiges iPad rausbringen wollen, mit dem man Steve Boymer erschlagen kann, oder was weiß ich.
Der geht von alleine.
Aber durch die Art und Weise, wie sie jetzt ihr Layout machen. So, aber das ist im Prinzip wie HTML. Ja, kannst du da Plus und Minus machen, dann ist die Schrift mal größer, und dann bricht es mal anders um und so.
Du, das gibt echt Ärger, wenn du hier HTML die ganze Zeit als Schimpfwort benutzt, ne?
HTML ist ja völlig in Ordnung, aber dass das jetzt so auf einmal so ein Browser-Appeal kriegt in seiner ganzen Verteilung, das finde ich problematisch. Jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, was gefällt mir eigentlich.
Uh, schwierig.
Da gab's irgendwie, äh...
Woran möchtest du lecken?
Ich überlege gerade, ob es irgendwas gibt, was mir wirklich gefällt.
Stille Tumble-Bees.
Weiß grad nicht. Also ob irgendwas wirklich besser, für mich besser geworden ist.
Wir haben noch schon mal festgestellt, dass bestimmte User-Interfaces und so und doch deutlich besser jetzt ohne den Filz und die Leder-Dicke rein und so irgendwie aussehen. Der Kompass.
Ja, trotzdem hat man schon das Gefühl, sie haben es einfach nicht hingekriegt. Also das hat schon was sehr einsnulliges. Und eigentlich fühlte sich das erste iPhone mit der ersten Software drauf nicht so einsnullig an.
Ich glaube, das ist nur vergessen seit sechs Jahren.
Warnlinien werden jetzt übrigens länger auch in höheren Zoom-Stufen bei Apple Maps.
Und was ich auch ganz absurd finde, ich weiß nicht, ob es euch mal aufgefallen ist, ist, dass auf den Sounds so fürchterlich viel Hall drauf ist. Moment. Mal kurz hier.
Auf dem Sound? Auf dem Sound wovon?
Auf allen System-Sounds.
Vorher war das ein knackiges Rack-Lack. Und jetzt ist es so ein Kack. Als würde ich irgendwie einen AK-47 in einem großen Raum, in einem großen Badezimmer durchladen. Also ich weiß nicht, das ist so.
Wo muss ich das denn noch mal einstellen? Unter Töne?
Naja, das ist ganz normal das Lockgeräusch.
Ja, Ton beim Sperren habe ich aber ausgeschaltet. So, jetzt mache ich das nochmal.
Da fehlt der Hall, davon abzusehen, dass es zu leise war.
Nochmal.
Achso, man muss es auch richtig anlocken. Jetzt haben wir es gleichzeitig gemacht. Das war jetzt auch nicht sinnvoll. Ich mache jetzt nochmal iOS 6.
Klack.
Du hast einen Hall drauf.
Du würdest trocken sagen.
Du ziehst deine AK-47 in diesem Raum hier durch und Roddy in der Tonhalle.
Das ist jetzt die gelungste Assoziationskette. Aber schön. Ist das bei allen so? Aber wenn wir uns jetzt schon über Klingeltöne unterhalten, dann wollen wir nicht weiter ein iOS 7 rumkritisieren, oder?
Das ist ja ein iOS 7.
Sag mir nochmal, was ihr richtig gut findet.
Also ich finde halt alles.
Ich finde, die sehen den At-the-beach-Klingeltun.
Nein, hast deine Klingeltun nicht.
Ich finde, da wo sie die neuen Fonts anwenden, zum Beispiel auf diesem Log-Screen und woanders auch zum Lesen, finde ich eigentlich ganz angenehm. Das ist von der Font-Auswahl her recht gelungen.
Ich finde auch so dieses ganze User-Interface ohne diesen, also ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich schick sogar.
Auch diesen Heutetap, oh man, das ist auch so eine Sache.
Heutetap?
Ja, oben von oben runter.
Wo es vorher gereicht hat, dir einfach ein paar Icons anzuschauen und du wusstest, wie das Wetter ist, musst du dir jetzt Text durchlesen. Mittwoch, 16. Oktober. Meist klar derzeit...
Ja, was stellt ihr das auch in Deutsch an? Also jetzt mal ehrlich.
Ist das jetzt die Sprache, mit der das Telefon mit mir redet oder nicht? Meist klar derzeit. Die Temperatur beträgt 7 Grad.
Oder auch nicht.
Semikolon. Die Höchsttemperatur lag heute bei 11 Grad.
Vielleicht ist es auch dunkel.
Ich meine, was muss ich mir denn hier an Text reinziehen, um zwei Informationspunkte aufzunehmen, nämlich 7 und 11, die man schön... Das soll ein Quick Info sein, dieses Teil?
Und dass es halt mostly clear ist.
Ja toll, aber das... Geschwafel.
Du benutzt dieses Ding oder was?
Nein, das ist unbenutzbar.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das Wetter von Apple war noch nie gut.
Es stehen drei Ereignisse im Kalender. Geile Information!
So genau will man es gar nicht wissen.
Das ist für mich eine Null-Information.
Für morgen stehen keine Ereignisse im Kalender.
Also bei mir zeigt er dir direkt an, die Ereignisse im Kalender.
Doch, für morgen.
Das hilft mir einfach nicht. Guck mal, zwei Bildschirmseiten, die füllen sie mit Geschwafel um zwei Zahlen, also dreiviertel des Bildschirms ist belegt, um mir die Information von zwei Zahlen mitzuteilen. Das kann doch nicht Ihr Ernst sein. Dann scroll ich irgendwie weiter, dann ist da nochmal ein halber Bildschirm voll, ein leerer Kalender.
Du, wenn du ein Nerd-Telefon haben willst, dann musst du dir ein Android holen und da selber Zeug machen.
Und dann steht da noch morgen. Es stehen drei Ereignisse im Kalender. Das erste beginnt um neun Uhr. Wieso kann dieses Gerät nicht einfach mir die nächsten drei Events einfach anzeigen?
Weil da noch drei Seiten dazu kommen sollen.
Das hat mein Nokia 710 oder wie der Scheißtal hieß, gemacht. Und das war praktisch. Du hast einfach die nächsten Termine gesehen. Und hier erzählt er mir einen Roman für nichts. Das ist doch wirklich, das geht gar nicht.
Aber es sieht schick aus.
Ach, das sieht nicht schick aus. Ich finde es nicht schick. Also ich finde es vertretbar. Warte mal, es geht ja noch weiter. Genau, jetzt im Safari. Was bitte ist das? Warte mal. Warte, der Safari.
Das ist den schicken Fullscreen-Mode, oder?
Jetzt musst du auch immer Google-Suche gleich benutzen, wenn du irgendwie...
Kannst du einstellen.
Du kannst dich nicht mehr zwischen Suche und URL unterscheiden.
Ich finde ja Unified Bar super.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich immer ans falsche getippt.
Das kann ja heute nicht mehr passieren. Die Blödsinn, dass du YouTube kommst, bei Google eintippst.
Der nächste Knaller, wo ich auch fast aus Pflaster geschlagen bin. Du machst in diesem Safari, gehst du irgendwie, tippst du oben in die URL rein und dann tauchen darunter deine Bookmarks auf. Also deine Bookmark-Diste taucht darunter auf. Und die Ordner sind Ordner, wie sie bei Mac OS 6 wahrscheinlich noch das letzte Mal aussahen.
Noch schick?
Schick? Das sieht ja aus wie ein Blackberry. Was ist das für eine... Ich meine, hallo, geht's noch? Ja, dann ist vor allem die Tastatur an. Das heißt, du siehst nur die Hälfte davon. Wieder ein unglaublicher Platz.
Was passiert, wenn auch so ein Ordner da raufläuft?
Wenn du scrollst, geht natürlich die Tastatur weg.
Irgendwie war das vorher mit dieser von links nach rechts durchnavigierenden Geschichte column-based, hat irgendwie auch wunderbar funktioniert. Also was sollen jetzt so komische Ordner-Symbole? Ja, Metaeben und in der nächsten Zeile E. Eine Platzverschwendung, das ist unfassbar, ja? Ja, dann geht er auf.
Zeig mal, ich hab keine.
Dann hast du da drin, dann hast du wieder deinen anderen View. Ja, also was ist auch alles gebrochen. Aber was war denn nochmal diese andere Idiotie? Warte mal, das muss ich mal kurz...
Jeder sind schon auf jeden Fall, also es fällt mir schon auch bei der täglichen Benutzung, dass da immer noch so ein paar komische Ecken dran sind, aber...
Dafür sind aber auch ganz viele Ecken, die iOS 6 hatte, sind jetzt dafür weg, sind jetzt woanders halt. Geht halt immer so, man ist nicht mit allen...
Sind jetzt woanders.
Naja, man ist halt nie mit allen zufrieden. Wenn ich mit allen zufrieden wäre, müsste ich ja nie wieder updateen. Das geht ja auch nicht, ne? Dann würde ich ja nichts mehr verdienen.
Aber wo ist denn das mit diesen Tweets?
Da war doch noch irgendwas...
Mit diesen Links, genau. Da war doch irgendwas in Safari. Ah, beende dich.
Beende dich.
Und sonst, die anderen Leute haben nichts zu sagen. Gibt es ja auch noch mehr Leute als Tim.
Wir haben ja schon ein paar... Also wir haben das ja eh schon seit eh und je drauf. Und ich finde es ja nach wie vor eigentlich ganz...
Ja, ich hätte mich daran gewöhnt. Aber ich meine, die Sachen, die Tim jetzt anspricht, die sind natürlich... Die habe ich natürlich verdrängt gehabt. Da sind so...
Sucht mal was im Browser. Und zwar auf der Webseite.
Geht das überhaupt?
Geht wie früher nicht?
Ja, nicht so. Sucht mal auf dem iPhone, mach mal im iPhone eine Webseite auf und dann such mal einen Text auf dieser... auf der Seite.
Also früher ging es ja so, dass man einfach oben wieder gesucht hat und hat nach unten gescrollt und hat dann gesagt, innerhalb der Seite suchen, richtig?
Guckt euch mal an, wie das jetzt aussieht.
Was sollen wir uns anschauen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es vorher aussah.
Mach mit deinem Safari mal eine Seite auf irgendeine und dann such mal einen Text auf dieser Seite. Mit deinem Mobile Safari auf dem iPhone.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie das geht.
Du musst oben halt...
Allein das ist schon ein Punkt, du weißt gar nicht...
Man tippt einfach ein und dann sucht man ja on this page und klickt dann wieder drauf.
Du musst dann mal teilweise erst mal hochscrollen, weil dann nämlich erst mal alle möglichen anderen tollen Vorschläge machen.
Das war vorher auch schon so.
Jetzt musst du halt auch noch deine URL übertippen, um dann da drin zu suchen.
Das meinte ich nämlich.
Jetzt weiß ich aber auch wieder, was ich meinte. Und zwar gibt es ja da unten noch diesen komischen Bibel-Icon. Oder was das sein soll. Du meinst die Bookmarks? Genau, diese Bookmarks. Ich weiß nicht, wonach das aussieht.
Ein Buch mit einer Schnur in der Mitte.
Sieht aus wie eine russische Fernsehantenne.
Oder so eine Brustbräuner. Die man sich so durch...
Du meinst diese Alu-Pappen?
Solar für zu Hause. Genau, so ein Teil, was du vor dich hinstellst.
Was so Leute in den 60ern vorsichtiger gehalten haben.
Das machst du jetzt auf und dann kriegst du eine Liste deiner Bookmarks. So weit in Ordnung.
So far so good.
Die gab es ja auch schon mal in dem anderen Ding. Wenn du eine URL eingibst, kriegst du die jetzt auch nochmal vor die Nase. Die dann irgendwie wieder was wegnehmen. Egal, dann hast du in der Mitte diesen Tab Leseliste. So weit in Ordnung. Und dann gibt es noch Add.
Shared Links meinste?
Naja, was? Also da tauchen Tweets auf.
Keine gesendeten Links steht da bei mir. Hier werden Links angezeigt, die Kontakte in ihren sozialen Netzwerken gesendet haben. Ich hab scheinbar keine sozialen Netzwerke.
Oder Kontakte.
Du hast deinen Twitter-Account auf iOS 7-Ebene nicht eingerichtet? Du hast nicht dem iOS 7 gesagt, hier ist mein Twitter-Account?
Äh, ich hab damit Apps darüber zugreifen können? Ich hab meinen Tweet Pocket angemacht und hab ihn benutzt. Ansonsten hab ich nichts gemacht, nein. Wieso?
Ja, ich hab das gemacht. Und dann tauchen da halt so Tweets auf.
Mit Links drin oder was?
Na ja, mit, unklar. Also mit Links, ja. Also Tweets mit Links. Aber auch, na doch, nur Tweets mit Links. Das heißt, die blenden quasi Tweets, die Links enthalten, haben einen wie, ähm, wie Bookmarks. Weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das auch gar nicht so eine doofe Idee. Ich war bloß sehr überrascht. Also du kannst sozusagen im Browser mal eben auf einen Link, der in deiner Timeline erschienen ist, klicken. Ohne das jetzt in einer Twitter abmachen zu müssen. Also sie verlagern die Links sozusagen explizit in den Browser rein. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so doof. Bloß da will ich nicht nur Twitter drin haben.
So schlecht waren die wohl mal gar nicht.
Was hat Apple jemals für uns getan?
Außer dem Equaduct.
Was denn?
Flash abgeschafft.
Ja, aber was hat Apple jemals für uns getan?
Sie haben den Internet Explorer rausgeworfen aus dem Betriebssystem.
Na ja, also da findet sich ja schon was, ne? Also stell dir vor, du hättest die ganze Zeit Windows benutzen müssen. Die letzten zehn Jahre Windows. Oh Gott, was wäre denn das aus dir geworden?
Ja, sie haben uns den Mac gegeben, das stimmt.
Thema, Thema die Dichte. Also ich bin nicht, total angewidert, aber auch nicht total überzeugt.
Ja, ich finde auch die neuen Ups, jetzt bemühen sich natürlich alle, irgendwie dem erstmal gerecht zu werden.
Wieso? Find my friends ist doch super.
Ja, aber dann updaten sie das endlich mal. Das ist so kaputt.
Nee, kaputt ist es nicht. Es sieht nur irgendwie aus wie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so das Interieur eines Lieds.
Hast du schon mal rangezoomt? Also ich weiß hier, der Typ zum Beispiel ist dieser Punkt, und wenn er dann draufklickt, dann wandert aber der Punkt da, wo eigentlich Huckel ist, wandert dann zu dem Punkt, wo ich draufgeklickt habe rüber. Also hast du es gerade gesehen? Also guck, ich klicke jetzt auf den Typen drauf, der diesen Punkt da darstellt, und wenn ich aber klicke, dann wandert der andere Punkt, was aktuell Huckel ist, wandert dann so rüber. Oder Karsten war es, mein anderer Kumpel. Also da fliegen ja die Punkte quer durch die Gegend. Nee, nicht alle haben das an. Also da können sie noch ein bisschen nachbessern. Aber das sind so Kleinigkeiten, ja, das sind halt Mini-Bugs.
Mini-Bugs.
Ja, aber du meinst, dass sie es jetzt auch für sich schon auf unterschiedliche Tabletgrößen vorbereiten. Und hatte ich ja auch schon mal gemeint, so mit allem alles so in Texte.
Du meinst, alles wird wieder dynamisch und so weiter, und dann können sie demnächst auch ihr 5 Zoll iPhone rausbringen.
Also dann sind wir halt mal wirklich jetzt bei diesem Resolution Independent Interface dann vielleicht doch angekommen. Allerdings um welchen Preis?
Da werden sie nicht mal auf dem iPad mit dem Wiederholpunkt irgendwie hinkriegen. Da ist ja womöglich genug Platz.
Da gab's so einen witzigen Spruch letztens im Twitter. Großmutter, warum hast du so große Hände? Damit ich das Samsung Galaxy Note 8.0 halten kann.
Also ich warte noch bis ich hier wirklich... Also ich warte noch auf den Tag, wo ich auch auf irgendwas stoße, wo ich mir denke, das würde ich unbedingt haben. Aber ich kann jetzt halt mit dem Browser besser arbeiten unter iOS 6 als mit 7.
Alle Icons.
Aber vor allem dieses Einstellungs-Icon.
Hübsches ist das nicht.
Das Einstellungs-Icon hat so was von Waschmaschine, wo man hinten aufgeschraubt hat.
Das ist eine Tretlage von einem Rennrad, sieht man noch. Also der Kettenwitz vorne.
Ja, da nimmt man ja auch mal Einstellungen vor.
Ja, vor allen Dingen hat man da eine Kette dran. Also ich meine, so ein Tretlager ohne Kette ist irgendwie auch so sinnvoll.
Aber das Schlimmste, was eigentlich passiert ist in der Zwischenzeit in Sachen Icons, ist nicht von Apple, sondern es gibt ja diese App Articles, die da so Wikipedia Frontend anbietet, war das nicht von dieser weiblichen iOS-Entwicklung, wie hieß sie doch gleich?
Aus München.
Wenny?
Genau, und das Icon hier von Articles, ich hab diese App einfach erst gar nicht gefunden, so irgendwie, wie, was ist das denn für eine App hier?
Sophistication.
Ja, und die hat jetzt irgendwie, aus irgendeinem Grund, hat die Icon so ein...
Hat die jetzt so ein komisches W gemacht. Das ist die einzige App, die ich nicht update deswegen.
Ja, das ist furchtbar. Ich hab das, also...
Na ja gut, die war irgendwann mal umsonst, da hab ich sie mir runtergeladen, bin jetzt aber weiterhin irgendwie begeisterter Wikipendian-Benutzer. Dieses Artikel hat mich nicht überzeugt, aber...
Ja, Wikipendian ist... Also, sie sind so head-to-head. Aber Wikipendian ist immer noch besser auf beiden Kapitel zu kaufen.
Also, was heißt ein schönes? Das hat zumindest ein konsistent, ein iOS 7-konsistentes Icon bekommen. Das kann man jetzt toll finden oder auch nicht.
Na gut, da zippen wir es. Sollten wir mal wieder Wikipendian mehr benutzen.
Das ist überhaupt sehr iOS 7-konsistent, dieses Wikipendian.
Ist es? Ach, das haben sie jetzt auch schon aktualisiert.
Ja, die waren eine der ersten. Also.
Also es ist kein totaler Fail. Es gibt nicht nur was zu meckern. Es ist gar nicht mal so scheiße.
Ja, aber was ist denn jetzt...
Lämpf.
Also dieses Ding von unten, wie heißt es noch gleich, das Control-Center, das ist natürlich total sinnvoll.
Gar keine Frage.
Das ist sinnvoll, aber bei mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu voll geräumt. Vor allen Dingen geht es mir immer so, dass ich die Taschenlampe anmache. Weil ich sie brauche.
Ach so. Ich dachte jetzt nicht absichtlich.
Nee, nee. Und dann irgendwann geht halt dieses Control-Center wieder weg. Weil halt... Genau, und dann ist die Taschenlampe noch an. Die ersten paar Male war ich etwas verwirrt. Wie kriege ich die Taschenlampe wieder aus? Das ist natürlich klar. Man drückt den Sleep-Button und schiebt das Control-Center wieder hoch. Aber wenn die Taschenlampe an ist, könnte das Control-Center da bleiben.
Ich hab eine gute Idee für die Sendung. Wir machen das große Licht aus, Dunkelheit. Und jeder, immer wenn man reden möchte, hält man sich kurz so her wie beim Grusel-Geschichten.
Die Taschenlampe ins Gesicht.
Das macht bestimmt eine ganz andere Atmosphäre, auch für die Hörer.
Und jetzt wieder mit den Bildern im Kopf, ne? Jetzt sehen wir aus wie die vier von Queen, während sie Bohemian Rhapsody singen. Wir sind aber fünf.
Nein, in dem Video sind es vier.
Wir fünf sehen aus wie die vier. Das geht auch mit fünf. Es gibt ja von Bohemian Rhapsody auch einen offiziellen Remix, den sie den...
Na?
Wie hieß denn noch der Film? Verdammt, du Scheiße. Ich hab schon wieder Hirnblockade.
Nicht so viel kiffen, Tim. Was? Test 1, 2, 3.
Wainsworld? Da sind sie zu fünft im Auto.
Fünft, tatsächlich.
Na, dann holen sie ja noch den einen Typen an der Straße rein und setzen ihn hinten rein.
Okay, Wainsworld passt wahrscheinlich eh besser, oder?
Wainsworld ist auch sehr lange her schon, dass ich das gesehen hab das letzte Mal.
Das ist toll. Was ich auch lange nicht verstanden hab, in dem Control Center gibt's ja das Icon für die Uhren-App. Aber da ist ja nur das für die Stoppuhr drauf. Das heißt, wenn man da drauf drückt, kommt man in der Uhren-App oder der Timer. Da kommt man nur zum Timer. Mich nervt das aber, weil ich meistens den Wecker stellen will. Da muss man immer erst zum Wecker umstellen.
Das hast du ja auf ganz hohem Niveau erzählt.
Das finde ich aber jetzt nicht so problematisch, weil der Wecker ist ja nun etwas, was meistens mit Aktionen in den nächsten Stunden zu tun hat. Ein Timer willst du so, oh jetzt schnell zwei Minuten, die Eier sind drin. Das ist schon was anderes.
Ja, wahrscheinlich das Gleiche mit dem Taschenrechner. Jetzt schnell ausrechnen, wie lange.
Find ich gut, aber dass auch eine Menge Sachen im Log-Screen angezeigt werden. Also zum Beispiel, wenn da ein Timer läuft, steht im Log-Screen auch, siehst du die ablaufende Zeit. Das war bei iOS 6 glaube ich nicht.
Und das sagten wir right now, it would take you 15 minutes to drive home.
Und er weiß dadurch, wo home ist, weil du da oft bist. Er stellt sich nämlich automatisch drauf ein, doch.
Warst du schon mal in den Einstellungen, wo du die Orte merkst, wo du so eine Karte siehst mit Kreisen, wo du am meisten gewesen bist? Am häufigsten?
Ist das auf allen Telefonen? Ja, wo ist denn das?
Also ich hab aber leider nur in Englisch. Also Settings, dann Privacy, ganz oben Location, dann ganz ganz nach unten, Find System Services, dann ganz nach Ortung, Ortungsdienste oder was?
Location Services, dann ganz unten.
Frequent Locations.
Oh, dann kann man raufklicken.
Kann man raufklicken und dann ganz unten History draufklicken und dann kommt da eine Karte mit den Orten und dann kannst du nochmal weiterklicken, wo du mal gewesen bist. Also Dennis hier zum Beispiel.
You lost me at Privacy. Datenschutz oder was? Ortungsdienste.
Ortungsdienste ganz oben. Dann Find my iPhone ganz unten.
Ach da noch ans Ende dieser Liste.
Mein iPhone suchen und dann?
System Services oder sowas. Genau unter Find my iPhone. Entschuldigung, nicht Find my iPhone.
System Services.
Ach da, Systemdienste.
Genau und da ganz unten wieder Frequent Locations.
Und da dann gibt es unten die History.
Ne, das hab ich hier nicht, bei meinem iPhone 4.
Hat er sich gemerkt, dass ich hier in Barcelona war?
Hier oder was?
Ja, da drunter gibt es eigentlich noch eins.
Dann gibt es nicht eins, was irgendwie... System Services bist du schon? Und dann heißt es Frequent Locations. Da muss man vielleicht was sortiert.
Zeitzone einstellen oder was?
Häufige Orte. Steht ganz unten, Häufige Orte.
Popular Near Me, das nicht. Doch, Häufige Orte.
Und den Verlauf kann man sich den Verlauf angucken lassen.
Wo ist das einsortiert, die Häufigen Orte bei dir?
Also bei den Systemdiensten, bei den Datenschutz-Ortungsdiensten. Dann runter, Systemdienste, noch weiter runter, runter, runter. Es ist, nee, nee, Quatsch. Da hab ich bei mir hier...
Zeig's doch mal an jetzt bitte.
Diagnosenutzung.
Zeitzone häufiger Orte.
Du hast die Lampe noch an.
Kann man aber an- und ausschalten.
Ja, aber dann kommt hier so eine Karte.
Erlauben Sie, dass sich Ihr iPhone merkt, welche Orte du warst. Wo, wenn wo?
Ja, aber das scheint nur beim iPhone 5. Oder vielleicht auch beim 4S?
Nee, klick mal auf den Namen.
Hast du das auch?
Ja, ich hab auch das 4S.
Nein, ob du auch diese häufigen Orte hast? Also wir halten fest, iPhone 4 hat das nicht. Alles ab iPhone 4S weiß, wo ihr wohnt.
Schweine im Weltall.
Das wissen die bei dir auch. Macht dir keine Sorgen. Macht dir keine Sorgen und macht dir auch keine Hoffnung.
Aber das, wo Home ist, das schreibe ich ja in meine Visitenkarte rein.
Was mache ich denn immer alle 14 Tage hier in Prenzlberg?
Ja, das ist krass irgendwie, das Protokoll. Das wusste ich noch nicht. Guter Tipp, Dennis. Also auf der A100 war ich einmal...
Und ich meine, die haben das jetzt schon in den Betas mehrfach überarbeitet. Früher hat sie die ganze Weltkarte bekommen. Dann konntest du auch rumzoomen in Deutsch und dann waren die Kreise auch noch rot. Und dann konntest du gucken, wo du überall so gewesen bist. Teilweise ganz gut. Dann dachte ich, ah ja stimmt, da waren wir ja auch und so. Und wo war nochmal der Eisladen? Na ja, ist klar, da.
Nicht so schlecht.
Aber ja, ich bin jetzt hier auch kein Post-Privacy-Spacko.
Wie man immer gerne sagt.
Meine iPhone hat mich dabei erwischt, dass ich bei IKEA war.
Die wissen alles von dir.
Häufiger?
Ne, einmal.
Ja, wenn du Schweden sehnst, hast du noch ein bisschen Schöttbullar essen willst.
Hier, Meringam 67 bin ich wohl in der Nähe am häufigsten oder oft. Ja, da ist der schicke Eisladen.
Du weißt doch, NSA steht für Next Step Apple, ne?
Genau, demnächst.
So, wollen wir mal wieder ein bisschen Fokus finden hier?
Ja, ich will noch kurz eine Sache erzählen.
Mit Bohemian Raps, die willst du den Fokus finden?
Und zwar gab es ja den Compass Gate hier eine Weile lang, wo sie meinten, der Compass würde nicht richtig funktionieren.
Beim 5S.
Ja, kann sein. Weiß nicht, ob die nur das IOS meinten oder die Hardware.
Das ganze Ding ist schief, glaube ich. Nicht nur fucking Compass, sondern auch die ganzen anderen Dinger.
Also meine Theorie ist, dass die halt erst mal hier einmal kurz durchkalibrieren.
Du bist ungeschickt.
Das macht man aus dem Handgelenk.
So, das ist halt, die wissen, glaube ich, nicht, dass man auch das Ding schräg halten kann. Und dann kann man den auf Null setzen. Und dann halten sie ihn gerade auf den Tisch. Und dann ist es natürlich falsch. Also man kann da hin und her schalten.
Die Leute, die das ausprobiert haben, haben das mit dem iPhone 4 daneben gemacht. Oder mit dem 4 und dem 4S noch daneben.
Ja, aber wenn sie außersehen mal bei zwei, drei Grad draufgeklickt haben, dann ist es halt verstellt. Die wissen es eventuell nicht. Und kommen durcheinander. Ist so meine Theorie. Bin mir natürlich nicht sicher. Bei mir ist es auch mal passiert, dass ich im Club saß, hab das so ausprobiert, dachte, das ist doch falsch und so. Der eine ist so, nee, der Tisch ist schon so schräg. Nein, der Tisch ist doch keine 8 Grad schräg. Bis ich gemerkt hab, man kann halt draufklicken und auf Null wieder zurücksetzen.
Und man kann schräge Dinge damit richten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das vorher schon ging. Man kann im Kompass sagen, er soll magnetisch oder geographisch Nord anzeigen.
Das ging auch schon früher immer.
Hab ich noch nie gefunden vorher.
Da war immer dieser E-Button oder was auch immer der Button hieß.
Ja, das ist es wohl in den Einstellungen.
So viel zum Kompass-Gate. Ob das jetzt ein bisschen verstellt ist oder ob die da falsch liegen, bin ich mir nicht sicher.
So redest du von der Wasserwaage im Übrigen, nicht vom Kompass.
Ja, aber das können glaube ich die Leute, die sich über sowas aufregen, auch nicht auseinanderhalten.
Für mich hier noch so ein kleines.
Dein Tisch ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich gerade. Ich bin versorgt, danke.
Beim Kompass kann man übrigens auch auf Null setzen. Da kannst du auch klicken und dann kannst du drehen und dann zeigt er dir an, wie viel du verdreht hast. Leute, die sich nicht trauen, öfter mal so ins Goal zu klicken, weil bei iOS 7 weiß man ja nicht mehr, wo man klicken kann und wo nicht.
Aber wo stellt man es dann zwischen magnetisch und unmagnetisch?
In den Preferences. Das ist auch so ein eigentliches iOS-Problem, dass ein paar Preferences innerhalb des Programms zu setzen und ein paar außerhalb zu setzen. Mal ist es so, mal ist es so. Bei manchen Programmen ist es sowohl innen als auch außerhalb.
Da haben sie ja auch keine neue Initiative gestartet.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das soll. Die wollten wahrscheinlich die Programmierer dazu nötigen, dass sie alle das außerhalb machen. Aber da haben sich die Programmierer nicht dran gehalten. Und jetzt hast du dieses Zwei-Schienen-System hier.
Das Problem an diesen Prefs in den Prefs ist auch, dass du da nicht so richtig viel machen kannst. Also kannst du im Prinzip nur eine Liste reinschmeißen, so nach der Art, was soll man denn einstellen können.
Ja, ordnen auf und so ein paar Werte oder sowas.
Genau, aber du kannst ja keine komplexeren Sachen bauen.
Also keine aktuellen...
Vor allem ist es halt, ich bin noch im Programm, wenn ich irgendwas wissen will, und ich will dann nicht aus dem Programm rausgehen, irgendwas einstellen und dann zum Programm wieder zurück. Das ist doch, okay, kann man mit Doppelklick und so relativ schnell hinkriegen vielleicht, aber es ist nervt trotzdem. Ich will das alles innerhalb des Programms machen.
Eine Erneuerung gibt es noch, die leitet dann sicherlich auf ein anderes Thema um, nämlich, dass es irgendwie als erwiesen gilt, dass Apple Multipass TCP in iOS 7 verwendet und zwar nur für Siri.
Wahrscheinlich testen die das erstmal an, ob es cool ist oder nicht.
Und dieses Multipass TCP sei a, noch relativ jung, wurde wohl angeblich wild bei diesem IETF-Meeting jüngst in Berlin diskutiert, wo du ja auch warst.
Da wird alles immer wild diskutiert und am Ende summen sie immer alle. Das wäre eigentlich schön, das sollte ich mal vorschlagen.
So wie bei der Republika.
Nee, das ist so, dass die machen Zustimmung per Akklamation, aber nicht durch Getrampel oder Tischgeklopfer, es gibt nämlich keine Tische, sondern die Leute summen immer alle. Ja, da wird gefragt, wir haben jetzt hier einen Vorschlag und wollen wir das jetzt irgendwie beschließen oder so? Und alle Leute, die dafür sind, sollen jetzt mal hamen und dann machen die alle so... Und dann wer dagegen ist, soll mal hamen und dann machen die alle so... Und dann ist das abgelehnt.
Das heißt, die machen das akustisch?
Die machen das akustisch, ja.
Dann gibt es da so ein Mikrofon-Array? Einfach nur so.
Aber da kann man auch laut summen. Und wenn der Chair das Scheiße entscheidet, dann schreien sie alle.
Aber man kann doch auch laut summen.
Ja, natürlich. Du sollst halt in der Lautstärke, also entweder gar nicht summen oder nicht.
Ah, du kannst sozusagen auch variieren, wie sehr du dagegen bist.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem, das macht der Typ, der die Frage stellt vorne, entscheidet nach seinem akustischen Eindruck, ob das jetzt angenommen ist oder nicht.
Tolles Verfahren.
Das ist ja echt interessant. Können wir ja auch mal probieren, oder? Gefehlt euch iOS 7?
Das ist doch mal toll, für jede ITF-Fanschätzung hast du ja immer ein paar Newcomer dabei. Da gibt es noch extra Orientierungsrunden. Meistens sind es irgendwelche Leute, die den neu hitten oder die sagen, ich bin jetzt mal Student hier in der Stadt, wo das stattfindet, jetzt kann ich mir das mal leisten. Geh da mal hin oder mein Lehrstuhl finanziert mir das mal. Und die gucken immer alle ganz verdutzt, weil die vorne diskutieren den ganzen Zeit irgendeinen Scheiß. Und dann plötzlich so, okay, if you hum now. Und plötzlich der ganze Saal so, hmmm, ein bisschen bekloppt. Das ist gut, das können wir ja auch einführen. Ich finde das gut.
Ja, hum now. Dann wissen wir jetzt mal genau, ob wir weitermachen wollen oder nicht. Aber dieses Multipath TCP ist ja auch noch so ein Propost-Standard.
Ich weiß gar nicht, haben die da nicht sogar schon einen RFC drauf geklebt?
Haben sie es schon abgebrummt?
Im heißen Artikel stand, das ist schon, gibt es einen RFC, der ist aber noch nicht angenommen, aber Apple macht schon so.
Dann ist das ein Draft. Also entweder, das gibt ja dann relativ feste Reihenfolge, wie die Dinge da sind. Aber eine Sache, die mir da dran nicht gefällt ist, dass, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, das ist ein RFC. Das heißt, es ist durch die ITF schon mal durch. Es gibt jede Menge Experimental Standards oder sowas, aber es gibt jedenfalls dafür schon mal ein offizielles Dokument. Das bedeutet, dass es auch schon mal mehr als eine Nase implementiert haben muss.
So, jetzt erklären wir nochmal kurz, was das ist. Es handelt sich hier um einen Standard, eine Möglichkeit von einem Gerät aus über verschiedene, unterschiedliche physikalische Netzwerkinterfaces.
Verschiedene IP-Adressen. Der Rest darunter ist erstmal…
Ja, okay, also über unterschiedliche IP-Adressen… TCP-Verbindung und nur TCP-Verbindung.
Also es handelt sich um eine Erweiterung für den TCP-Standard, den es ja auch schon seit fünf Minuten schon gibt. Da gibt es so Options, die man da machen kann, sind im Laufe der Jahre endlich hinzugekommen. Und das ist nun mal einer, der nun mal richtig wesentlich da eingreift, der einfach sagt, also es gibt da so eine Negotiation Phase, wo erst mal so ein Client an Server sich darüber einigen können, ob sie überhaupt Bock auf so eine Nummer haben. Und dann ist die Neuerung dabei, dass die beiden Gegenstellen mal zu raunen dürfen, dass sie nicht nur über die IP-Adresse, über die sie momentan miteinander kommunizieren, kommunizieren können, sondern auch über andere IP-Adressen. Zusätzlich, gleichzeitig, parallel. Mit demselben State? Mit demselben State, mit demselben Stream sozusagen. Man baut dann sozusagen nochmal so, ich weiß nicht, das heißt nicht Stream, das heißt, oh, heißt es Stream? Muss ich nochmal nachgucken. Dass man sozusagen mehrere logische Verbindungen aufbaut. Auch parallel bei Stream.
Haben die eigene Sliding Windows dann oder?
Ja, muss ja.
Ne, ja, ne.
Können ja unterschiedlich schnell seine unterschiedliche Fehlerrate haben. Also müssen sie ja auch unterschiedliche Sliding Windows haben.
Aber es geht doch nur darum, die Problematik schneller zu sein.
Du hast da oben immer noch TCP drauf. Und oben drauf hast du eine Applikation, die auf dem TCP drauf sitzt. TCP ist halt auch schon 30 Jahre alt oder noch länger oder 40 Jahre alt. Da darf sich nicht mehr richtig viel daran ändern. TCP ist eigentlich ein relativ stumpf Protokoll. Das ist nämlich einfach nur ein Byte Stream. Da gibt es auch keine Markierungen drin, sind keine Pakete drin oder sonst sowas. Einfach nur ein Rohr, wo du nacheinander Octets rein kotzt und die kommen drüben irgendwie wieder raus.
In der Reihenfolge.
In derselben Reihenfolge und flusskontrolliert. Und flusskontrolliert. Aber halt eben, du kannst zum Beispiel auf der einen Seite 10 Bytes reinschreiben und auf der anderen Seite kommen 2x5 raus. Theoretisch. Aber worum es jetzt bei Multiparts unter anderem geht, ist halt, dass du mehrere, sozusagen mehrere Layer 3s drunter haben kannst. Mehrere IP-Layer drunter haben. Ja genau. Ich glaube, man kann sogar V4 und V6 mischen. Muss ich nochmal nachschauen.
Ich wollte es nochmal kurz mit meinen Worten versuchen zu beschreiben. Also man versucht mehrere redundante Wege aufzubauen, um dieselben Daten in derselben Ordnung zu verschicken. Für solche Fälle, dass die eine der Verbindungen wegbricht. Und aber dann die Daten eben über den anderen möglichst schnell da hinkommen, wo sie hin sollen. Also du schaffst ja quasi vor allem Redundanz. Es ist egal, ob es über den einen oder den anderen geht.
Die Applikation, die oben drauf sitzt, die ändert den State nicht. Das ist ja auch das Thema. Alle möglichen modernen Protokolle, die du machst, gerade was so Mobilgeräte machen, die machen ja auch sehr viel basierend auf HTTP. Das heißt, die haben eine Applikation, die setzt selber auf HTTP auf. Die wiederum setzt vielleicht sogar noch auf TLS auf, auf ein Encryption-Ding, TLS, SSL. Die setzen auf TCP auf und das setzt dann auf IP auf. Und das, was sich die ganze Zeit ändert bei deinem Gerät, ist eigentlich nur der IP-Layer. Und das macht jetzt eigentlich keinen Sinn, wenn du jetzt eine Applikation hast, die eine Session offen hat, die einen Stater hat, die schon alles miteinander vereinbart hat, Schlüssel, Krypto-Schlüssel ausgetauscht usw. Das jetzt alles wieder abzubrechen und wieder neu hochzufahren, nur weil sich deine IP-Adresse unten drunter ändert.
Genau. Und du kannst aber auch mehrere Verbindungen parallel haben.
Und so nutzt es offensichtlich...
Ja, aber so nutzt es Apple offenbar, indem sie halt alternativ über das Mobilfunknetz auch ihre Verbindungen zu Apple halten, nur für den Fall Siri. Sodass, wenn du da reinquatscht, dass es egal ist, ob jetzt das WLAN gerade schneller ist oder ob das WLAN gerade in der Nase bohrt und irgendwie seinen Router nicht mehr findet oder sonst irgendein DSL-Down ist.
Das musst du auch erstmal merken, aber mittelfristig können sie, wie gesagt, ihren State und ihr Crypto-State alles erhalten und einfach mit Siri kann weiter in eine virtuelle Röhre rein spucken, seine Bytes und die kommen mittelfristig drüben an beim Siri-Server und zurück.
Das heißt, für das iPhone, der macht über das WLAN eine Connection und über das GSM, aber das kommt auch bei, sagen wir jetzt, im Falle von Siri, bei Apple bei dem gleichen Ding an oder auch bei drei verschiedenen.
Genau, exakt dieselbe Vermittlung.
Und der weiß auch, diese beiden gehören zusammen, also Gegenstelle ist immer eine.
Und jetzt mal klar zu machen, weil viele Leute, ich habe auch Tausende von Twitter-Dingern dazu gekriegt, weil alle Leute sehen dich jetzt als den Heilsbringer. Endlich kann ich meine DSL-Leitung wenden! Da sind sie immer noch alle hinterher, wie der Teufel hinterm Weihwasser. Aber man kann damit auch Loadbalancing und so was machen, aber erstens, es ist eine Kernel-Erweiterung, das heißt, du kannst jetzt nicht einfach mit deinem iPhone, mit irgendeinem Safari gegen einen beliebigen Web-Server reden. Und dann geht das irgendwie alles. Sondern beide Seiten müssen dieses MPTCP implementieren. Und das ist, wie gesagt, keine User-Library, die man in seinen Appadgen reinstricken kann. Das ist ein Kernel-Modul, das musst du in deinen Kernel reinmachen. Da gibt es experimentale Module, die wahrscheinlich auch von den Leuten kommen, die an dem RFC damit gebastelt haben, für Linux und wahrscheinlich jetzt offensichtlich auch für andere Plattformen.
Auch für Mavericks?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, die ich genau angucken werde, wenn ich zu der Q-Size Artikel lese bzw. selber mal mehr in Mavericks drauf installiere und dann mal gucke, was da drin ist. Da kann man nämlich relativ einfach sehen, ob das ist. Man muss das auf beiden Seiten erst mal richtig unterstützen. Das wird eine Weile dauern, bis die Leute das alle drin haben. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass du jetzt sagst, ich spiele jetzt MPTCP drauf, oder habe jetzt mein iOS 7, und deswegen streame ich jetzt wie Sau.
Wenn ich im Userland so ein Programm schreibe, weil du meintest, der ist im Kernel implementiert, dann muss ich doch sagen können, ob ich das Feature haben will oder nicht.
Ich denke, dass du das wie alle TCP-Optionen auch aus den Applikationen heraus beeinflussen kannst. Dass es also einen Kernel-Default gibt, und du aber als Applikation mit dem Socket-IO-Control sagen kannst, ich möchte das jetzt haben, ich möchte das nicht haben oder so.
Aber der Nachteil ist ja, weil ich es richtig verstanden habe, dass er immer parallel zwei Connections aufbaut. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier bei Timme sitze und wie Siri benutze, geht es zwar über das WLAN irgendwie schnell raus, aber parallel dazu schickt er über das GSM mir so ein paar Bytes raus, um die Connection erst mal aufzumachen und mehr macht er nicht, er öffnet sie nur.
Das gibt Apple auch selber zu, das gibt einen Whitepaper von Apple dazu, wo sie auch sagen, ja, das betrifft auch deine Mobilfunkzeugs und ja, wir benutzen auch ein paar Bytes von deinem teuren Data-Plan, aber wir präferieren das WLAN, solange es geht. Und erst dann, wenn das andere nicht geht, dann schicken wir wirklich einfach Daten über das Mobilfunknetz.
Und dann immer nur die paar Tiber Bytes, um die Connection aufzubauen.
Na, man kann jetzt vielleicht sogar nachrichten. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie groß die Option ist, aber wir müssen auf jeden Fall erstmal wieder einen SYN-Packet schicken auf die andere Seite. Das sind 40 Bytes, da kommt ein SYN-Act zurück, dann die Option jeweils immer mal drauf. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, für MPTCP werden das bestimmt irgendwie 8, 16, 20 Bytes oder so nochmal sein. Also die hauen erstmal so für so eine Verbindung, 200, 200, 300 Bytes oder so. Aber das ist ja nur Seriös, du wolltest ja auch mal gucken, wie viel Traffic da zu ist. Die Mobilfunkverbindung ist ja normalerweise relativ stabil. Wechselt hauptsächlich den WLAN, dass es entweder gar nicht da ist oder nicht, oder wechselt es zwischen WLANs hin und her, aber die Mobilfunkverbindung bleibt ja eigentlich, gerade bei einem iPhone, den ganzen Tag aktiv. Der bleibt ja so lange da, wie er kann. Nein, überhaupt. Die Mobilfunkverbindung mitsamt deiner IP-Adresse, die du dort hast, die ist ohnehin immer die ganze Zeit da. Das heißt, der macht die dann einmal auf zu Siri und der ist gut und wechselt sozusagen nur noch das andere Endstück, das WLAN-Endstück, das wechselt er immer aus. Du kannst auf eine MPTCP-Verbindung zur Laufzeit immer wieder neue Connections hinzufügen und alte raus schmeißen und so. Stehst du wie ich meine?
Ich kann dreimal Siri machen, aber die Connection macht er nur einmal auf.
Dein Siri sagt, ich möchte jetzt gerne mit meinem Siri-Server reden. Und ja, lieber Colonel, wenn du MPTCP hast, dann mach mal. Gib ihm. Dann baut dein Siri-Client eine Verbindung auf. Und zwar einmal hier über Tims WLAN und einmal über das Mobilfunknetz. Jetzt ist die Show gleich zu Ende. Ohnehin gleich zu Ende, ist ja schon halb zehn. Und dann gehen wir alle brav. Dann verlässt du das WLAN. Die Verbindung aus dem Mobilfunknetz bleibt aber bestehen. Das heißt, der ganze TCP-Stack, das ganze Siri und die Siri-Server-Client-Verbindung bleibt erst mal so, wie sie ist. Da passiert nichts. Die Applikation merkt davon nichts. Jetzt kommst du zu dir nach Hause, buchst dich in deinen WLAN ein, das iPhone merkt es, macht wieder eine neue Verbindung auf, per WLAN, aber unter dem Siri weg. Unter dem Arsch von Siri weg. Und so geht das den ganzen Tag. Nimmst du mal einen Feld weg, einer kommt hinzu, eine fällt weg, einer kommt hinzu.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo eine stirbt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eine andere schon da ist, gestiegen.
Das gilt aber nur für TCP-Verbindungen, die ich wirklich offen habe. Also du gehst davon aus, dass Siri den ganzen Tag eine offene Verbindung hält.
Und nicht, dass sie eine aufmachen, wenn sie sie brauchen.
Dass er nicht pro Siri versucht, den ich mache, muss er nicht eine neue Multipass aufbauen, sondern die ist schon noch da.
Das ist die Idee.
Also keine 300 Bits pro Siri-Benutzung, sondern nur 300 Bits pro GSM-Wechsel.
Oder WLAN-Wechsel. Jedes Mal, wenn du die Adresse wechselst, wird es auch gemacht.
Okay, über WLAN ist ja egal, und über GSM passiert es halt nicht so oft, meinst du? Dann könnt ihr doch eigentlich auch Multipass demnächst für iMessage mitmachen und alles darüber schicken und am Ende werden sie es einfach für die Notification einschalten, oder?
Deswegen machen sie das wahrscheinlich auch. Aber wie gesagt, du musst das auch auf der Gegenseite haben. Und jetzt kann natürlich durchaus sein, wie Siri bei Apple auf dem Linux-Server läuft, wo sie einfach dieses Kernel-Modul reingeladen haben. Und iMessage oder das Notification-Server ist jetzt noch nicht. Das ist jetzt alles Spekulation. Weiß ja keiner auf, was da läuft. Aber der Witz nochmal ist der, das ist ein Layer, der sozusagen im TCP mit drin steckt. Deswegen, den kannst du auch nicht im User-Land implementieren. Den kannst du nicht wie zum Beispiel SSL implementieren. Deswegen kann man es in eine Library packen, in eine Applikation mit rein, da muss der Colonel nichts von wissen. Aber für diese Feature musst du sozusagen an deinem Colonel rumfingern. Weil das ist ja auch der Einzige, der normalerweise weiß, wenn sich an deinen IP-Adressen was ändert. Also der weiß es zuerst.
Also der TCP-IP-Stack muss du halt können.
Also der Apple-Developer, das ist doch so, du kannst dich da auch registrieren als Applikation beim Mac aus X und sagen, wenn sich an der Internet-Zugangssituation was ändert, sag mir mal Bescheid. Weil das macht ja der Mail-Client und selbst das Safari macht. Du kannst ja ein Safari in Google packen und später erst die Internetverbindung aufmachen, dann öffnet er den Ohr.
Du kannst das sogar auf einen gewissen Server machen. Reachability heißt das. Du meldest dich deine Reachability auf einen Server an und wenn sich was ändert, kriegst du einen Callback.
Aber normalerweise, wie gesagt, der erste, der davon erfährt, wenn sich an der IP-Kollektivität was ändert, ist der Colonel.
Das musst du unter iOS sogar machen, weil Apple gerne mal sagt, hier die Applikation musst du unterstützen, dass das iPhone offline ist. Und da muss dem User Bescheid gesagt werden.
Okay.
Das steht irgendwo in den App Store-Dingern drin und sie haben wohl auch schon Leute abgewiesen deswegen, weil die das nicht implementiert haben.
Das ist echt eine der besseren Ideen in iOS. Das ist wirklich cool und ich wünschte mir das mehr für den Mac auch. Also so ein bisschen mehr On-Off-Awareness, das würde den Mac extrem gut tun.
Ja, die Schnittstelle ist ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, kratzbürstig.
Aber immerhin, früher war das halt so, du hast halt einen stumpfen Socket und du hast an sich, das war so die reine Lehre, dass die Layers nichts miteinander zu tun haben und dass natürlich eine Applikation gar nicht wissen muss, ob ein Linklayer da ist oder nicht. Was allerdings am Ende des Tages irgendwie Quatsch ist, weil du willst natürlich wissen, ob du Konnektivität hast oder nicht oder ob sich daran was ändert. Und deswegen finde ich das schon ganz okay, dass man das da eine ordentliche Schnittstelle findet. Aber du sagst, die ist nicht so ordentlich.
Die ist ein bisschen schwierig zu benutzen. Also es ist halt so ein C-Ding mit, ja, also es ist nicht so schön. Nicht so schön Coco, wie man das so kennt, aber...
Jetzt um die Management Summary. Alle Leute jetzt so, ah, NPCs, geil! Ah, der Heilsbränger! Nee. Aber nett. Ich finde es auch cool, dass das Apple, die ja wirklich auch mit einem Pack von Leuten immer so auflauft auf der ITF, da nicht immer nur irgendwie dooflige Politik macht, sondern auch immer sagt, oh, das finden wir mal cool, das hauen wir mal einfach mal in unser Premium-Produkt mit rein. Das ist ja schon mal eine Aussage. Das gibt sowas auch mal einen Push. Vorher, die fünf Leute, die das mit Linux machen, da geht kein Hahn nach. Aber wenn jetzt Apple das einbaut, richtig regulären ihre Produkte und spätestens wenn das mit Mavericks kommt, dann wirst du sehen, dann wären diese Treiber oder Betriebssystem-Ad-Ons für MPT-CP und die Unterstützung in den Applikationen dafür oder sowas, die wären dann natürlich ganz schön hochgehen.
Was ich mich jetzt frage ist, wenn ich jetzt unter iOS eine Connection aufmache zu einem Server, der das kann, habe ich das jetzt in iOS 7 dann auch schon in meiner App?
Wenn du Siri heißt, ja.
Also meinst du, das ist nur für Siri einschaltbar?
Ähm, musst du jetzt die Entwickler fragen. Also nochmal, alle anderen TCP-Options, die es gibt, gibt es ja noch jede Menge. Du kannst da noch Passcodes und Timestamps und la la la und was weiß ich nicht, alles mit anmachen. Die haben alle einen Kernel-Default. Das ist das, was der Kernel macht, wenn du einfach nur sagst, gib mir einen Sockel. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Options. Und du kannst sie immer noch einzeln an- oder ausmachen. Und ich vermute mal, dass es ebenso für MPTCP genauso ist und dass Apple sich einen Kernel-Default ausgewählt hat, der jetzt erstmal sagt, nichts, und das Siri explizit anknipst.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn du Netzwerk machst unter iOS, dann machst du es meistens auf einen Abstraktionslayer, der von Sockets sowieso relativ weit weg ist.
Kommst du an einen rohen Socket eigentlich ran? Offiziell, ohne, oder heißt es wieder, oh, er hat die API nicht benutzt, draußen aus dem Store?
Das kann ich dir nicht aus dem Hut sagen, weil ich wüsste jetzt nicht, warum ich das tun sollte, aber... Aber wenn du halt sowas machst wie diese neue URL-Session, wo du halt irgendwie, also, hat dich das schon mal erklärt? Da gibt's so einen Prozess, der läuft so im iOS, und du kannst quasi über eine relativ sinnvolle Schnittstelle kannst du da Downloads reinkippen.
Downloads reinkippen heißt, du sagst, hier ist ein All, laden wir immer irgendwo hin, oder was?
Und dann kann das iOS die abkillen, und der Download läuft aber weiter, weil er in diesem speziellen URL-Session-Prozess läuft. Und wenn der Download fertig ist, dann weckt dich das iOS im Hintergrund wieder auf und sagt dir, übrigens, dein Download ist fertig. Hier ist mal deine File-System-URL, wo du das Ding dir von woanders hin kopieren kannst. Und also, keine Ahnung, wenn es da irgendwo einen Multipath gibt, dann ist es tief versteckt in irgendwelchen anderen Klassen.
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, wie gesagt, so Api-Quatsch ist nicht so meins.
Es gibt keine große Hurra, wir können jetzt Multipaths.
Also, sagen wir mal, es ist jetzt vielleicht noch nicht anknipsbar oder vielleicht ist es demnächst anknipsbar, wenn es anknipsbar ist, dann ist es eine coole Sache, gerade wenn man so spezielle super mobile Apps schreibt, die extrem davon abhängt, dass du schnell immer wieder umschalten kannst.
Es spart hier auch Bits und damit auch Strom. Weil, wie gesagt, es geht ja nicht bloß darum, die wenigsten Applikationen setzen heute nur auf TCP auf, sondern haben eben, weil es ist ich, einen Encryption-Layer dazwischen, dann noch einen HTTP-Layer, sind eingeloggt, haben einen Session-Kontext und so weiter und so fort. Und das alles, jedes Mal wieder neue Räte zu etablieren, wenn man eine Änderung der IP-Konnektivität hat, geht halt auf die Dauer auf die Batterie. Und wenn du diese Dinge einfach halten kannst...
Da muss ich dich aber widersprechen. Also Apps, die die ganze Zeit Connections halten, sind eher die Ausnahme. Normalerweise hast du eine API, wo du sagst, ich will jetzt was haben, machst ein Request, kriegst einen Response und dann war es das wieder.
Ja, aber in Push-Situationen. Wenn du auf was reagieren musst, was von außen kommt.
Ja, deswegen sag ich halt, das sind die wenigsten Apps, die sowas machen können.
Ja, aber warum, ist doch blöd. Lass die doch ruhig einen TCP-Layer offen haben. Jedes Mal, wenn du wieder anfängst, den ganzen SSL und TLS neu aufzurollen, bei jedem Ding, ist ein wahnsinniger Austausch von Paketen. Je nachdem, was du für eine Latency hast auf deinem Mobiltelefon, eine saue Zeit, musst du jetzt mal drüber nachdenken. Also allein um eine TCP-Verbindung zu etablieren, brauchst du drei Pakete, dreimal hin und zurück. Jetzt machst du einen SSL-Layer drauf, wo die Zertifikate ausgetauscht werden und bla und hin und her sind nochmal sechs oder acht Pakete, die da hin und her gehen, bevor du überhaupt erst mal ankommst, dein HTTP-Header-Request da rein zu drücken. Bis dahin haben wir immer noch kein 1-Hit-Byte-User-Daten übertragen. Und das jetzt jedes Mal zu machen, finde ich relativ albern. Das finde ich viel sexier, das Ding aufzuhalten, in der Keep-Alive-Session die ganzen Crypto-States so zu erhalten, wie er ist.
Deswegen hat Apple die Push-Notifications eingeführt, damit man nicht alles offen halten muss, sondern die wollen die Klappe halten und warten, bis sie ihre Push-Notifikation bekommen.
Man muss ihnen sofern Recht geben, wenn du tatsächlich mehrere Requests an die gleiche URL schickst, dann macht das Apple alles für dich, der hält die Verbindung tatsächlich offen. Aber das ist halt, wie gesagt...
Jetzt möchte ich mal mehrere Requests abgeben und mich zwischendurch mal bewegen. Ich hab nämlich ein Mobiltelefon.
Der Punkt ist, du kannst jetzt auch Push machen ohne Apple.
Ja, warum sollte gerade Apple das jetzt featuren?
Ja, das Ding ist nur, wenn die App nicht mehr läuft, also nicht mehr im Vordergrund ist, dann kann sie halt auch jederzeit von Apple abgeschossen werden.
Aber da könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, das ist ja denkbar, wie mit den anderen Sachen, dass man einfach sagt, hallo Colonel, hier hab ich ein TCP-Socket oder einen offenen Socket. Wenn da drauf was zuckt, sag mir mal Bescheid, ich geh mal so lange weg. Und du wirst dann wieder geweckt, wenn das Ding wieder da ist.
Und ganz ehrlich gesagt, wird auch nicht kommen, weil ich nicht glaube, dass da draußen genug Developer sind, die sowas sinnvoll programmieren können. Die meisten werden einfach zu viel Akku damit verbrennen und damit ist das Feature gestorben.
Okay, da gibt's eben Leute, die meinen, dass man direkt auf die Socket zugreifen kann.
Das kann sein, wie gesagt, ich hab's noch nicht gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich geht's schon nur im Include-File, weil die Option irgendwie nicht mehr da ist. Man muss einfach die von Hand reinprobieren und dann geht's vielleicht.
Und dann verlässt er wieder den Part der offiziellen Ups und fliegt's wieder aus dem Store.
Ich hab seit den 90ern keine Raw Sockets mehr programmiert. Ich vermisse nichts. Das ist irgendwie, ne?
Wir in unserem Elfenbeinturm.
Eine kurze Nachfrage nach diesem Multipass. Inwiefern spielt ihr das jetzt mit solchen Sachen wie Verschlüsselung und so weiter mit?
Was für eine Verschlüsselung? Hipsack? Hipsack ist unten drunter. Es ist oben drüber. Sonst spielt es keinen.
Das sind ja auch dieselben Daten. Ich überleg nur gerade, gab's nicht auch so Szenarios, wo die IP-Adresse eine Rolle spielt?
Das spielt in der Tat eine Rolle, allerdings nicht auf demselben Socket. Es gab das gute alte FTP-Protokoll benutzt, zum Beispiel sowas. Da wird sich innerhalb des Protokolls über die IP-Adressen unterhalten, die man außen verwendet. Deswegen wurde durch die ersten NUT-Implementationen oder den FTP durch die ersten NUT-Implementationen gekillt und so was.
War das bei SIP nicht immer so?
Bei SIP ist das auch so, aber SIP ist eh nicht TCP-basiert. Aber das ist nochmal eine andere Liga, aber mit demselben Problem. Du hast immer das Problem, dass wenn du auf einem Protokoll dich über Informationen unterhältst, die außerhalb dieses Protokolls zusammenhängen, auf einer TCP-Session über die darunter liegenden IP-Adressen, dass da gerade im V4-Bereich durch NUT totale Irrungen und Wirrungen entstehen können. Also der FTP hat ja sowas gemacht, wie auf einem TCP-Socket gesagt, zu der anderen Seite, ruf mich doch mal zurück, meine IP-Adresse ist doch 1,2,3,4, mein Port ist 4711 oder so.
Weil die noch den alten Standard nehmen, wo man halt für die beiden Kanäle zwei unterschiedliche Ports benutzt, 20 und 21 sogar bei FTP.
Genau, 21 für den Command-Channel und 20 für den Data-Channel.
Aber es sind Programme, die TCP verbinden, ich versuche mich gerade noch mal ein bisschen in die App hier einzudenken, aber zumindest zum Zeitpunkt des Errichtens eines Servers und so weiter, Annahme einer Verbindung und so weiter, spielt ja die Absende-Adresse auch durchaus eine Rolle. Wenn die sich jetzt ändert, unter dem Arsch, also bleibt die alte dann erhalten, auch wenn die Verbindung nicht mehr da ist?
Nein, das ist ja gerade der Punkt. An dieser Stelle, normalerweise merkt eine Applikation von Multipart TCP nichts. Außer, wenn sie halt wissen möchte, mit wem red ich denn da drüben. Also zum Beispiel selbst ein normaler Web-Server, der gerne in sein Log-File mal reinschreiben möchte, mit wem man da redet. Für die Leute ist es natürlich mega spannend, weil du hast jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr nur eine Adresse, die zu dir connectet, sondern N. Und die ändern sich auch noch während deiner Session. Möglicherweise. Das ist natürlich, an dieser Stelle, schon ein Brainfuck für die ganzen Leute, die da loggen und machen und tun.
Kann man zur Laufzeit von dem Socket nochmal die Absenderadresse rauslesen? Oder kriegt man das?
Ganz normale Option. Get-Pier-Adress, Get-Pier-Namen.
Und wodurch ist die dann definiert bei Multipass, TCP?
Das Zeug ist relativ frisch. Man müsste sich jetzt mal angucken, wie es die Leute mit ihrer Linus-Implementation gemacht haben. Dann wäre z.B. die nächste Frage, kann ich mich registrieren auf einem Socket, dass der mir Bescheid sagt, dass der mich antritt, wenn sich Multipass unten irgendwas ändert. Damit ich dann noch mal, wenn ich hinzukomme oder wie auch immer, damit ich den in irgendeine Art und Weise loggen kann. Das ist natürlich auch der Nightmare. Diese ganze Nummer, wenn du dir das mal anguckst, die Leute, die das Multipass-Projekt gemacht haben, die stellen z.B. auch ein VM-Image zur Verfügung, wo sie alle möglichen Leute auf der Welt bitten, ladet das doch mal bitte drauf auf euren Rechner und lasst das einfach mal laufen, unter Virtual Box oder wie auch immer, damit wir mal ein paar Tests machen können, weil die wollen jetzt erst mal gucken, ob diese TCP-Optionen, die sie neu herzufinden haben, ob die überhaupt durch alle Firewalls und durch alle Router durchkommt, oder ob da nicht irgendwelche oberschlauen Deep Packet Inspector hingehen und sagen, äh, versteh ich nicht, schmeiß ich mal weg. Das heißt, das ist auch noch nicht so ganz sicher, inwiefern das jetzt überhaupt die gesamte Netzinfrastruktur überlebt. Deswegen ist es z.B. auch so implementiert, dass so ein MPTCP-Stack, wenn ihr eine neue Verbindung aufbaut, macht ihr die Optionen mit rein und probiert dann, kann man einstellen, default so dreimal erstmal so einen Aufbau mit dieser Option und wenn das irgendwie nicht klappt, dann macht ihr das Ganze nochmal, dann vergisst ihr das ganze Zeug und macht das alles nochmal im alten State. Weil er dann glaubt, da ist irgendeine Firewall dazwischen, die eben das ganze Zeug kaputt macht, nur weil er überhaupt diese Option drin hat.
Also muss alles noch erforscht werden und ist alles noch nicht ganz klar.
Ich will ganz kurz sagen, für die Leute, die jetzt glauben, dass sie sich damit jetzt endlich, ich hab meine drei DSL-Anschlüsse, ein Megabit, krieg ich jetzt endlich drei Megabit zusammen, theoretisch ja, in den nächsten Jahren nicht. Sucht euch was anderes.
Aber praktisch ist, wenn die eine DSL-Connection gerade ihren Reconnect hat, macht er auf der anderen schnell weiter.
Aber du kannst die eben nicht bündeln, auch das über nochmal, nur das mal grundsätzlich sagen können bitte. Es ist ein Unterschied, du kannst, wenn du mehrere Anschlüsse hast, kannst du darauf Load balancen. Das ist wahnsinnig einfach, aber damit kriegst du nicht die Summe hin. Was viele Leute ja wollen, ist das sagen, ich hab jetzt hier meine drei VDSL-Anschlüsse, krieg jetzt endlich mal ein Download mit 150 Megabit hin. Nein, kriegt ihr nicht. Ihr kriegt von drei Applikationen jeweils 50 Megabit hin. Kein Problem, aber ihr kriegt nicht die Summe hin, wenn ihr nicht noch ganz anders saubert. Vergesst es einfach.
Dann schließen wir das Thema glaube ich mal ab. So, jetzt stehen. Also ich würde gerne hier über das noch reden und das noch reden, bevor wir vielleicht auf die Frage kommen.
Ich verlink mal nochmal hier so einen Multipass.
Dann sag ich mal kurz, ich war neulich mal versehentlich im Apple Store. Da lagen total zerfetzte, da war glaube ich witzigerweise an dem Tag, ich war nämlich doof, ich wollte eigentlich was zur Reparatur bringen und auch Teile holen. Ich bin genau an dem Tag dahingelaufen, da lagen, und ich war relativ früh da noch, Apple Store Berlin. Release vom iPhone 5S, an dem Tag, war ich denn da irgendwie um 11 oder halb 12 oder so was.
Bisschen spät aufstehen.
Ich habe nicht dran gedacht, dass das iPhone 5S da rauskommt. Ich wollte was ganz anderes, ich wollte auch kein Telefon da kaufen oder irgendwas. Jedenfalls lagen da aber zerfetzte Typen am Boden und so was, die waren einfach völlig rund, die waren komplett überrannt worden und so was. Und was echt krass war, in der Mitte stand ein riesengroßer Tisch, der war fast voll mit 5Cs. Das wollte keine Sau haben, offensichtlich. Die haben mir die 5S aus den Händen gerissen und alles überhaupt. Du kannst auch heute noch hingehen, da steht immer noch der Tisch mit denen voll mit 5Cs. Offensichtlich kauft die keine Sau.
Sie sind aber auch besser damit ausgestattet. Sie haben wesentlich mehr 5C auf Lager als 5S. Also hatten sie von Anfang an schon. Weil sie angeblich Probleme haben mit der Fertigung von denen.
Das ist eine totale Fehleinschätzung. Von dem Fingersensor. Die haben die so schön aufgebaut, in Gruppen, je nach Farbe. Und so, manche Farben waren, glaube ich, gar nicht angefasst. Weiße war angebrochen. Die Roten hatten so auch noch, da gab es zum Beispiel so ein hässliches Blau, da sah dieser komplette Block auf dem Tisch immer noch genauso aus, wie in der Nacht vorher aufgestellt. Also da will offensichtlich keiner. Ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt aussieht, aber damals dachte ich so, okay. Ein bisschen Fehleinschätzung, was die Marktakzeptanz davon angeht.
Hast du dann bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich mal das Ding angeschaut?
Ein 5S mal angeschaut? Ja, ich hab sie doch mit diesem Touch-Sensor da rumgespielt.
Hast du gleich mit deinem Fingerabdruck abgehoben?
Ich hab versucht, das Slow-Mo zu benutzen, aber es ist mir nicht so richtig gelungen.
Slow-Mo?
Wie hängt das eigentlich?
Na, es gibt, wie du halt jetzt diesen Square-Modus und Foto-Modus und Panorama-Modus hast, dann kannst du ein bisschen weiter scrollen und dann gibt's irgendwann den Slow-Mo-Modus. Und dann nimmt der Slow-Mo auf, aber irgendwie, ich hab's nicht verstanden, keine Ahnung.
Na, du nimmst halt dann den 27P auf. Ich dachte schon, wir hätten gar keins an Tisch hier.
Ist natürlich jetzt schon klar, dass wir das jetzt noch mal umreichen mussten.
Also Slow-Mo ist halt, du nimmst halt im Prinzip einfach Film auf, aber im speziellen Slow-Mo-Modus, der im Wesentlichen erstmal bedeutet, dass du halt nicht mehr 1080p Videos hast, sondern 27p Videos, aber die dann eben mit 120 FPS geschossen bekommst und danach kannst du dir das normal anschauen, was quasi ein Viertel davon ist. Und dann bestimmte Zeitregionen auswählen, wo du es eben, weiß gar nicht, kann man zwei verschiedene Langsamkeiten einstellen da.
Wie gesagt, ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Weil ich meine, 120 Frames, das erlaubt ja eine Menge Geschwindigkeitsprozesse.
Da oben siehst du deine Timeline und eine Stelle davon kannst du auf Slow-Mo setzen. Und wenn du dann drückst, dann speichert das so ab und schmeißt die restlichen zu vielen Frames weg. Also, weil er nimmt ja erstmal den kompletten Movie mit 60, 60 oder 120?
120.
Mit 120 auf. Oh, da sieht man aber auch kein Schwein.
Na doch, ich könnte es gelingen, dich mal zu benutzen.
Ja, ich habe es ganz vergessen.
Und der Ring ist auch schwarz, oder was?
Ist das immer so bei den Schwarzen?
Oder war da ein Adding-Antrag?
Ich dachte, der Ring ist immer... Ach so, golden ist er nur bei dem Weißen, oder was?
Nein, beim Goldenen.
Beim Goldenen. Beim Weißen ist er selber und beim Schwarzen ist er schwarz.
Ich habe übrigens vorhin in der... Ich habe vorhin in der U-Bahn eine Frau gesehen, die war sehr blondiert und die hatte ein goldenes 5S. Und da dachte ich, ah ja, genau.
Ich habe die noch nicht live gesehen, aber ich finde, das Goldene sieht irgendwie echt attraktiv aus.
Also ich habe sie live gesehen. Ich war ja an diesem Freitag morgens um 7.45 Uhr da, bin ich ja zum Kudan, bin am Townsien lang, da war schon ein O2-Laden, da waren schon Ballons draußen und lauter Leute dachten, oh Scheiße, wenn der O2-Laden hier schon so voll ist, ich habe ja schon so eine Ahnung. Und dann bin ich hin gefahren zum Apple Store, es war noch nichts zu sehen, weil die sind da hinter so einer Baustelle, siehst du nicht viel, und dann kam ich da und da war alles voll, dachte, oh meine Fresse, nee, hast ja gar keinen Bock, bin ich gleich wieder umgedreht und wieder nach Hause gefahren. Das ging gar nicht. Und ich sollte ja für den Starbug eins mitbringen, hier zum Touch-ID hacken, der meinte, fährst du zum Store? Und ich ja, alles klar, bringen wir eins mit, Farbe egal, und ach, Scheiße, auch bringen wir das Goldene mit, meint er, das Kleine natürlich, aber das ging an dem Tag gar nicht.
Dieses Cover.
Lass mich das mal machen, sonst machst du es falsch. Man muss das nämlich nicht oben rausholen, sondern erst unten, weil da die Buttons nicht stören. Also so mach ich das jedenfalls.
Ach so, verstehe, also da die Buttons.
Also ist meine Theorie, dann geht's nämlich relativ einfach.
Okay.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, das Space Gray. Von vorne ist es eigentlich so schwarz wie vorher auch. Und hinten ist es grau.
Was denn?
Lass mich mal anfassen.
Und der Rahmen ist auch grau.
Doch?
Nein. Nicht lecken.
Nicht lecken, Tim.
Ich will mal eine Vorstellung davon bekommen, was sie als Space Gray bezeichnen.
Sagt er unter seine echten Lichtlampe.
Ja, ich war an dem ersten Freitag, da war ich auch da, aber irgendwie erst spät Nachmittag.
Und war da schon entspannt.
Der hat schon abgewunken.
Ich kann meinen Finger nicht erkennen.
Und dann hab ich mir die Dinger angeguckt. Also standen ja auf den Tischen jede Menge. Und irgendwie hatten die das Ding, die haben ja hinten immer so einen Sicherungsteil, das kleben sie hinten dran, ne? So eine Diebstahlsicherung. Und die Diebstahlsicherung vom 5C war viel schwerer. Man hatte das Gefühl, das 5C ist doppelt so schwer wie das 5S. Ist es aber gar nicht. Das war, fand ich, nur ein netten Trick irgendwie, dass das 5S wirkt, das so total leicht.
Mal gucken, ob dieser famose, super, hyperduper Autoblitz ordentliche Farben macht. Der blitzt gar nicht.
Muss ich einstellen, Mann.
Hab ich eben schon gemacht.
Auf Auto. Sind beide an, aber...
Der ist aber unangenehm.
Jetzt scannt er erstmal noch.
Nee, jetzt macht er erst... Der Ding steht auf Video. Wieso stehen wir jetzt auf Video? Nee, ich steh auf Lomo, bitte.
Jetzt hast du mich Slowgemode.
Flash.
Ich hab aber beide an gerade. Ich bin gleich blind, weil er mich wieder hier... Jetzt hab ich... Bei meinen Augen sollen sie jetzt dran gewinnen, um dann einmal voll reinzuhauen.
Geht aber.
Ich find die Kamera ist ziemlich cool, also...
Ja, die Kamera macht einen guten Eindruck, muss ich auch sagen.
Ja, ich denke, dass vor allem auch die Kamera ist, die Leute zu den neuen Modellen zieht.
Und die iOS 7-Performance.
Ich als Nerd, 64-Bit natürlich, ne?
Ja, 64-Bit ist sowieso super.
Bitcoins rechnen auf dem 5S. Aber damit meinst du nicht, oder?
Nee, aber die Kamera ist schon cool.
Oder sehe ich, wie viel mein Pool gerade meint.
Okay, kommen wir doch noch mal kurz zu dem Touch-ID-Kram. Also, Starbug hat dann sein Telefon aus einer anderen Quelle bekommen.
Da musst du ja noch lange warten. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, war der erst Samstag Nachmittags im Briefkasten.
Deswegen hat es so lange gedauert mit dem Cracken, ne? Ich hab ja vorher gesagt, dass du das in den nächsten 7 Tagen machen. Wie lange hat der? Er braucht 3 oder so.
Er meint, der hat es im Briefkasten gehabt. Von Heise hat das ja irgendwie bekommen. Haben sie ihm eins per Post geschickt. Irgendwie hat er auch noch eins aus den USA mitgebracht. Bekommen wir auch immer, dass es so schnell ging. Jedenfalls hat er mir erzählt, er wäre eigentlich nach einer halben Stunde hat das zum ersten Mal ohne echten Finger geschafft. Aber da hat er halt den Fingerabdruck direkt vom Finger genommen, was man natürlich als Dieb nicht machen kann. Aber so grundsätzlich, das ging nach einer halben Stunde. Und dann hat er noch mal probiert mit Fingerabdruck irgendwie fotografieren. Das hat ein bisschen länger gedauert. Und das ging auch noch am Samstag oder so, glaube ich, relativ schnell. Aber es war noch nicht so schick, so einmal von zehn Versuchen. Das wäre noch nicht so cool gewesen. Und da meint er, er hätte veröffentlichen können, aber das war ihm nicht cool genug. Und deswegen hat er noch länger gemacht, bis es so fein war, dass es wirklich, weiß ich nicht zu, 90 oder 95 Prozent wohl mal geklappt hat und erst dann hat er veröffentlicht. Also so gesehen, hat er sich tatsächlich noch einen Tag Zeit gelassen, um nicht irgendeinen Schrott rauszuhauen, sondern hat was ordentliches rausgehauen und da hat er Glück gehabt, weil vier Stunden später kam er der nächste schon oder so, ne? Hab ich irgendwas gelesen. Ja, doch, da kam relativ schnell, nach ihm kam dann der nächste.
Mit derselben Methode?
Ich glaube, ja.
Auch mit so Platinen-Ads-Nummern?
Ja, die Berichte waren ein bisschen durcheinander. Ich hab's auch erst nicht verstanden. Manchmal war was zu lesen von irgendwie abfotografiert und dann mit Ausdrucken und Laser-Printer mit Dings und dann wieder mit Platinen-Ads. Also irgendwie war es nicht so klar, der Artikel war ein bisschen...
Für die Hörer, die jetzt immer noch nicht richtig mitbekommen haben, worüber wir eigentlich reden, also wir reden jetzt über Touch-ID vom 5S, von dem ich ja vorher gesagt habe, dass es dann wohl alles nicht so einfach sein wird, wie das bisher immer lief. Damit lag ich sozusagen komplett daneben. Starbug meinte allerdings auch, das wäre auch seine Erwartung gewesen. Und er sei halt sehr enttäuscht gewesen, dass es so einfach ging, weil er sich im Prinzip noch nicht mal was Neues hat einfallen lassen müssen, nur so ein bisschen mehr Sorgfalt, was die Auflösung betrifft.
Der braucht einen besseren Scanner, das war's glaube ich.
Was ich mich jetzt frage ist, dass Apple hat ja erstens behauptet, das wäre jetzt kein Fingerabdruckdingens, sondern sie würden tiefer gucken.
Ja, das tun sie wohl auch.
Und sie haben auch behauptet, der Fingerabdruck würde ja wohl das iPhone nicht verlassen. Oder zumindest den Fingerabdrucksensor. Jetzt frage ich mich, ob die Aussage auch gelogen ist. Und ob wir bis zum Kongress irgendwie die ersten ausgelesenen Fingerabdrücke kriegen.
Welche von den beiden Aussagen?
Die zweite, dass der Fingerabdruck nicht den Sensor verlassen würde.
Ich sag nochmal was zur ersten. Ich glaube, das allgemeine Missverständnis, dem ich da erlegen bin, und was Apple sicherlich auch so haben wollte, dieses wir schauen in die tieferen Hautschichten. Das stimmt, aber sie schauen nicht dahin, um was anderes zu finden, als das, was sie darunter finden, sondern sie schauen dahin, um da dasselbe zu finden, was aber darunter unter Umständen wegen Dreck am Finger nicht immer so zuverlässig erkennbar ist. Also wenn du dreckige Finger hast...
Den Satz hat da jetzt keiner verstanden.
Nein? Verstanden.
Aber Tim und ich sind eh auf der gleichen Welle.
Ich sag's mal total, ich sag's mal mit anderen Worten. Also, zur Sicherheit sparen sie sich sozusagen die äußerste Schicht, die nämlich auch dreckig sein kann. Und schauen auf die Schicht darunter, aber du siehst letztlich da dieselben Strukturen, du siehst da nicht irgendwas anderes. Sie scannen nicht deine Knochen und deine Blutbahnen und deine weißen Blutkörperchen und messen irgendwie, wie schnell die von A nach B rauschen.
Ich dachte, dass sie so ein bisschen tiefer scannen, um den Unterschied zwischen wirklich 3D-Strukturen und einem Bild unterscheiden zu können. Da hast du da halt eben kein Foto von einem Finger.
Toter Haut und lebendiger Haut, irgendwie sowas. Aber dem scheint wohl irgendwie nicht so zu sein.
Oder eben der Software ist noch nicht irgendwie auf Hardcore-Modus.
Ich glaube, hat er in der Sendung noch was über Chaos Radio zugesagt? Ich weiß nicht, ich hab ihn glaube ich auch gefragt und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, meinte er, also es wäre jetzt nicht wichtig, dass da ein Finger dahinter ist. Das geht einfach mit der Attrappe. Ich bin mir gerade nicht 100% sicher, dass ich ihn das wirklich gefragt habe. Zumindest wollte ich ihn das fragen.
Ich glaube, ich hab ihn auch gefragt und er meint, man muss es nur hinhalten, da muss kein Finger dahinter sein.
Ja, so. Mit anderen Worten, diese Erwartungshaltung, dass das irgendwie durch andere Methoden getäuscht werden muss, die hat sich so nicht erfüllt. Die Aufregung ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder so ha ha ha, wir haben euch herumgekriegt. Aber ich glaube, was so eine gewisse Wahrnehmungsstörung in dieser ganzen Debatte auch ist, ich hab das von irgendjemand anders gelesen. Er meinte, man sollte sich halt darüber im Klaren sein, dass man mit einem Daumenabdruck oder mit einem Fingerabdruck nicht ein Passwort liefert, sondern man liefert seinen Userleben.
Jaja, das ist klar.
Ja, also so wie man darüber über auch dieses Konzept Sicherheit nachdenkt. Und es ist schon klar, dass auch andere Leute unter Umständen in der Lage sind, denselben User-Namen Nachweis zu machen, selbst wenn der User da nicht da ist. Aber es ist sozusagen eine Convenience-Security-Funktion, die nochmal dazwischen ist. Die zwischen Code-Fragen und gar nichts liegt. Und da ist halt der Fingerabdruck.
Was ist das schon ein Wort für? Securvene-ty? Securvenience? Oder so? So wird es wie Infotainment?
Secuvenience.
Was vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Schlechteste ist. Also ich meine, mit der User-Experience war jetzt auch nicht so eine schlechte Idee.
Und du hast jetzt deinen Fingerabdruck da abgegeben, Dennis.
Nee, was ich mich frage ist, wie lange dauert es jetzt, bis sie wirklich an die Rohdaten kommen von einem Sensor? Ob der da drin ist, ob der tatsächlich im Sensor bleibt oder ob sie da auch gelogen haben. Und das Teil wird nur in einem dieser, wir hatten als letztes mal über diese komischen Exception Levels gesprochen. Und irgendwie dieser ganz untere hieß ja irgendwas mit Security. Und es kann natürlich sein, dass die ganze Erkennung da in diesem untersten Exception Level läuft, über dem dann der Hypervisor ist. Also wenn dem so ist, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass vielleicht in dem ersten Chip dieser Arm-Technologie auch irgendwo eine Sicherheitslücke ist, wo jemand vom obersten Exception Level in den untersten kommt und irgendwelche Daten ausliest.
Aber eigentlich brauchen wir noch die ganzen Exception Level gar nicht, weil wenn die NSA mit geheimen Gerichtsvorschlag zu Apple geht und sagt, ey rückt mal alles raus, müssen sie rausrücken, dürfen keinem was davon sagen, dann sind alle raus. Da brauchen wir doch auch nicht auf eine Lücke in der CPU zu warten.
Nein, ich meine, die Fingerabdrücke hat die NSA eh, wenn du einmal eingereist bist. Das ist jetzt nicht das Thema, sondern es gibt halt noch die sportliche Herausforderung für die Leute, die dann beim Kongress präsentieren als Erste, dass man da halt das Foto vom Fingerabdruck irgendwie auch direkt aus dem Telefon holt.
Also die allgemeine Vermutung, was ich so bisher gehört habe, ist, dass man aus diesen Daten, die da in dem Chip gespeichert sind, nicht einen Fingerabdruck rekonstruieren kann.
Sondern so was Ähnliches.
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht Hash-Funktion sagen, aber es ist sozusagen ein digitales Abbild, was der Erkennung, der Wiedererkennung dient und nicht der Reproduktion eines Fingerabdrucks.
Ja, aber je besser du, oder je näher du am Original bist, desto besser kannst du den Vergleich mit etwas tun, was halt auch nicht ganz das Original ist. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass so ein Finger irgendwie ein Stück Daten ist, was sich nicht ändert, worauf du einen kryptographischen Hash rechnen kannst. Sondern du machst ja immer einen Ähnlichkeitsvergleich, der halt so gut sein muss, dass du möglichst wenig Fals-Positives und möglichst wenig Fals-Negatives hast. Also dass du nur dann, wenn es übereinstimmt, halt auch ein Positiv kriegst. Und dazu musst du aber möglichst viele Merkmale dessen, was du ursprünglich mal gelernt hast, behalten. Und deswegen halte ich das nicht für unwahrscheinlich, dass sie auch tatsächlich die Rohdaten aufheben, um im Zweifelsfall überall die Rohdaten zu rechnen. Und mit so einem schnellen Chip, wie diesem 64-bit-Arm-Dingens, können sie das nämlich auch machen.
Das Wort, das du vorhin gesucht hast.
Das wäre für mich jetzt so die Argumentation zu sagen, sie rechnen garantiert in der CPU. Weil sonst können sie es gar nicht richtig ordentlich machen. Oder nicht besser als die anderen vorher. Weil da ist ja nicht irgendein langweiler 70 MHz-Arm nochmal in dem Touch-ID drin.
In dem Sensor ist das alles drin.
Ja, das glaube ich eben nicht. Vielleicht habe ich nicht recht, aber ich glaube es einfach nicht.
Na, das ist aber, sagen wir mal, diese eigentliche Erfindung von dieser Firma gewesen. Dass sie halt sozusagen diesen Chip gebaut haben, in dem das drin ist. Den sie immer weiter reduziert haben, bis er halt so klein und so stromsparend war, bis man ihn in ein iPhone einbauen kann. Aber ich sage jetzt mal überhaupt nichts Definitives. Sondern wir harren der Dinge, die dort kommen. So oder so ähnlich ist es auf jeden Fall gelaufen. Auf jeden Fall Gratulation an Starbug an der Stelle nochmal. Es trifft den richtigen. Und mit der Raumfahrt Agentur auch die richtigen.
Da muss man nochmal dazu sagen, da gab es auch so einen schicken Tweet. Also der Starbug hat ja, da gab es ja dieses, wie war das? Diese Spendenaktion dann, ne?
Ist Touch ID hacked jetzt?
Genau, da gab es ja so Spenden schon, die da schon reingegangen sind. Wer das zuerst macht, der kriegt folgende Kohle. Und der Starbug hat das ja woanders hin gespendet. Und dann meint irgendwer, dass es ja voll der coole Typ ist, der seinen Dings woanders hinspendet. Und dann meint hier der Tomz, da wer den kennt, dass die Leute mal Starbugs Auto angucken sollten. Dann wären sie noch viel mehr impressed, dass er die Kohle weggibt. Und wer Starbugs Auto kennt, das fand ich sehr gut. Noch eine zweite Sache zu Touch ID, da hat der Starbug mir auch gezeigt. Das gibt ein Video, wo ein Typ, man kann ja fünf Finger anlernen. Und übrigens, wer es noch nicht weiß, wenn man in diesem Anlern-Ding ist, wo dann Finger 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 steht, man kann dann Finger drauflegen und der Finger, der es ist, das leuchtet dann ganz kurz auf, damit man weiß, welcher Finger ist. Also, um es euch mal zu zeigen, was ich den Usern ja leider nicht machen kann, man geht hier in dieses Ding rein. Wo ist das Kack hier? In General, Fingerprint, da. Ach, scheiße, Passcode eintippen.
Kannst du mal dein Telefon mal hier... Ach so, du bist nicht im richtigen WLAN, scheiße. Sonst könnte man hier mal mit Airplay reinholen.
Dann kann man hier bei Fingerprints gehen und dann sieht man hier, ich zeige es dir mal, sieht man ja 1, 2, 3, 4 Finger, die ich gelernt habe. Und wenn ich jetzt irgendeinen draufhalte, dann leuchtet der mal so kurz, geht der so grau auf und dann weiß man, welcher welcher ist. Also hier lege ich den drauf und dann...
Kannst du die nicht auch benennen?
Nee, benenn nicht, aber du kannst sie wiederfinden, indem du sie kurz drauflegst. Und der leuchtet dann kurz grau auf. Und weil das steht halt nirgends, dass es so ist, das merkt man irgendwann durch Zufall. Hat der Starbug zum Beispiel auch nicht gewusst, haben wir an irgendeinem Abend mal kurz rausgefunden. So und was er mir noch gezeigt hat, ist, dass wenn man halt nur einen Finger beibringt, dann muss man den ja mehrmals drauflegen. Und es gibt so ein YouTube-Video, wo ein Typ einen Finger beibringt, also ist noch gar keiner drauf, er bringt einen bei und man soll den Finger mehrmals drauflegen und der Typ legt aber jedes Mal den anderen Finger drauf. Bringt dem Phone das bei, ist dann auch irgendwann fertig und ich glaube, er geht wirklich beide Hände durch, ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Und der hat dann nur einen Finger beigebracht und der kann dann aber mit verschiedenen Fingern sein iPhone öffnen. Das heißt, das iPhone scheint jeden einzelnen Finger-Dings, den du drauflegst, einzeln zu speichern. Also ich dachte mal, der kombiniert das zu einem großen Fingerprint zusammen, aber es scheint nicht der Fall zu sein, sondern er speichert die alle einzeln und guckt, ob es irgendwie passt.
Als wären es alle unterschiedliche wären tatsächlich, er nimmt da mehrere.
Das heißt, man könnte dem Ding auch sagen, Finger 1 sind die drei, Finger 2 sind die drei. Also könnte es schon dem alle 10 Finger beibringen.
Also mehrere Personen auch.
Ja, das sowieso, ja.
Ja, und vor allem, ich glaube, wenn er was erkannt hat, dann, und er merkt genug Ähnlichkeit, dann erweitert er sozusagen noch das Erkennungsspektrum während der Benutzung.
Das weiß ich nicht so genau. Das war auch so meine Idee. Das dachte ich auch, dass sie vielleicht live auch während ich das Telefon benutze oder jedes Mal, wenn ich es öffne, dass er wieder den Fingerprint einscannt, weil vielleicht ändert sich ja auch so ein Fingerprint von diesen feinen, das ja so leichte, kaputte Stellen und so in dem Fingerprint, wenn man da mal rangezoomt hat, da sind ja ganz viele kleine Einrisse drin, dass vielleicht die diese kleinen Einrisse benutzen, wenn die sich mit der Zeit ändern, dann nützt das auch nichts, wenn irgendwer mein Fingerprint hat, weil sich diese kleinen Verletzungen, sozusagen diese Defekte, sozusagen ändern und das iPhone kann die Defekte die ganze Zeit immer wieder neu mitlernen, während du das halt benutzt.
Dann wird aber die Polizei schon seit Jahren immer ins Klo greifen, wenn sich der Fingerabdruck so ändern würde.
Naja, nur die ganz kleinen Defekte, die Polizei hat den Fingerabdruck gar nicht und sind so ultra perfekt. Die nutzen ja viel gröber und dafür aber den ganzen Finger.
Was ich auf jeden Fall cool war, war natürlich auch klar, das hat nur eine Stunde gedauert, bis der erste natürlich seiner Katze oder seinem Hund oder sowas in die Hand gedrückt hat, und dann mit einer Katzenfoto jetzt sein Telefon aufmachen kann.
Wie kann man eigentlich mit iOS 7 hier den Fullscreen-Mirror anschalten? Können wir das mal einer erklären? Ich konnte doch vorher immer, da wo Airplay-Einstellung ist, konnte ich sagen, ich gehe mal komplett auf so einen Apple TV drauf.
Ich kann ja ein iOS 4 das nicht, äh ja dein iPhone 4.
Ja man kann die Finger auch, man kann ihnen auch Namen geben.
Warte mal. Oh ich sehe jetzt einen Mischpult. Neuerdings im Airplay. Der kann nicht Bildschirmsynchronisation machen. Meinst du so?
Mit dem Mischpult kannst du keinen Bildschirmsynchronisieren. Okay, dann ist das eine Einschränkung meines iPhone 4.
Ja, das konnte ja noch nie Bildschirmsynchronisation.
Das konnte es noch nicht.
Das konnte auch unter iOS 6 nicht.
Genau, das wollte ich euch jetzt gerade mal empfehlen hier zur Demonstration von iOS-Sachen. Dann sehen zumindest wir das. Na, das ist doch schön. Das ist schön.
Wir klauen uns hier gerade gegenseitig das Airplay.
Manchmal, dass er beide nebeneinander macht.
Das macht er eben nicht.
Für zwei farbige 2D-Flächen noch ein HD-Beamer.
Man hätte draufklicken können, aber so.
Oben hätte man so ein iPad, was sozusagen auf dem einen Beamer ist und auf dem anderen.
Da kannst du auch einen iPad eins an die Wand hängen.
Schaut in deine manischen Augen.
Die Uhr ist schon wieder weg, aber du kannst doch einfach ein iPad dahin stecken.
Warum ist eigentlich die Uhr da oben weg?
Weil ich die Uhr hier gerade als zusätzliches Dingsbums habe. Aber ich hoffe ja, dass die iPad-Minis jetzt schön billig werden, dass ich das mal an den ganzen Tisch machen kann.
Irgendwann müssen die iPhones und iPads, weil es jetzt noch fehlt, hier so kleine Mini-Beamer drin. Dass die so automatisch das an die Wand werfen.
Ja, die Projektor-Idee.
Kommt zuerst von Samsung. In schlecht. So, mit dem Fingerabdruckzeug hat Samsung Apple doch auch gerade mal so ein paar Wochen geschlagen, oder?
HTC hat das irgendwie hinten dann so drauf.
Was heißt ein paar Wochen geschlagen? Kam vorher raus, oder was?
Angekündigt vorher.
Gut, noch irgendwelche sonstigen iPhone-Erfahrungen, die wir der Welt hier noch mit der Welt teilen sollten? Ansonsten wollte ich halt auch ein bisschen so meine Unruhe zum Ausdruck geben.
Unruhe?
Naja, wir haben ja wieder perfektes oder sagen wir mal nicht so perfektes Timing, je nachdem wie man das sieht. Nächste Woche Dienstag ist dieser nächste Event. Bei dem es sein könnte, dass neue iPads vorgestellt werden. Bei dem es sein könnte, dass Mavericks vorgestellt wird. Bei dem es sein könnte, dass der Mac Pro vorgestellt wird. Oder...
Na da jetzt gerade Mavericks für Developer gesagt wird, die sollen jetzt ihre Mavericks Apps in den Store packen. Und das war beim letzten Mal auch eine Woche, bevor das iOS 7 rauskam. Sieht das ganz stark danach aus, als wenn dann da halt Mavericks rauskommt und das wurde...
Ja, aber kannst du dir einen Event vorstellen, wo sie neue iPads und einen Mac Pro vorstellen?
Vielleicht kommen gar keine neuen iPads?
Vielleicht haben die neuen iPads irgendwie einen Thunderbolt-Port und dann kannst du das direkt als Display anschließen.
Und vielleicht kommen auch gar keine neuen iPads. Aber ich glaube, dass Mavericks kommt und ich glaube, dass die Tonne kommt.
Die Tonne und Mavericks wird kommen, ja.
Und nur das?
Ja, und zwar mit...
Und iLife 13.
Na hoffentlich noch ein Mac Pro.
Aber das Ding, die werden es ganz groß bewerben als Made in USA. Ja, in Kalifornien werden sie sagen, aber sie werden auch andere States da erwähnen. Aber es ist halt das, was sie ja gemeint haben, dass sie halt eine gewisse Production irgendwie in Amerika machen. Ja, weiß ich wo. Ich würde sagen, man könnte es Made in USA nennen, aber ich würde behaupten, dass die das Made in USA nicht sagen werden, so in der Form.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder zum Prediction-Modus hier. Ja, Show-Noter, falls ihr irgendwie Predictions einsammeln wollt. Wir lassen uns dann testen. Wir hatten ja nicht so eine gute Quote gerade. Naja, also ich weiß, ich finde, iPad, vielleicht tun sie das jetzt, aber bisher, bisher haben sie das nicht gemacht. Also ich meine, Mac Pro ist so eine schmale Zielgruppe.
Ja, für die Millionen von Stücken für ein iPad, das könnten wir in Amerika gar nicht auf die Reihe kriegen. Deswegen so ein... bei den iPads. Und bei den Mac Pros, da verkaufen sie dann nur so ein paar Tausend, da kann man das schon mal machen.
Was kann man was machen? Ein Event?
Nee, in Amerika herstellen.
Ja, natürlich, klar. Ich rede jetzt nur davon, was stellen sie jetzt eigentlich vor und worauf müssen wir uns jetzt einstellen? Mavericks ist ehrlich gesagt das, was ich am meisten ersehne noch so. Das ist das einzige, was ich wirklich ersehne, glaube ich.
Warum?
Warum? Bist du heiß drauf?
Lad doch die GM runter!
Lad doch die GM runter, die gibt's doch nun schon seit zwei Wochen.
Ja, ich war aber auch zwei Wochen im Urlaub und hatte seitdem keine Gelegenheit.
Ich hab Mavericks heute Nachmittag mal draufgespielt. No risk, no fun. Und ich finde ja immer noch, die beste Neuerung von Mavericks überhaupt ist die Aktivitätsanzeige.
Ja, Batterie, ne?
Ja, Energie nennt sich das.
Ich finde die Aktivitätsanzeige voll scheiße, weil man kann überhaupt nicht mehr sehen, wie viel man jetzt runterlädt, weil er zeigt so ein schicken Grafen an, aber keine Werte dazu. Man weiß gar nicht, was es ist.
Na ja, dazu hab ich immer noch iStat-Menus.
Und dann guck mal bei deinem Aktivitätsmonitor, wie viel deine iStat-Menus an Batterie verhaut. Dann steht es nämlich da. Genauso wie nämlich hier SMC, ne warte, wie heißt es hier? SMC Fan Control, der sorgt auch für richtig fett Batterieverbrauch, also jedenfalls bei dieser Energieanzeige von dem Aktivitätsmonitor.
Also weit nicht so viel wie Safari und keine Ahnung, diverse andere Dinge. Die Aktivitätsanzeige selber auch.
Ja, aber das sind Dinge, die sich verbessern werden. Das zweite, wo ich so ein bisschen Hoffnung habe, ist das alte Rechner, die das jetzt noch laufen können. Also ich habe zum Beispiel noch so ein 2008er iMac. Mavericks läuft auch auf allem, was auch wo Mountain Lion liefst. Kein Gerät rausgeschlossen worden, soweit ich weiß.
Oder?
Und der 2.8.er kann 10.8.er rennen?
Ja, das ist das letzte Modell, was das kann. Die 2.7.er iMacs sind jetzt mit Mountain Lion alle rausgeflogen. Und die 2.8.er, das sind halt die Silbernen, die können das. Also mit schwarzem Rücken und so weiter, diese Generation. So, aber deren RAM ist sehr eng. Genau, und das ist sozusagen etwas, was ich mir erhoffe, dass hier mal wieder so ein Release kommt, was eben auf derselben Hardware deutlich besser läuft, als das derzeit mit Mountain Lion der Fall ist. Weil die Kiste, die swapt sich irgendwie immer wieder tot. Und das, obwohl ich da eine Fusion Drive gebaut habe.
Also ich habe hier 2,14 GB komprimierten Speicher.
Sag mal, Roddy, kannst du mal was in meinen AirDrop fallen lassen?
Ist das das, was gespart wurde oder was?
Obwohl, nee, nicht, da ist ein WLAN-Platt hier.
Na, er sagt was von virtueller Speicher, 11 GB, verwendet das Swap 0 und Speicher habe ich halt 8. Das heißt, irgendwie der Rest muss komprimiert sein.
Mach mal einen Share auf hier über Kabel.
Dann?
Dann hole ich mir von Roddy seinen letzten Song, den er gemacht hat.
Achso, den kriegst du jetzt.
Ja, weitere Sache, auf die ich natürlich dringlich warte, ist dieses Multi-Monitor-Handling. Also wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte, hier mal wirklich ab auf einen Monitor zu klebben, im Fullscreen-Modus, dann macht der Fullscreen-Modus für mich das erste Mal wirklich Sinn. Zumindest jetzt hier so bei einer Mac Pro-Situation. Also ich würde mir zum Beispiel noch einen vierten Bildschirm machen, der einfach nur so als Statusscreen ist und so weiter.
Die Grafik hat da doch mit Dreien schon Probleme.
Na jetzt nicht mehr. Nachdem ich es einfach mit Luft ausgeblasen habe. Ja und ich hab diese blöde USB-3-Karte rausgezogen. Vielleicht wäre dir auch das Problem. Die hat mir zwar diese USB-3-Ports hier, Dennis, das Teil, was du mir empfohlen hast, ich hab's nicht zum Laufen bekommen.
Na ein Kumpel von mir hier hat gesagt, es geht, du hast das Kabel einfach, du hast keinen Strom drauf gekriegt, richtig? Wahrscheinlich ist der zwingend.
Ich muss ja wirklich noch Strom dran machen, stimmt, da war ja was. Aber so ein Kabel hab ich halt nicht.
Ja, kannst du bei eBay bestellen, gibt's ohne Ende.
Bei eBay.
Da gibt's ja sau Strom auf eBay. Auf dem Muzzerboard sind zwei so kleine PCI-Stromkondaktoren, die sind eigentlich für deine Grafikkarte und vielleicht sind die bei dir auch schon belegt, aber du kannst da bestimmt bei eBay mal ein bisschen gucken, da gibt's Splitterkabel und so weiter, weil viel braucht das Ding ja nicht. Du kannst ja auf jeden Fall da irgendwie was abklauen und...
Grafikkarten, Powerversorgung, Splitterkabel.
Ja, das ist nur ein PCI-Teil, was da rauskommt. Und meistens gibt's natürlich von Molex auf das moderne PCI. Ich weiß nicht, du brauchst das jetzt ja genau andersrum, da weiß ich nicht, ob es sowas gibt, aber ich denke, also eigentlich gibt's...
Die China-Jungs, die lüten dir alles zusammen.
Genau, zur Not muss viele immer kurz ran.
Ja, vielleicht hat ja auch der Chat da einen Tipp. Das Produkt heißt Grafikkarten, Stromversorgungskabel, Weiche...
Nach Molex. Molex, das ist Molex, was das Ding da braucht.
Ach echt, Molex heißen die Teile?
Ja, die Firma heißt so und das ist einer von diesen Standards, aber man nennt das grundsätzlich Molex.
Der löscht den Installer nach Molex.
Dieser Stecker hier?
Das?
Der wird Molex-Stecker gewesen?
Ja, eigentlich gibt's hier eine Firma, die so heißt, aber der bekannteste, den die wohl haben, also bei den PC-Jungs jedenfalls, ist dieser da und den nennt man halt Molex.
Dieser 500 Jahre alte, wie er jetzt 5,12 Volt in eine Festplatte reinschmeißt?
Ja, in dem man sich irgendwie Finger aufreißt, Fingernägel abbricht.
Das wusste ich nie! Wie lange gibt's den jetzt schon? Ich hab genug PC geschraubt in meinem Leben, keine Angst.
Ja, du hast aber nichts gelernt.
Nicht wie das Ding heißt. Aber ich weiß schon, wie ich mal da die Finger auf die Betonen kann.
Ich hab ja dann irgendwann eine Zange immer benutzt, das ging super.
Kann man die Firma jetzt noch auswendig machen und verklagen?
Computer Disk Drive Connector Initially on the sugared floppy disk drive. Sugared floppy disks, da war der schon das erste Mal dran.
So sieht der auch aus.
Ich finde, der sieht irgendwie ganz cool aus eigentlich.
Er hat auf jeden Fall, wie die USB-Verlängerung, hat der auch, wenn du den einmal reingesteckt hast, der ist nicht einfach so rausgegangen.
Der hält, der hält.
Aber der gibt's ja mehr oder weniger nicht mehr. Die haben jetzt seitdem SATA-Strom anders aussieht und die Grafikkarten alle jetzt hier diesen PCI-Strom-Dings da haben und so. Also gibt's ja den kaum noch.
Aber wie heißt jetzt dieser Stecker, der an Grafikkarten dran ist?
Ist das nicht der? Nein, das ist nicht der.
Das ist der, der an Floppy ist.
Das nennt man PCI-Strom. Oder PCI-Express.
PCI-Power-Connector.
Und dann gibt's als Vierer, Sechser und Achter. Und das hab ich alles gelernt, als ich dir meine fetten Grafikkarten, also vier Grafikkarten in einen Rechner verbaut habe für Bitcoin. Da lernst du dann alles. Auch dass du nur vom Board selbst irgendwie nur 75 Watt holen darfst. Und die restlichen, die müssen direkt vom Netz lang. Weil sonst brennen dir auf dem Board die Leiterbahnen durch, wenn du da zu viel durchballerst, zu viel Ampere. Deswegen, ja.
Ich hab gestern ein Schild hier gesehen, wo dran steht, wir arbeiten hier mit Naturstrom. Da dachte ich auch so, was ist ein Naturstrom? Das, was bei denen natürlich aus der Steckdose kommt oder so? Gehst du durch den Wald, guckst mal unterm Stein, da ist so eine Steckdose und da kommt der Naturstrom raus.
Ne, anders. Da geht der Ostfriese bei Ebbe raus und holt sich einen Kilowatt.
Ok, kurze Klärung zu diesem Stecker. Also das Ding heißt PCI Express Auxiliary Graphics Power Connectors. Und schafft 75 Watt zu der Grafikkarte.
Der normale Vierfache oder was? Der Sechsfache schafft 75?
Vierfach gibt's nicht. Es gibt sechs und acht.
Genau, der Achter schafft 150 und bei den fetten Grafikkarten brauchen wir zwei davon.
Genau.
Und dein Mac darf aber maximal, darfst du nur 300 Watt aus diesen beiden Konnektoren da rausholen. Und das sind beim Apple natürlich, kann ja nicht anders sein. Die Konnektoren haben natürlich eine andere Größe. Die sind sozusagen optisch gleich, aber in kleiner. Deswegen musst du bei eBay halt so von klein auf Standard irgendwie holen für Apple. Sonst geht es nämlich nicht.
Auf dem Board?
Also bei Apple gibt's ja keine Stromkabel innen drin, wie bei den PCs, wo die einfach alle so rumhängen.
Also brauch ich jetzt eine PCI Express Power-Konnektor-Weiche.
Und schreibt noch Mac Pro dazu und das Ganze bei eBay rein.
Und dann kommt da das Passwort.
Posten wir irgendwie 6 Euro oder so.
Hootschimming Flower Power Enterprises hat ja bestimmt ein ein passendes Produkt im Portfolio.
Weil es gibt ja ganz viele Leute, die sich eine fettere Grafikkarte reinmachen und denen fehlt aber dieses Kabel, was ist natürlich nicht dabei per Default und da muss man sich die da besorgen und die gibt es irgendwie.
Wieder was gelernt hier bei Freak Show, wa?
Krasse Scheiße! Was machst du jetzt mit den ganzen Grafikkarten, die du jetzt hast?
Die liegen so rum, ich brauche keinen Schwein mehr.
Ach, was hast du denn noch für welche?
Ich habe dreimal 58, 70, ich habe noch eine 59, 70 und die andere 59, 70 ist durchgeknallt und das war es eigentlich.
Irgendwas, was ich gebrauchen könnte?
Du hast ja da die 68, 70 drin. Oder 68, 70, ja genau.
Ich habe überlegt, ob ich mir diese neue, diese weiße da, diese...
Hol dir die mal, dann würde ich die gerne bei dir durchtesten. Aber ich habe gehört, dass die ein Problem hat. Und zwar, es ist halt nur ein kleines Problem, aber ich finde es halt doch für so einen Apple-User ein Schönheitsfehler und zwar, wenn die Default-Screen-Auflösung nicht zum Display passt. Das heißt, der weiß von selber nicht, welche Auflösung der Display hat und stellt per Default das Falsche ein. Du kannst es zwar dann einfach umstellen und dann ist alles stimmt, aber es ist halt nicht das Default. Wie umstellen?
Wann umstellen? Einmalig umstellen.
Du gehst einfach in Display-Konfiguration und sagst dann, ich will nicht 1280, ich will 1920 haben und dann stimmt es wieder.
Eine Kaffeekarte, der man sagen muss, wie groß der Bildschirm ist.
Das ist ein kleiner Schönheitsfehler, man kann es fixen, aber es ist nicht toll. Das andere Ding ist, ich weiß nicht, ob es bei der Sapphire auch so ist, aber da gibt es ja dieses netcast.org, dieses Hacker-Forum, wo die da Grafikkarten mit Firmware neu machen und so weiter. Und da erzählen sie mal, dass manche Grafikkarten laufen nur mit 2,5 Gigatransactions pro Sekunde an, statt 5. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die Sapphire das richtig macht, aber da gibt es Anleitungen, wo man irgendwelche Widerstände weglöten muss und dann stellt er automatisch auf 5 um. Ist jetzt nicht so mega wichtig, aber ist halt auch so ganz kleiner Schönheitsfehler. Von 2,5 auf 5. Gigatransactions pro Sekunde, die da über den PCI-Bus gehen, das kann man irgendwie konfigurieren. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob die Sapphire, diese weiße, ob die auch schon 5 macht. Wenn nicht, könnte man es wahrscheinlich leicht fixen. Da gibt es außen so Jumper, die man dann weglöten muss, damit kann man die Grafikkarte mehr oder weniger konfigurieren. Ja, aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch einer unserer Hörer, irgendwer wird ja wohl, die sich diese weiße Meckentosche Sapphire-Karte geholt haben.
Hoffentlich nicht.
Und da die es inzwischen ist ja auch einigermaßen billig geworden. Was? Die kostet jetzt nicht mehr 500 und auch nicht mehr 400. Ich glaube, die sind jetzt bei 350, 330 oder irgendwie so. Also die sind natürlich immer noch viel teurer als die normalen, weil die sind natürlich auch im Preis gefallen, aber es geht jetzt schon langsam.
Jetzt wo es die Bitcoin-Miner nicht mehr interessiert. Das fände ich auch sowieso so witzig bei diesem ganzen Bitcoin-Mining.
Was hat die ursprünglich gekostet?
Ich glaube 450 oder so, oder 480 als die rauskamen.
Ja, jetzt gibt es die für 360. Was kostet die für einen PC-Markt normalerweise?
260 wahrscheinlich.
Naja, das geht ja noch.
Das Problem ist, dass die haben ja versucht sich ein bisschen an Apple anzudenken, haben das Ding halt weiß gemacht. Ich habe leider noch keinen weißen Mac Pro gesehen, verstehe ich ja auch nicht so, wie ich auf die Idee komme. Aber es sieht einfach scheiße aus.
Aber die sieht man doch gar nicht.
Und dann können sie das Gehäuse auch weglassen.
Ich finde das insofern cool, als dass du einfach den Produktbild sofort ansiehst, ah, das ist die Karte für ein Mac.
Ah, das ist für die Mac-Idioten, die zu viel bezahlen. Toll, da habe ich ein ganz tolles Gefühl.
Naja, 100 Euro mehr, aber ich meine, sie hat eine weiße, glänzende Verpackung.
Weißt du, wenn da so ein Alurahmen drüber wäre, dann sage ich, alles klar, 100 Euro mehr, dann sieht sie den Schick aus und hat so Metall und Zeug und lüftet hinten raus und so. Aber ne, die haben da so ein billiges, weißes, glänzendes Billigplastik oben drauf geklatscht.
Da steht aber Mac Edition drauf.
Na hol dir die mal, ich würde mir die gerne mal angucken.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hol mir die nur, wenn das für mich wirklich Vorteile verspricht, die ich jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so richtig sehe. Das wirst du nicht so richtig, was schneller wird, weil dieses blöde Google Earth, das wird irgendwie nicht schneller. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob hier überhaupt mein Upgrade auf Mavericks Erfolg haben wird oder ob mir da nicht wieder mein ganzes Audio-Netzwerk um die Ohren fliegt. Aber es kann nur besser werden. So, ja, okay, gut. Also, Mavericks, gibt's da noch irgendwas zu vermuten?
Ja, ich will da noch einmal up-renten. Ich hab das ja zu Hause mal aus beruflichen Gründen installiert, ja, ich brauch das ja. Und was mir aufgefallen ist im Finder, also ich hab meinen Downloads Ordner, ich sag jetzt einfach mal die Wahrheit, ihr könnt euch den Rest dann selber denken, da hab ich einen Ordner Videos, und den hab ich jetzt mal aufgeteilt, nachdem es ein bisschen voll wurde, in Movies und Serien, ja, Serious. Und wenn ich dann, ich bin jetzt...
Also deine Heimfilme getrennt von deinen Heim...
Serien. Genau, und wenn ich dann irgendwie so ein neues Ding runterlade und da reinschmeißen will, ich bin in einer Listen-Ansicht und ich hab alles zugeklappt, weil ich mag dieses Aufklappen, nicht? Und geh dann auf Videos und lass es da reinfallen, oder ich denke, dass es dann aufgeht, dann, ich hab das hier leider nicht da, aber du müsstest es mal nachmachen. Ja, dass die so aufgehen.
Du kannst onscreen gehen, mein Freund.
Wie auf dem Screen? Hast du da Mavericks?
Wartest du dich, dass du das...?
Ja, zu Hause. Auf meinem Mac Pro.
Wie, und du klebst hier deine Kamera, aber benutzt den Fingerprint-Sensor da?
Ja, mein Fingerprint ist ja wohl ein bisschen was anderes als mein Gesicht und so.
Und die Front-Facing-Kamera?
Black Magic. Und jetzt?
Die liegt immer so zu Hause und da leg ich immer was rüber. Nein, Quatsch. Die filmt die Decke.
Musst ihr hier Spring-Loaden?
Ja, der Witz ist, dass genau, dass diese beiden Orner, die jetzt bei dir da ganz normal angezeigt werden, bei mir kommen die so ganz komisch mit Kreise und werden beide gleichzeitig, aber offen, aber ohne Pfeile angezeigt. Ich kann es euch leider nicht erklären, ohne euch das vor... Sind da, sind da... Hat das Zeug Inhalt da bei dir? Diese beiden Dinger, die da mal gerade gesehen hat? Ja, nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe Showers gebügelt.
Ich habe hier kein Mavericks. Das ist meine Kiste zu Hause. Aber jedenfalls sieht ganz komisch aus und da sind auch Kreise vorne dran, die keine Farbe haben, so pro Ordner. Und ich kann dann das... also irgendwas...
Alles wird gut, Dennis, wieder.
Wollen wir nicht lieber darüber reden, was sich jetzt dadurch sozusagen ändern könnte?
Nein, das Linen-Ding ist weg. Das ist das Beste schon von allem.
An welchen Stellen?
Bei den Notifications.
Was ist da jetzt? Jetzt ist alles Blur oder was?
Geh mal rechts oben in die Ecke und klick mal drauf.
Irgendwie die Karte funktioniert doch nicht so gut.
Weiter rechts und weiter oben. Ganz rechts oben.
Nein, Notification Center.
Wir wollen das Notification Center sehen.
Ja, und dann?
Das Notification Center.
Nochmal ganz rechts oben. Ja, siehst du, da ist es weg. Es ist einfach nur grau.
Ach so, das ist ja ein großer Sprung nach vorne.
Ich finde schon.
Weil ich fand es vorher immer so, ich fand mich in 30, 40 Jahren zurückkatapultiert.
Resopal ist nicht mehr? Ja gut, Resopal hat es irgendwie noch nie gebraucht.
Ja genau.
Oder? Also ich meine...
Nein, es war immer disgusting. Es sah scheiße aus.
Ja hier, naja, es gibt halt die...
Aber die Maps, so richtig schnell ist das noch nicht, oder? Also das flutscht irgendwie nicht. Ich finde das ist ganz schön langsam. Und der nutzt auch irgendwie nur eine CPU nicht alle. Und ich habe da so einige gefunden in meinem Rechner.
Der nutzt nur eine CPU?
Also das performt tut das nicht.
Ich sag dir, die stellen sich voll drauf an, nur noch GPUs zu benutzen.
Ja, habe ich auch.
Ja, da ist nur eine drin.
Wollt ihr noch was sehen, dann mache ich das hier wieder aus.
Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt die tolle Karte sehen, damit... Ja, das ist ja auch ein 3D und ja, wollte ich eigentlich auch gerade sehen.
Hier gibt es die tolle Aktivitätsanzeige.
Ah ja, zeig doch mal diese Energiesache. Das ist doch mal sehr interessant.
Da die Aktivitätsanzeige braucht gerade am meisten.
Und der Finder, wie immer.
Frag mal den Durchschnitt an und nicht den aktuellen.
Durchschnittlicher Energiebedarf.
Und wer ist da oben?
Skype läuft aber gar nicht. Das hab ich nur heute Nachmittag ein Stündchen laufen lassen.
Eine Stunde?
Was ist denn Nachspotlight, bitte?
Das ist dieses Programm vom Transporter. Das ist diese Box, die ich mal...
Das hat keinen Namen oder was?
Ich weiß nicht. Das ist halt auch so eine App, die sich nur ins Menü reinhängt.
Wie sieht das denn aus?
Die sind ordentlich klein. Diese Dwetches, das ist ja das letzte.
Nee, leider nicht. Mac-Kleins sind generell ein Problem. Nicht nur bei app.net.
Nee, aber dieses Transporter-Ding, das ist wirklich nur...
Aber in was ist denn die Einheit dieses Energiebedarfs?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann.
Prozent.
Ja, unten hier bei den Grafen, da ist keine Einheiten, keine Größen mehr da. Auch beim Netzwerk und bei Festplatte kannst du nicht mehr sehen, was es ist. Das ist voll scheiße.
Aber da steht vorher voll super.
Aber aktuell steht da oben zum Beispiel auch nicht.
Aber guck mal, da unten sind doch Einheiten, Empfang, Daten pro Sekunde.
Ja, jetzt genau diesen Augenblick. Da musst du mal in der Grafik gucken. Aha, das könnte jetzt ungefähr hier so sein, aber du siehst nicht, was dein Max war und so weiter.
Das ist schon noch. Ich würde hier gar keine Daten empfangen.
Tim, zumindest bei dem aktuellen Bedarf macht Prozent natürlich für den Benutzer am meisten Sinn. Weil der User will wissen, wie viel von meiner... Ja, würde ich jetzt mal mutmaßenweise keine andere Einheit angeben. Für alle andere geben sie eine Einheit an.
Ja, aber Prozent von was?
Von deiner Batteriekapazität oder von der Gesamtstromkapazität. Nicht bei Durchschnitt kann ich jetzt nicht, aber bei dem aktuellen...
Die Frage ist, ist es relativ, ist es sozusagen prozentual zu dem durchschnittlichen Gesamtverbrauch? Das würde ja keinen Sinn machen.
Fahr doch mal mit deiner Maus darüber.
Dann würde ja der Skype-Wert sinken, umso mehr andere Programme laufen.
Durchschnittlich in den letzten acht Stunden, niedriger ist besser. Naja, ist doch klar. Less ist more.
Das ist so, als ob du in so einen Laden reingehst, in den Supermarkt und sagst, guten Tag, ich hätte gerne fünf. Ja, fünf was.
Na, weniger. Weniger ist besser.
Ich hätte gerne von dem Hack, wie viel? Fünf.
Weniger ist besser.
Mehr ist besser in dem Fall, aber egal.
Ich hätte gerne einen Sendungstitel für heute. Weniger ist besser.
Ich hätte gerne 350.000 und drei Wasser.
Also Mavericks durchschlagender Erfolg, auf ganzer Linie.
Pass auf, oder?
Ja, die neuen Sachen.
Roddy, du kannst doch jetzt deinen Airplay-Klimbim auch so machen, dass das wirklich ein zweiter Bildschirm ist, oder? Also wenn du jetzt...
Schreibtisch erweitern?
Genau, wenn du jetzt deinen Schreibtisch...
Show me your Schreibtisch.
Können wir auch eine kurze Andachtsekunde machen für diese Formulierung?
Schreibtisch erweitern.
Erweitern.
Was ich jetzt machen kann, ist... Du hast jetzt einen zweiten Screen.
Gemürret oder wie?
Hier ist er.
Die spannende Frage ist...
So, und jetzt macht doch mal bitte auf deinem Hauptbildschirm vor deiner Nase eine Up in Fullscreen-Modus.
Das ist ja nicht dein Hauptbildschirm.
Ist egal, den, den du vor der Nase hast. Nicht den, den wir sehen.
Nehm noch mal Safari zu dir rüber.
Ach so, ne, den kann man nicht Fullscreenen.
Einfach Finder, zack, irgendwas.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Egal, Safari, ach Safari.
Also ich finde, wir sollten erstmal eine Abstimmung abhalten.
So eine Brumm-Abstimmung oder was?
Ist Fullscreen.
Ist jetzt Fullscreen. Aber hier ist noch Resopal.
Okay, man merkt nichts. So, jetzt gehen wir auf diesen Bildschirm, den wir sehen, den zweiten, ins Menü rein. Da ist jetzt überhaupt die Menüleiste. Das kannst du jetzt auch klicken.
Und bei ihm ist weiter mit Fullscreen.
Guck mal, da ist das zweite Safari-Fenster. Obwohl das andere auf Fullscreen.
Ja, weil du machst ja das Fenster auf Fullscreen. Und nicht die App.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist ja fast brauchbar.
Die Bugs, die ich noch fixen muss.
Ja, das ist so. Was ist, wenn du jetzt dieses Fenster nimmst und nach links schiebst?
Hier hin?
Ist das jetzt über oder unter dem Fenster?
Noch ist es über. Jetzt lass ich mal los. Jetzt ist es weg hier.
Ja, wo ist es jetzt?
Wahrscheinlich dahinten.
Du kannst über den Kontrollkursor rechts dahin gehen.
Ist ein bisschen hier.
Das sind ja so die Momente, wo man dann doch mal über einen Videocast nachdenkt.
Wir werden das gleich zusammenfassen. Ich muss noch eine Frage.
Komm mal hier deine Screens nach rechts oder nach links, weil jetzt müsste es ja theoretisch auf dem nächsten Screen gelandet sein.
Du musst mit der Maus erst mal zu dir rübergehen. Du bist noch in dem anderen gerade. Die Maus bestimmt den Fokus wahrscheinlich.
Ich möchte gerne meine... Was machst du jetzt?
Ich versuche, nein.
Kontrollkursor rechts oder links?
Was tust du?
Das sagen wir dir nicht. Rate.
Nee, geht nix. Irgendwie ist das Fenster jetzt weg, was ich versucht habe zusätzlich.
Vielleicht hat er es in diese Tabs mode reingemerged.
Hast du deinen Fullscreen-Modus beendet?
Zwischendrin ja, aber der, ich glaube, er hat es eigentlich...
Was denn, das Fenster ist trotzdem weg?
Ja, weg ist weg.
Guck doch mal in deine Fensterliste.
Ich bin der erste Mensch.
Einmal mit Profis.
Da, da!
So, ist das Fenster da.
Das hier müsste es sein.
Ist es irgendwo? Nee. Ah, ist es weg?
Siehst du es.
Geil. Okay, zweiter Test. Mach nicht diesen Unfug hier mit diesem Übersichtsscheiß.
Tim will sein Mavericks kaputt spielen.
Mach bitte nochmal auf deinem internen Bildschirm einen Fullscreen an.
So, ja, jetzt.
Jetzt nimmst du dieses andere Safari-Fenster. Keiner hat sowas, das nicht verlieren. Die kommen alle wieder. Und schiebst es nur zu 30% in deinen anderen Bildschirm vorbei.
Dann ist es hier Fullscreen.
Hier sieht man es nicht. Auf dem internen, so, ja?
Tim, meinst du nicht, dass du schon zu alt bist für eine Doktorarbeit?
Über 50% schiebst du nochmal näher ran, dass es aber immer noch zu sehen ist. Ja, und unverändert, ja? Es schiebt sich unter diesen Fullscreen los. Ah, jetzt fängt es an, sich bei 60-70% löst es sich nämlich auf.
Das liegt daran, dass deine Maus den Rand berührt.
Ja, die Maus ist rübergegangen. Oh, guck mal.
Fass mal das Fenster ganz, ganz, ganz rechts an. Also so, dass du es noch schieben kannst.
Mann, ja, hier so. Ganz rechts, jetzt langsam. Ach, linksam.
Schieb, schieb, schieb, schieb, schieb, schieb.
Schieb, schieb, schieb, schieb, schieb.
Es fängt nämlich nicht mit dem Fenster zusammen, sondern dann, wenn es in der Maus ist.
Erst wenn die Maus drüben ist, dann kommt das.
Und jetzt lass es los?
Ja, dann ist das auch weg. Toll!
Aber das heißt, jetzt weiß ich endlich, was ich davon zu halten habe. Etwa so, wie ich mir das gedacht habe. Ein Fenster hat jetzt sozusagen einen Screen auch als Ort. Und der andere Screen in diesem Modus, du hast doch diesen neuen Modus, das ist doch dieser neue Modus, oder hast du noch diesen alten Modus?
Ich hab nix umgeschaltet, aber ich hab auch einfach nur installiert.
Dann geh doch mal in deine Präferenzen. Checken Sie doch mal ihre Präferenzen.
Wir sollten uns...
Was denn? Nee, das ist wichtig.
Wir sollten uns umbenennen.
In?
Mobile Max.
Hier ist nix mobil.
Monitore? Keine Ahnung. Mission Control? Was ist das? Schreibtisch? Bildschirmschoner? Wo stellt man das ein? Wahrscheinlich Monitore.
Mission Control.
Nein, das hat mit dem Monitor nichts zu tun.
Aber das ist anordnend, das werd ich jetzt mal kurz machen.
Nein. Ach so, damit es so in der Reihenfolge ist.
Damit es richtig rum ist.
Mission Control.
Missionskontrolle.
Nee, das ist ja nicht Mission Control. Das ist ja, wie dein Fullscreen-Modus funktioniert.
Bei Programmwerken, Space auswählen, geöffnen.
Monitore verwenden, verschwenden Spaces. Ist es das?
Verwenden verschiedene Spaces. Ja, wahrscheinlich Abmeldung erforderlich, wenn ich das jetzt ändern will. Ich melde mich jetzt nicht an.
Okay, verwenden verschiedene Spaces.
Ich glaube, das hat jetzt überhaupt niemand mitgekriegt, was wir hier gemacht haben.
Ich will es jetzt mal zusammenfassen. Also wir haben diesen Fullscreen-Modus in Mavericks, der sich geändert hat. Vorher war es so, du machst Fullscreen. Alle anderen Bildschirme sind dann mit diesem Linen überzogen. Und es ist total brain damaged und unbenutzbar. Jetzt scheint es einen neuen Modus zu geben. Und ich glaube, das Setting, was du da hast, ist bei Default das neue Setting.
Wie immer.
Kann sein, ja.
Und das neue Setting ist so, dass jetzt ein Fenster eben zum Bildschirm zugeordnet ist. Es kann nicht mehr in beiden liegen. Es liegt entweder in dem einen oder in dem anderen. Und der Moment, wo es verlässt ist, wenn du es wegschiebst und du bist mit der Maus ganz an der Kante, dann übergibst du es. Und das macht die Sache insofern ganz benutzbar, als dass du immer noch diese Anordnung hast der Monitore. Kannst aber so einen Bildschirm einmal abgeben. Kannst aber dann immer noch deine Fenster so zur Seite rausschieben, solange du sie nicht runter schubst. Das könnte funktionieren. Ich glaube, sie sind da nah dran an der Lösung. Mein Gott, wie lange hat das gedauert?
Unglaublich.
Halbes Jahrzehnt.
Ja, die mussten vorher ein iPhone raus.
Okay.
Ich mach jetzt hier den Ding ins Aus.
Ja, ich mach mal hier auch den... Gucken wir mal, was der Chat sagt. Wir brauchen doch noch einen zweiten Beamer.
Oder noch einen zweiten Chat.
So mit deiner Beamergeilheit.
Der neue Song hat nur 4 Beamer pro Sekunde.
Wenn du mal wieder mehr Podcasts produzieren würdest, würde das auch nicht sein.
Mach mal irgendwas über Kabel.
Entschuldigung, dass ich jetzt mal Urlaub gemacht hab.
Oder mit Torrent Sync.
Aber der macht immer WLAN-Sies.
Das ist unglaublich raffiniert mit dieser Linie. Das finde ich echt ziemlich cool.
Wollen wir noch über den Mac Pro reden? Oder lassen wir das sein?
Gibt ja nichts Neues.
Mülleimer bleibt Mülleimer.
Wir können nochmal über den Preis spekulieren, aber ich denke ja nicht deutlich unter 5K.
What?
Nicht deutlich unter 5K?
Einsteigermodell 2500.
Ich denke, das Einsteigermodell fängt mit 6K an.
What part of wir wollen nicht über den Preis diskutieren habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ich finde das aber wirklich interessant, weil das ist so ziemlich das Einzige, was sie nicht gesagt haben.
Da war kein Memo.
Also ich glaube, es hat eine 2 vorne dran, das Einsteigermodell, aber es kann auch so 1899 irgendwie so.
Ich sag mal, es gibt kein Einsteigermodell.
Doch, definitiv.
Es gibt nur Medium Pro und richtig Pro.
Es gibt auch eins mit nur einer Grafikkarte, könnte ich schwören.
Einsteigermodell im Sinne von preislich affordable. Weil ich denke, dass sie da eine ganze Menge Einsparpotenziale haben. Ich meine, was macht die Kiste so teuer? Gut, sie haben da saumäßig viel SSD drin. Das bauen sie irgendwie weitgehend schon selber und haben sie irgendwie Economies of Scale und da wissen sie, was sie tun. Dann haben sie da RAM drin. Na ja, das haben sie sowieso schon seit Jahrhunderten zu teuer verkauft, da können sie es auch mal billiger machen. Und was ist noch drin? Diese GPUs. Aber ansonsten enthält dieses Gerät ja auch nichts. Ich meine, sie haben noch ein bisschen Thunderbolt-Ports.
Da ist ein Macbook Pro eine Tonne gepackt.
Na ja, das ist schon ein ordentlicher Prozessor als ein Macbook Pro drin.
Also ich könnte mir so zwei, zwei, zwei, drei so oder...
Nee, das ist kein Macbook Pro, weil da ist ja auch kein Bildschirm drin. Na ja, eben, das meine ich halt. Das ist einfach so ein Gehäuse. Das ist nicht groß, das ist nicht viel Material dran. Da sind im Wesentlichen drei Mainboards drin.
Nicht mal ein Akku.
Kein Akku, genau. Keine Tastatur, keine Maus. Also die ist jetzt im Preis nicht enthalten, sag ich mal so.
Ja, aber ein halber Starfighter an Aluminium, also ich meine...
Kein Bildschirm. Keine PCI-Ports, keine Drive-Ports. Ich meine, was hat der Mac Pro zuletzt gekostet? Der kleinste Einstiegspreis. Was war denn da der Einstiegspreis?
Guck ich mal nach.
Das wäre mal ganz interessant. Ja gut, einen dicken, fetten Kühlkörper hat er. Keine CD-Laufwerke, keine unnötigen Kabelladen.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war der Grafikkartenspeicher schon komplett unklar, den sie da drauf gebaut haben. Es war ja relativ viel Zeug.
Ja, 6 Gigabyte.
Ja, aber pro Karte, ne?
Initial Price 2999 Dollar. Der letzte Mac Pro.
2999, really?
Dollar, also...
Echt, wo hast du das her aus dem Mac-Tracker?
Ah, sorry, das ist der Mac Pro Server. Moment. Der Mac Pro mit 2000, der ist... Initial Price 2999 Dollar. 2,5. Ich denke mal auch, dass der Mac Pro mit 2 anfängt. Wo genau angesiedelt, weiß ich nicht, aber eins scheint mir zu wenig. Und dann ist er auch noch in den USA gebaut, weißt du.
Er ist doch in Billiglohnland geworden, oder nicht?
Na jetzt mit Obamacare.
Wo hast du die Informationen gerade her?
Mac Tracker steht das auf der General Page.
Ach, da steht's ja. Ok, alles klar. Also ich sag, sie bleiben unter 2,5. Also sie gehen nicht mit dem Einstiegsmodell. Ja, was weiß ich, vielleicht ballern sie da weniger GPU-Rahmen rein oder sonst irgendwas. Wahrscheinlich tun sie das nicht.
Ich glaube, sie wollen oben den Markt absahnen, der da ganz oben ist. Alles andere können die PCs sowieso besser.
Naja, nicht wenn sie ein gut händelbares GPU-Powerhouse für so einen echt coolen Einstiegspreis machen, der einfach für viele Anwendungen einfach die bessere Lösung ist. Also das kann schon sein, dass sie damit angreifen.
Genau, und die ganzen Gamer steigen um auf die Maschine.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. So weit sind wir noch nicht.
Da bist du aber cool, wenn du mit so einem Teil auf dein Netzwerk-Party aufräuschst.
Da bist du nicht. Wieso? Na, weil mit dem Apple da der Loser bist. Weil deine Maus nur eine Taste hat.
Naja, kannst du auch drei und fünf Tasten-Mäuse an die Maus...
Kannst sogar mehrere anschließen.
Das weiß aber keiner.
Das arbeitet doch wohl bitte keiner von den Gamer mit einer Standard-Maus, oder?
Die haben doch alle... Die haben doch alle so eine Tastatur mit Rollen.
Bei der Mac auch eine USB-Maus anschließen kannst. Denkt man doch, da ist die Maus mit dem einen Button.
Ja, vielleicht. Die Gamer halt.
Ich game mit meinem Touchpad, deswegen kriege ich auch bei PvP immer auf die Fresse.
Also ich bin gespannt. Ich bin gespannt.
Ein bisschen gespannt sein, das dürfen wir alle.
Kleinigkeit noch, es gab ein Apple-TV-Update, aber das war noch vor dem iOS 7-Release, oder? Oder war das...
Ich nichts wiss.
Du nichts wiss? Ja, weil jetzt haben sie da irgendwie auch Podcasts kleint und Sinken mit der Podcast, also von ihrer Podcast-App. Du kannst jetzt sozusagen deine Subscriptions auch auf dein Apple-TV Sinken und da vorhalten und runterladen lassen.
Mein eigener Podcast.
Ja, also auf so einem Apple-TV kannst du jetzt quasi auch...
Kann ich mir denn aussuchen, welche Podcasts ich wohin Sünke oder Sünkt der immer alle? Ich habe ja schon das Problem mit iPhone und iPad. Also, weil die Videos will ich nicht auf dem iPhone haben.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Ich glaube, du kannst irgendwie einstellen, ob er irgendwie automatisch runterladen soll oder nicht. Das war's. Also Sünden ist ja sozusagen alle deine Podcasts. Und ehrlich gesagt, für Leute, die jetzt so 4, 5, 6 Sendungen hören, ist das irgendwie ein völlig korrektes Interface. Aber du kannst dann halt so ein Apple TV an deiner Anlage anschließen und kannst so mit einer normalen Fernbedienung Podcasts hören.
Übrigens hat der erste Mac Pro der LAS auch 4.500 gekostet.
Der erste?
Also 2006.
Der kleinste.
Da gab es wohl nur einen in diesem Jahr.
Das ist immer.
Ist der Mac Pro Preis?
Pro Bedarf, Pro Preis.
Wer will den jetzt mal übernehmen?
Ich muss jetzt hier erstmal meine Browser-Fenster wieder wieder.
Also wir haben jetzt hier noch verschiedene Themen. Ihr könnt euch ja mal irgendwie.
Ja, ich fange einfach an.
Wer mag den mal?
Ich habe ja, weil, also am Wochenende habe ich mal wieder versucht, Filme zu bearbeiten. Das mache ich nicht so häufig, weil ich bisher immer jetzt mit iMovie so schmerzhafte Erfahrungen hatte, dass ich gar nicht das Bedürfnis verspürt habe, das wiederzutun. Das liegt zum einen daran, dass mein Macbook Pro halt anscheinend zu wenig Grafikpower hat für Videobearbeitung und dieser Live-Preview bei iMovie, den kann man ihm zwar abgewöhnen, aber dann wird es total pointless, weil man dann noch die Soundwaves sieht. Also es gibt Leute, die sagen, mit iMovie kann man auch prima Filme editieren, aber ich kriege binnen Sekunden, was mir echt nicht häufig passiert, so einen richtigen Hals, so richtig so, oh, Software, ich möchte Gewalt anwenden. Das bringt mich so richtig in Rage.
Man kann mit iMovie Filme schneiden für unterschiedliche Geschmacksmischungen von Filmen.
Ja, aber, also ich meine, meine konkrete Anwendung ist halt, ich habe Film vom iPhone und habe Sound von einem externen Mikrofon über ein externes Interface und will die halt sünden und allein dieses Interface, wie da so Soundspuren repräsentiert werden und wie man die voneinander trennen muss und wie man die übereinander legen kann und immer dieses Geruckel, weil er immer diesen Scheiß-Live-Preview rendert, das Konzept von Projekten, Timelines und das ist total, weiß nicht, als ob sie irgendwie den Filmschnitt so komplett am Thema vorbei nochmal.
Da ist eine andere Zielgruppe, es ist die Proversion von dem normalen Trimming. Ein Movie ist sozusagen ohne...
Ja, aber es ist wirklich nur das auch, ne?
Ja, aber du benutzt in der Regel wirklich auch Audio und Video immer so, wie sie schon beisammen sind und das fügst du in eine andere Sequenz. Ich finde ein Movie an der Stelle vollkommen berechtigt und was du da machen willst, ist keine Aufgabe für ein Movie.
Aber selbst wenn du halt nur ein Film vom iPhone runterholst, ich meine, das ist alles schon 1080p auf dem iPhone 5, also schon alleine da die richtige Stelle zu finden und so dieses permanente Gehacke, weil es halt alles live gerendert sein muss und so weiter, das geht mir halt total auf die Ketten. Also es ist mir eigentlich im Weg zum Audio-Editing. Du willst halt eine Marke genau, so mit einem Pixel genau ansteuern und es macht immer so wupp wupp und wupp wupp und...
Du meinst dieses Live-Ranzoomen, wenn du ein Bild hälst?
Das ist furchtbar, I hate it so much. Und ich habe spaßenshalber Reaper, kann ja auch Video zumindest anzeigen und dann habe ich dieses Video mal kurz in den Reaper reingezogen, weil mir ging es ja um das Audiosynken, und er zeigt halt die Audiospur von dem Video an. Und das performt, auch mit Live-Preview, das flutscht richtig. Am Ende kann ich das Video da nicht rausrennen, deswegen habe ich es dann nicht gemacht. Das war halt wirklich nur für die Audiobereitung, aber ich habe zumindest gesehen, es geht. Eine Lösung ist möglich. Dann habe ich halt noch mal kurz so, ich habe ja schon mal gesagt im Twitter, ich hätte gerne sowas wie Reaper für Videoschnitt, aber das gibt es auf Mac nicht. Da haben ja alle gesagt, ihr benutzt doch Final Cut Pro. Dann habe ich mir mal eine Trial-Version von Final Cut Pro untergeladen, um das mal auszuprobieren. Und auf jeden Fall kann man schon mal sagen, das performt besser als das iMovie. Also das gleiche Film-File einmal mit iMovie bearbeiten und diesen Live-Preview rendern und sowieso in Effekte.
Das performt wie Hölle, weil da einfach immer alle cross befindet.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal gleich aufgefallen und es geht auf jeden Fall auch dieses Audiosyncing und so. Es geht viel natürlicher von der Hand. Also man merkt halt, das ist ein Tool, wo man noch ein bisschen mehr Kontrolle hat. Aber ich muss auch sagen, so blöd ist das Interface von Final Cut Pro 7. War das die letzte Version? Ne, 9?
Neun.
Ach, ich weiß nicht, ich hab sieben. Das letzte Mal Final Cut hab ich...
Bei Logic war es neun.
Ja, Final Cut 7 hab ich das letzte Mal auch irgendwann benutzt. Und da war jetzt das Interface halt nicht so schön, aber wie sie da eigentlich so diese Tracks von Video und Audio in dieser Timeline organisiert haben, das fand ich eigentlich immer noch so vollkommen ausreichend. Ich weiß gar nicht, wieso jetzt dieses alles in einem und live rendern und alles irgendwie zusammengemanst und immer mit hin und her hackeln.
Aber ich muss sagen...
Und auch dieses Konzept von Projekten und deiner Timeline, ich zum Beispiel in iMovie, ich versteh das Interface einfach überhaupt nicht.
Das Timeline-Konzept von iMovie ist einfach komplett kaputt.
Und das ist halt in Final Cut zum gewissen Teil halt auch so drin. Also weißt du noch, früher bei Final Cut hat es ja auch so wie beim Audio-Tool fast eine Tracks.
Ja, aber das ganze Asset-Management ist von Final Cut so viel besser. Und auch diese ganze Logik, die da drin ist, muss man halt erstmal verstehen. Aber es ist einfach, was so die Speicherökonomie, Zurichsgeschwindigkeit und Aufhindbarkeit von FU betrifft, das ist schon sehr geil. Also das finde ich klasse und ich kam mit Final Cut Pro X auch auf Anhieb zurecht, mit so kleinen Hackeligkeiten, wie ich übrigens auch damals mit Final Cut Pro überhaupt auch vom Start weg gut klar kam. Trotzdem, ich finde das neue User-Interface.
Das ist auf jeden Fall viel besser.
Das ist auch diese Timeline, dass das so magnetisch ist und so weiter, dass es so ein Müttersprung ist.
Es ist auf jeden Fall auch, wie gesagt, zigmal besser als dieses iMovie. Kann es sein, iLife wurde auch schon eine lange Zeit nicht mehr geupdatet, ne?
Ja, wollen wir uns mal über iWork unterhalten? Gleich, gleich. Arbeite mit der Version 09.
Gleich, gleich. Ähm, und jetzt nur noch so am Rande, also das Final Cut, da werde ich mal von der Trial-Version vielleicht auch demnächst mal auf die Pro-Version umsteigen, weil das jetzt zumindest mal gezeigt hat, dass es jetzt meinen Anforderungen gerecht werden kann. Und dann hat mir ein Hörer einen Tipp gegeben für Leute, die Audio und Video von unterschiedlichen Quellen sünden wollen. Und zwar gibt es da ein Tool, das heißt Plural Eyes. Und das benutzen wohl so Filmleute, um eben ihre Audiospuren mit dem Video zu sünden. Das kostet halt so viel wie so ein Final Cut. Oder so in dem Dreh war das, glaube ich, Red Giant Plural Eyes heißt das irgendwie. Und das ist wohl so ein Tool, was dann eben automatisch versucht, sozusagen deine Audiospuren zu sünden, indem es halt eben die Audiospuren analysiert.
1099.
Ich habe es jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert, aber wie gesagt, ein Filmmensch, der durchaus schon ein paar Mal gemacht hat, mit Film editieren, der hat gemeint, das würden wohl die Leute so benutzen.
Tim, du denkst gerade dran, Remote-Podcasts zu sünden, oder was hast du gerade am Auge?
Nö, ich interessiere mich generell für das Thema SYNC.
SYNC, that's faster than a cup of coffee.
Ja, also, dass all die Leute, die da ambitioniert am Video und Audio zusammen mixen sind. Ja, aber ansonsten auf jeden Fall kann man abschließend sagen, weil es ja da am Anfang auch so fett die Dramen um Final Cut Pro gingen, also das Interface ist wirklich jetzt schon mal sehr viel aufgeräumt und angenehm. Also bei Final Cut 7 war das ja auch alles so unter zig Menüs oder Einstellungsdialogen versteckt.
Das war vor allem noch die gute, alte Makromedia-Sicht auf User Interface. Das steckt ja da ganz tief drin. Das merkt man auch.
Ich frage mich auch, ob jetzt zum Beispiel dadurch, dass jetzt irgendwie diese ganzen analogen Formate sozusagen so langsam jetzt auch wegfallen und also irgendwie habe ich auch, ja, weiß nicht. Analog.
Das liegt immer.
Also bei Final Cut habe ich mich auch immer mit diesen ganzen analog bezogenen Videoeinstellungen so ein bisschen überfordert gefühlt und da ist jetzt alles schon so, hier willst du ein File, willst du ins Web, willst du aufs Apple-Device. Das haben wir jetzt bei Final Cut glücklicherweise auch gleich so in diesen ganzen Workflow-Presets so schön mit reingezogen, dass man nicht erst groß überlegen muss, was man jetzt eigentlich haben will.
Das bringt uns zum nächsten Thema, falls du sonst nichts mehr anmerken möchtest.
Roddy, du weißt schon, ne? Ja, ich habe mir ein Logic Pro X gegönnt und habe das also tatsächlich auch ein paar paar Abende lang probiert und ich muss sagen, ich bin ganz angetan. Das ist das erste Logic, von dem ich das Gefühl habe, das möchte ich nicht innerhalb von 30 Sekunden wieder zumachen.
Und du weißt sehr, wovon du redest. Wir erinnern daran, du hast ja deine Hände drin gebadet.
Na, in Logic selber nicht. Aber lustigerweise gibt es, warte mal, kannst du nochmal das Ding ins Anmachen?
Ah, wir bekommen eine Live-Verführung hier.
Ja, prinzipiell. Also, ach so, ich muss jetzt...
Den Sound auch gleich einspielen?
Ja, wenn ihr das wirklich hören wollt. Es gibt immer noch diese Musik-Tastatur.
Kannst du mal oben gucken, was dein Sound-Device jetzt ist?
Mein Sound-Device.
Rechts dein Sound-Device, rechts Sound-Device.
Alt auf Sound klicken.
Sound-Device.
Das da?
Da muss man immer klären, wie man ein Mac bedient.
So, dann geh doch mal auf Black Magic.
Und jetzt hat er dein Video da rausgeschmissen.
Das ist ja interessant.
Ist nicht bei Video-Audio-Automatik dabei?
Ja, eigentlich müsste doch beim Video das Audio mit dabei sein.
Ja, da gibt es Obskure.
Also ich mach das nochmal hier mit Airplay. Na, wie auch immer. Also es gibt diese Musik-Tastatur noch, die ich irgendwann mal gebaut habe.
Hast du jetzt den Ton hier drauf?
Ich glaube schon. Warte mal, ich mach das hier mal auf meinem.
Gib Sound.
Nein, mach doch mal da oben. Fick doch nochmal da drauf, ob es jetzt umgestellt ist.
Nee, es ist immer noch internes Mikrofon.
Nein, nicht die Input, der Output.
Ja, er guckt hier auf seinem Screen gerade in der Menüleiste.
Ja, aber ein Mikrofon ist keine Ausgabe.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Ausgabe-Gerät, du hast kein Ausgabe-Gerät gesetzt.
Mischpult oder Black Magic?
Du kannst auch mal Mischpult machen, ist egal. Mischpult kannst du auch machen, falls er das besser verkraftet. Also ich würde ja behaupten, er fliegt jedes Mal mit seinem Airplay raus. Kannst du mal, bevor du das umstellst, wir machen das jetzt nochmal.
Liebe Hörer, sei tapfer.
In den Sound-Preferenz. Stell das jetzt mal auf Black Magic vorher.
In den Systemeinstellungen? In Systemeinstellungen, wo ist denn der jetzt? Rechts oben. Ton, Ton, Ton, Ton.
Kannst du es einstellen?
Der steht jetzt auf dem Mischpult.
Kannst du auch den Black Magic einstellen?
Ja, kann ich auch.
Bleib da auch drauf, spring nicht weg und hopf nicht.
Nein, bleib drauf. Und jetzt mach mal deinen Screen-Fu an.
Und jetzt nochmal gucken, wie es aussieht.
Der ist immer noch angewählt hier.
Ja, mach mal Lautstärke an. Lautstärke einschalten.
Mehr? Mehr, mehr.
Max, Max, Max, gib alles. Jetzt was spielen.
So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken. Das hast du so einfach. Weil ich muss jetzt natürlich hier noch gucken, ob ich da Output-Gerät Airplay...
Ach so, weil Logic macht das ja eh nochmal separat.
Logic macht das eh nochmal separat, genau.
Das hätten wir auch einfacher haben können.
Okay, er sagt auch nochmal Chor-Audio initialisieren.
Hast du das komponiert oder?
Ich hab das komponiert. Ich hab das sogar...
Punk-Gitarre sehe ich...
.komplett selber geschrieben. Also bis auf den Drama vielleicht.
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Man hört nichts, super.
Nee, man hört nichts. Achso, aber du bist jetzt auf Mischpult oder auf Apple TV?
Da ist wieder nichts. Obscur.
Ja, aber du gibst doch jetzt direkt da drauf aus, oder? Das ist alles braun. Das funktioniert alles.
Ich bleib mal hier, jetzt könnt ihr halt nur hören. Jetzt könnt ihr halt nur hören.
So.
Will man überhaupt was hören?
Ja, hier müsste eigentlich was kommen. Das ist Schalme.
Audi Routing in 2013.
Vor allen Dingen, im Logic steht ja nur Airplay. Das steht ja nicht Black Magic. Also wer weiß.
Ja, vielleicht muss man dann hier den Ausgang noch auf den anderen. Okay, vielleicht ist es...
Habt ihr mal noch ein Bier?
Nee, muss noch fahren nachher.
Ich will. Nein, OSC will ich nicht.
Okay, lassen wir das mit der Musik.
Lassen wir das mit der Musik. Aber ich kann mal so ein bisschen drüber reden.
Warum müsst ihr ja noch eine Miniklinke haben, wenn alle Stricke reißen?
Eine Miniklinke? Ja, dann gib mir die mal.
Könnt ihr auch noch mal ausprobieren? Ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, ob die...
Nee, ich hab schon zwei getrunken und jetzt muss ich erst mal dieses hier gewerkelt bekommen. So.
Weiß ich aber jetzt auch nicht, ob da zuverlässig Sound bei rauskommt.
Erst mal den Expander-Regeln.
Ich hör was.
Something's coming.
Vielleicht ein bisschen lauter.
Da musst du nicht nur plus minus machen, sondern nur plus plus plus.
Mach mal aus. 19, 20... Bist du sicher, dass du nicht über Apple TV kommst jetzt gerade?
Das kann schon sein, aber...
Jetzt kommst du nämlich über Apple TV.
Jetzt komm ich über Apple TV.
Jetzt, wo du die Klinke herangeschickt hast.
Super. Na gut, also. Mach mal lauter. Oder?
Spiel mir erstmal was. Dann kann ich es auch lauter machen.
Ja hier.
Mehr geht nicht.
Also das reicht doch die Leute.
Jetzt müsste man die mal aus dem Örb kicken.
Wieder. Ich weiß nicht, worum es knallt.
Warum sind das da viele Spuren?
Bitte dein System-Audio-Device mal auf was anderes stellen.
Mein System-Audio-Device?
Ja, und das Logic, nur das Logic.
Aber so ein Peitschen würde doch in den Song so mit reinpassen.
Aber das Geknacken finde ich ja jetzt mal obskur.
Das ist nicht in deiner Anlage.
Das kommt von deiner Seite. Das ist aber jetzt komplett Airplay. Du bist über W-Lanen. Nee, über Kabel bist du ja drin.
Über beides.
Ja, aber das geht ja nur über Ethernet. Du bist ja in dem Public-Netz, oder? In dem W-Lanen.
Das hat mit dem nichts zu tun.
Jetzt haben wir den ganzen Podcast-Tag knackt.
Oh, was ist mit dem Expander los?
Download ist fertig, vielleicht ist es jetzt besser. Na, wie gesagt, vielleicht rede ich noch ein bisschen über das Final Cut. Was lustig ist, man kann...
Logic. Das Logic.
Können wir das Knast dann auch ausmachen wieder?
Ja, ich kann das Knast dann ausmachen.
Machen wir aus, genau.
Also so viel zur Live-Demo.
Also, wenn man hier so eine Gesangsspur aufnimmt, dann kann man das im Loop machen. Und, Moment, ich mach mal ein bisschen größer, dass man auch was erkennen kann.
Gab's diese Track Groups schon vorher?
Doch, die Track Groups gab's vorher schon auch, aber das war vorher nicht so ganz so einfach zu benutzen. Hatte ich immer das Gefühl. So, und jetzt kannst du ein sogenanntes Comp erstellen. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt von den vier Aufnahmen, die du hier untereinander siehst, kannst du sagen, ich nehme jetzt das Stück von der vierten Aufnahme, dann nehme ich als nächstes was von der dritten Aufnahme, dann nehme ich was von der vierten Aufnahme.
Immer das, was am besten klingt.
Genau, immer das, was am besten klingt, wo man sich nicht so verhauen hat. Es gibt da irgendwie für Gesamtsaufnahmen noch eine Korrektur in der Tonhöhe, aber die habe ich natürlich nicht verwenden müssen. Insofern weiß ich nicht.
Weil es eh egal ist.
Ja, entweder es ist eh egal oder keine Ahnung. Also auf jeden Fall. Das hätte ich ja überhaupt erst mal rausfinden müssen, wo das ist. Kann ich jetzt auf der Seite rausziehen? Das ist schon mal ganz cool. Das war irgendwie neu. Was auch neu ist, sind diese Drummer. Und zwar die haben da... Kann ich jetzt hier mal... Hier kann ich das zeigen. Es gibt da so einen Drum Track. Und da gibt es dann... Wo ist jetzt mein Drummer?
Das jetzt so ruckig aussieht, nur weil es jetzt hier eher Video ist, ja?
Es gibt also tausende so... Ah, ich weiß, das muss... Wo hab ich denn?
Ich seh schon, ich hab's nicht.
Ich hab's schon zwei Wochen nicht mehr benutzt. Deswegen ist es jetzt ein bisschen schwierig. Nee, das war es nicht. Das war es auch nicht. Da unten muss man irgendwie hochklappen. Irgendwie muss man von unten hochklappen.
Ist da vielleicht da, wenn du da auf links unten Portland klickst?
Nee, nee, das ist was anderes. Na gut, dann zeig ich euch das eben auf dem iPad. Weil es gibt ja noch diese... Ja, es gibt noch die Logic Remote dazu. Mal sehen, ob der sich jetzt auf einen verbindet. Da kriegt man dann teilweise die Views, die man in dem Logic hätte, kriegt man dann auch auf dem iPad. Nee, für einen Drummer gibt es das natürlich nicht. Super, oder?
Ja, also man kann damit jemanden, der Schlagzeugspiel simulieren.
Ja, und zwar es gibt da extrem viele Schlagzeug-Simulationen. Und das Lustige ist, die sind so in Typen eingeteilt. Man hat immer so den Schattenriss von so einem Punk und von so einem Typ mit langen Haaren, so einem Mettler und so einem Grunge-Typ und so weiter. Und dann klickt man den an und man macht dieses Schlagzeug an und hat direkt das Gefühl, ja, genau, das ist so ein Typ, der spielt genau so Schlagzeug.
Ja, aber der eine ist halt wirklich so ein Prügel-Punk-Schlagzeuger und der andere ist halt eher so, weiß ich nicht, wie man es von Soundgarden kennt oder so und so ein Zeug. Also das ist schon sehr geil.
Kann man auch so irgendwo die Charakteristika so einstellen? Den Slider mit irgendwie Zottel, mehr Zottel, weniger Zottel?
Ja, aber du hast so ein Sliderfeld, von oben nach unten hast du laut und leise und von rechts nach links hast du einfach und komplex. Und das funktioniert auch relativ gut. Also diese Drummer sind schon geil, da kann man echt Stunden davor sitzen und sich nur Schlagzeug anhören. Aber es kommt mit einer Downside, die Mediendownloads sind extrem groß. Also irgendwie...
Um die Dinger zu installieren meinst du?
Ja, das Teil, wenn du es so runterlädst, ich glaube es sind nur 600 Megabyte oder so, nur in Anführungszeichen. Aber du kannst dann irgendwie 50 Gigabyte Sounddaten runterladen. Also so die Drummer kosten alle jeweils so 2-3 Gigabyte und dann gibt es irgendwie noch so ein Grand Piano, was nochmal 5, 3 oder 4 kostet oder so. Und dann kriegst du die ganzen Garage Band Instrumente und dieses und jenes und sonst was. Und ich bin da blöd geworden vor allen Dingen. Was ein bisschen schwierig ist zu finden, wenn du halt einen Garage Band Song aufmachst, dann welche Sounds brauche ich jetzt eigentlich, damit ich alle Spuren höre? Weil er das natürlich irgendwie, also was heißt natürlich, er zeigt es dir halt nicht an. So nach der Art, hier spielt, hier fehlt was, klick jetzt auf runterladen und dann geht's. Das hat er irgendwie nicht dabei.
Und das heißt, wenn man das jetzt in seiner Timeline positioniert, ist das quasi so eine parametrische Geschichte, die man zu jedem Zeitpunkt immer ändern kann.
Was?
Ich kann was weiß ich da schon alles fertig komponieren mit einem bestimmten Drama und kann dann nachträglich die Komplexität, mit der er da gerade trommelt, nochmal ändern.
Ja, im Prinzip schon. Also, ja, du kriegst, also...
Also nicht so, dass er das einmal in fertiges Audio rausrendert und dann arbeitest du damit weiter?
Nee, nee.
Es bleibt parametrisch bis zum Schluss?
Ja, ja, es bleibt parametrisch bis zum Schluss, aber wird wahrscheinlich irgendwo auch Spuren freezeen. Also sprich, das Rausrendern irgendwo, sich halten und solange du nicht an den Parametern drehst, rechne das nicht jedes Mal neu.
Okay, was ist noch toll?
Was sehr geil ist, es gibt den erweiterten Modus und den super erweiterten Profi-Modus. Also irgendwie, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie die heißen, aber auf jeden Fall hast du hier einmal erweiterte Werkzeuge einblenden und dann noch die zusätzlichen Optionen. Das geile ist, wenn du, so wie ich das gemacht hast, einen Song nimmst, was du in Logic 9 aufgemacht hast, kriegst du automatisch alle Funktionen. Aber es war trotzdem nicht schlimm. Also es hat nicht viel getan.
Ich bin schockiert, dass jetzt hier irgendwie in dieser Runde der Trend allgemein scheinbar zu deutschen User Interfaces geht.
Was? Wieso?
Wieso benutzt du denn dein Mac OS und dein Logic auf Deutsch?
Vielleicht war das...
Du, das mach ich eigentlich seit ich den Amiga nicht mehr hab und kein Englisch benutzen mehr muss.
Aber die deutsche Übersetzung ist immer so schlecht.
Und man findet doch im Netz gleich viel besser, wenn man den Englischen und sich nicht überlegen muss, wie könnte es jetzt in Englisch heißen?
Das kann ich aber. Das krieg ich hin. Das krieg ich hin.
Es ist ja nicht so furchtbar schlimm, normalerweise, auf dem Weg.
Doch.
Also ich komm damit...
Da hast du noch nicht befinden, wo du gearbeitet hast.
Was ich schlimm finde, ist Englisch. Wenn die Leute den Scheiß mixen, das kann ich gar nicht ab.
Hab ich dir auch gemacht jetzt, oder?
Na manchmal macht es ja einfach keinen Sinn, ein deutsches Wort zu erfinden.
Wo war denn das hier? Also was wirklich schlimm ist, wo es mich echt gekraust hat, das waren die ganzen Amp-Simulationen. Die Amp-Simulationen und die... Also man kann hier... Das sieht ganz wunderbar aus. Man kann sich das hier angucken. Paddleboard, ja, super. Und dann kann man hier so... Wenn sie irgendwo erscheinen würden.
Das war's schon immer. Hätte man auch mal besser vorbereiten können, hier die Demo, finde ich. Ich werde langsam unruhig. Ich werde das Produkt nicht kaufen, wenn es so weitergeht. Ach, ich hab's ja schon gekauft.
So war's auch. Du würdest es nicht nochmal kaufen.
Naja, also ich hab's halt gekauft, um festzustellen, dass es nichts geändert hat in den Bereichen, die für mich wichtig sind. Was sehr, sehr wenige Bereiche sind, aber es ist einfach furchtbar. Aber ich fand das User-Interface schon nochmal etwas zugänglicher.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Hast du auch auf neue Shortcuts umgestellt oder hast du die alten beibehalten?
Ich hab noch nicht auf irgendwelche Shortcuts umgestellt.
Das ist auch das erste, was er dich fragt nach dem Installieren.
Ja, wenn du das schon mal vorher hattest, wahrscheinlich.
Du, keine Ahnung, ich hab das, weiß es nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, das Reaper-Interface, das sieht vielleicht hässlicher aus von den Icons, aber von der Übersichtlichkeit wieder so, ich meine, ich finde das jetzt nicht unbedingt sehr viel übersichtlicher.
Diese Amp-Simulationen sind echt ganz schlimm. Also erstens klingen sie alle gleich und alle schlecht, also sie sind wirklich alle ganz gruselig, keine Ahnung, die haben wahrscheinlich keine Amps zu Hause und spielen nicht Gitarre oder so.
Zum Beispiel Amplitube, also es gibt ja andere Firmen, die so Amp-Synthesisierung machen und da klingen die Amps schon sehr viel besser. Bei Apple ist das noch nicht so ganz so.
Nee, also die sind alle gruselig. Und wie gesagt, diese ganzen Tretminen, da sind, also ich hab bisher nur die ganzen Verzerrer probiert und die verzerren zwar alle wie blöd, aber gut klingen tun sie nicht.
Wir haben gerade irgendwie den Stream wieder eingebüßt, Clemens, kannst du mal gucken, was so... Jetzt ist er wieder da. Aber es scheint wieder was abgerissen zu sein.
Aber ich finde halt jetzt hier bei Logic, also irgendwie es gibt das Menü, es gibt irgendwie Präferenzen, dann gibt es links was rein und rausfährt, es gibt unten was rein und rausfährt, es kommt irgendwie was von rechts rein, also irgendwie, es ist halt irgendwie so multidimensional. Dann gibt es hier so ein Overlay, guck mal diesen schwarzen Rand, also vom User Interface übersichtlich. Sieht vielleicht hübscher aus, aber übersichtlich erinnert mich das nicht.
Also wenn man Logic 9 ein bisschen benutzt hat, dann sieht man hier auf jeden Fall deutliche Fortschritte. Und sie haben es geschafft, sagen wir mal, den generellen Stil beizubehalten. Ich meine, sie haben ja schon mal vorher vereinfacht, im Schritt von 7 auf 8 oder 8 auf 9. Da haben sie ja das User-Interface schon mal auf Single-Window umgestellt. Und jetzt haben sie quasi auch, wie alles angeordnet ist, noch mal sinnvoller gestaltet. Gewöhnungsbedürftig sind solche komplexen Programme immer. Aber ich meine, gut rieper hin, rieper her, das ist einfach... Also, weißt du, diese ganzen Settings-Dialoge mit irgendwie Fließtext als Einstellung...
Also, die ganzen Tasteninstrumente sind schon groß, zum großen Teil ziemlich geil. Also, das muss man schon sagen.
Leider für Podcastern nicht zu gebrauchen nach wie vor.
Ja, man spricht ja auch, macht nicht Musik als Podcast.
Ne, einfach so Sachen wie Kapitelmarken. Ich meine, du kannst zwar supergeil hier Regionen markieren, aber du kriegst die Scheiße nicht exportieren. Es gibt einfach keine Möglichkeiten, diese Metadaten der Bearbeitung zu exportieren. Was vielleicht nochmal interessant wäre, zu schauen, ob da in den Dateien, die sie da schreiben, irgendwelche XML-Files rumliegen oder so. Aber ich glaube, die Zeit, wo sie so Bundles benutzt haben, ist auch vorbei, oder?
Kann das Ding nicht auch so Project-Files schreiben, wie Final Cut oder so, in irgendein XML-Format oder irgendwas? Nein, ja, ein Mühe gegen einen Herrn.
Brauche ich die Frage? Nein, weiß ich nicht. Ja, sie schreiben irgendwas.
Guck mal da oben, bei Ablage oder so gibt es da irgendwie Export.
Ja, es gibt hier eine Menge Zeug zum Exportieren.
Und wir können, warte, warte, warte.
Projekt an Final Cut Pro XML.
Na bitte, da hast du doch deinen ganzen Quack. Da hast du ein XML-Filechen. Und dann musst du den angucken, was da rauskommt.
Was auch ein bisschen verwirrend ist, was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen Exportieren, Bouncen und Bereitstellen?
Bereitstellen heißt Ländern. Ja, aber Bouncen ja eigentlich auch.
Bouncen ist halt die Bezeichnung für das eigentliche Herausrendern des eigentlichen Projekts. Das Erstellen der finalen Musikdatei.
Ja, hier steht Bereitstellen für iTunes, Medienübersicht und Soundcloud.
Exportieren exportiert halt irgendwas, aber nicht zwangsläufig den Sound.
Aber nochmal, da dieses Projekt an Final Cut Pro XML, da kriegst du den ganzen Metascheiß raus.
Du bist dir sicher, dass da die Kapitelinformationen drin sind?
Ich hab hier keine Kapitel drin. Also das muss Tim dann schon selber ausprobieren.
Ja, das ist interessant. Ich sehe auch gerade, dass die Logic X-Dinger tatsächlich Ordner sind. Da lohnt sich unter Umständen auch nochmal diese ganze P-List-Geschichte.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin da ganz zufrieden mit. Das ist so das erste, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, das kann ich auch benutzen. Also vorher, ich weiß nicht, mein erster Eindruck von Logic 7 war so, irgendwie nur Fenster, nur Fenster und dann tausende Möglichkeiten, diese Fenster anzuordnen mit auf einem Zehnerblock gespeicherten Fenstersets und so. Das war uhu.
Moment, machen wir weiter.
Mein Flieger geht gleich.
Eine Kapitelmarke für, willst du vorzeitig abreisen?
Ausbrechen.
Ich such gerade vergeblich, ach so, ich mach mal hier die andere Schrönung an. Ich hoffe, dass es jetzt auch mit dem Stream sich wieder eingependelt hat.
Das war gerade eben noch Roddys primäres Display.
Ich wollte gerade Airplay trennen machen, aber Gott sei Dank hat man ja jetzt in Mavericks auf jedem Bildschirm eine Menüleiste.
Ja. Sonst hätte ich ein Problem gehabt.
Keine zehn Jahre später.
Ich hab noch eine kleine Sache, wenn du gerade schon beim nächsten Thema suchen bist. Ich bin ja jeder ZFS-Guy.
Ich bin sogar wach bei dem Thema.
Es gibt ja hier das OpenZFS und wie Roddy schon meinte, da gibt es ja so einen Typen, der sich um den OS X-Port kümmert.
Lundmann.
Genau, und der scheint wohl wirklich dolle loszulegen.
Ich mach das seit Monaten.
Es war auch gerade die EuroBSDCon, also das ist immer so eine Konferenz für FreeBSD und da waren die OpenZFS-Jungs auch. Also dieser Typ, der Matt Ahrens heißt. Und mit einem von den FreeBSD-Codern und die haben dann Vortrag gehalten und da haben sie auch mal aufgelistet Illumos, FreeBSD, Linux und OS X. Und wie viele Commits die so liefern. Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung hab, dann ist der OS X, der liefert gerade für ZFS die meisten Commits. Wahrscheinlich nicht pur an ZFS, sondern das, was er importiert. Aber der Typ ist da auf jeden Fall sehr stark aktiv und dass er so richtig auch von OpenZFS mit erwähnt wird, heißt auch, dass da wohl richtig was im Gange ist und dass nicht wieder nur irgendeiner es erst mal versucht und in drei Wochen aufhört, weil er da nicht weiterkommt. Also da scheint ein bisschen was mehr mal stattzufinden.
Ein Major Contributor.
Ja, doch, deutlich. Auch Linux, da passiert echt ne Menge. Also es kann dem ZFS nur gut tun, dass da jetzt viel mehr Leute drauf gucken und dass sie sich da mal so ein bisschen einigen.
Du meinst, wir kriegen mittelfristig dann vielleicht sogar mal irgendwann mal ne Situation, wo man einfach ein Fallsystem auf ne externen Platte umstecken kann, ohne dass es nen Bluescreen gibt?
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht.
Wenn du es vorher exportierst.
Vor diesem Cevo war ich ja auch nicht mehr angetan. Aber ich hoffe, dass das neue... Dass das neue...
Läuft übrigens nicht auf Mavericks, ne?
Cevo. Ja.
Cevo wird schon weg.
Hat er mir beim installieren auch gleich deinstalliert?
Ja, WebKit gibt's grad auch noch nicht für Mavericks. Egal. Jedenfalls, was wir da noch erzählt haben bei diesem Talk, ist... Ich weiß nicht, ob viele Leute es kennen, aber ich hab halt einen ZFS-Rechner, wo ich immer dicke Filme draufschiebe mit Geek-Easternet und ich kann auch irgendwie mit 100, ja so 112 MB die Sekunde, also was so wirklich das Limit von Geek-Easternet ist, irgendwie da Movies draufschieben oder dicke große Files und so nach so ein paar...
Deine Heimporno-Produktion, die ist auch wirklich am...
Kann er live draufspielen.
Heimspielfilme.
Und jedenfalls spiele ich so drauf und nach so ein paar 100 MB, wenn der Cache halt irgendwie voll ist, dann bleibt irgendwie die Sache stehen, dann passiert zehn Sekunden lang nichts. ZFS muss irgendwie komplett sein Cache leeren, auch nicht asynchron, sondern da geht halt da nichts. Und wenn er damit fertig ist, dann kann ich wieder weiter mit 112 MB die Sekunde rüberschieben. Aber effektiv kommen dann am Ende irgendwie nur 50, 60 MB die Sekunde irgendwie dabei raus und das ist ganz schön scheiße. Und dieser Matt Ahrens hat sich mal hingesetzt...
So mit drehenden Teilen dran? Ja, das sollte nicht ungewöhnlich, eine Platte mit drehenden Teilen nach einer gewissen Zeit eben auch mal sagen, ich muss jetzt mal drehen.
Du machst ja den Cache voll, er wartet bis der Cache voll ist und dann hält er alles an, um die Daten rauszuschreiben. Und du kannst ja auch gucken, er schreibt die ja relativ schnell auf die Platte raus, aber 500, 600 MB braucht halt seine 5, 6 Sekunden, bis es auf die Platte weggeschrieben ist. Und danach lässt er mich erst irgendwie weiter Daten schieben. So, und die Samet Ahrens hat sich jetzt dieses Ding mal angeguckt, das ist ja der ganze Cache, und hat den mal so umgeschrieben, dass es halt... Also wenn du den Cache nicht voll schreibst, dann schreibt er das ZFS alle 5 Sekunden auch immer so parallel und asynchron, Daten weg, wenn der Cache aber voll ist. Dann irgendwie kommt da so ein Special Case irgendwie und dann steht irgendwie alles, bis der irgendwie seinen Cache wieder komplett abgearbeitet hat. Und das ist ganz schön scheiße, wenn du den zu schnell voll machst. Und der hat das jetzt umgeschrieben, dass halt das nicht mehr passiert, sondern auch parallel, während du den Cache füllst, da auch ein Prozess ist, der den Cache auch wieder entleert. Asynchron. Und ja, und das sollte, dieses Problem, was ich vorhin geschädet hab, das halt ab und zu mal 10 Sekunden stehen bleibt, das sollte damit irgendwie behoben sein. Wann der Patch dann auch mal bei freebies.de auftaucht, das weiß ich noch nicht. Aber ich hoffe, das ist die Lösung, weil es hat mich schon immer genervt. Ich hab's nie verstanden, warum das bei ZFS plötzlich so eigentlich ist. Ja, sollte nicht sein. Hat er auf jeden Fall gefixt, soll jetzt alles voll schick sein. So, und dann die zweite Sache, weil ich hab...
Dritte.
Ja, dritte, Entschuldigung. Gut aufgepasst, Watten. Hab vor zwei, drei Jahren schon mal hier mit dem LZJB Decompression Algorithmus rumgespielt und den ein bisschen schneller gemacht. Hab da bei diesen freebies.de Haupttypen, diesen Pavel Davidek oder wie heißt der, der zuerst ZFS da auf freebies.de gemacht hat in 10 Tagen oder wie er es damals geschrieben hatte, mal diesen Patch geschickt und so, der macht irgendwie das Decompression so 7% schneller, zumindest in meinem Testcase. Kam keine Antwort und dachte mir, okay, ist wahrscheinlich nicht interessant genug, wie auch immer. Und dann hab ich mir jetzt irgendwie letzte Woche gedacht, naja, ist ja gerade so Open ZFS Hype, ich will ja auch so meinen Beitrag leisten, schick ich die Mail mal nochmal, hab aber diesmal einen anderen Typen genommen, mit dem ich letztens schon mal was wegen der LZ4 Compression da geschrieben hab. Und schon nach 9 Stunden war das Ding gleich bei freebies.de committed und der hat mir zurückgeschrieben, ja, hier Impressive und so und das Ding ist jetzt drin. Das heißt, alle ZFS Pakete gehen jetzt durch meinen verbesserten LZJP-Decompression-Routen durch.
Wenn sie die denn benutzen?
Wissen wir ja, wo die Datenkorruption herkommt.
Ja, Metadaten werden immer mit LZJP komprimiert und dekomprimiert. Also 6-7% ist nicht viel, aber es war nur so ein ganz kleiner Patch und der hat's einfach gebracht. Und ich hab jetzt mit dem Erdgeist hier, der auch OpenTracker macht, das ist ja so ein Hardcore Assembler und C-Coder und so. Wir haben uns das Ding nochmal angeguckt und haben auch schon mehrere Sachen gefunden, aber irgendwie so richtig so was Schickes, Direktes, was auf allen Plattformen auch was bringt und nicht nur auf einer CPU, auf der anderen nicht. Haben wir jetzt noch nicht so wirklich gefunden. Und er meinte, wir müssten einfach mal so komplett neu schreiben, so von vorne. Ist ja auch nur, ist gar nicht so viel Code, den man da bräuchte, aber das haben wir noch nicht gemacht. Vielleicht finden wir ja nochmal was. Ich hatte da so verschiedene Ideen, aber der Patch ist auf jeden Fall seit letzter Woche drin und in der nächsten Woche müsste er dann auch an FreeBSD Stable landen und wann die anderen Plattformen aufnehmen.
Ist das deine erste FreeBSD-Kontribution?
Nee, ich hab auch mit dem Erdgeist zusammen, haben wir uns schon mal irgendwie was angeguckt. Irgendwo so ein Zero Copy in FreeBSD und alles hat funktioniert. Also wir haben noch Zero Copy irgendwas umgestellt und wir waren dann mal so schlau und haben einfach mal probiert, so was Jux, was passiert, wenn ich eine Paketgröße von Null angebe. Zero Copy ist so, wenn, ja, ist schwierig zu erklären, weil manche sehen es so, manche so. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es gut hinkriege. Also wenn du dem Colonel irgendwelche Daten gibst, dann muss der Colonel die Daten nicht erst irgendwie so kopieren, sondern nimmt die gleich von dort, wo du liegen. Oder wenn der Colonel dir Daten bereitstellt, dann macht er sie dir gleich da an, wo du sie haben willst. Und du musst sie dir nicht holen und nochmal extra eine Sache kopieren. Das heißt, ein Copy-Vorgang fällt irgendwie weg. Und Zero Copy heißt eigentlich, dass alle Copy-Vorgänge wegfallen. Also zum Beispiel die Netzerkarte packt das Paket gleich da an, wo du das irgendwie haben willst, ohne dass es nochmal umhergeschoben werden muss. Also meistens ist es nicht Zero Copy, sondern Minus One Copy, also dass du einmal weniger kopierst. Und jedenfalls haben wir herausgefunden, dass der Typ irgendwie nicht gegen Null checkt, oder irgendwie so. Und wenn du die Paketgröße von Null angibst, irgendwie bei so einem Http-Get oder irgendwie sowas, irgendwas. Jedenfalls haben wir da so einen Bug gefunden. Also ich hab schon öfter mal was bei ZFS, der dir gelingt. Ich hab auch schon mal einen anderen ZFS-Bug gefunden. Und zwar, wenn man keine Rechte hat an ZFS, also du brauchst ja Rudrechte, um was am Pool zu ändern. Und wenn ich aber einen Command abgesetzt habe ohne Rudrechte und da zurückkommt, ja, den darfst du aber gar nicht absenden, dann ist dieses Command trotzdem in einer ZFS-History gelandet. Obwohl ich eigentlich gar keine Rudrechte hab und der überhaupt gar nicht irgendwie was am Pool ändern müsste, weil wurde mir ja eh nicht erlaubt. Und das war eindeutig ein, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Security-Bug ist, aber auf jeden Fall sollte das da nicht landen. Und der hat sich auch bedankt und hat den dann weggefixt.
Hier der Patrick Stein, der Jolly, der diesen Jollies Fast VNC macht und so. Der hat irgendwie auch mit ZFS rumgespielt und hat so ein total obskures Ding gefunden. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche ZFS-Variante er gerade im Test hatte. Aber er hat so einfach mal so ein Hello World Programm gemacht, so was, so cchello.c. Starten lassen, so mit print hello world, irgendwie sleep1-loop. Hat also mal hello world ausgegeben. Das Ding lief dann weiter, das a.out sozusagen lief dann weiter. Und dann hat er den Code geändert und das World in Großbuchstaben gemacht. Neu compiled in dieselbe Datei. Schwupps, ohne dass das Programm neu starten musste, lief das neue Binary und er hat das World in Großbuchstaben gemacht. Ja das hat so nicht zu sein, wenn ein executable geöffnet ist.
Das war schon früher so. Früher sind die die Dinger dann gerne gecrasht. Es gab Zeiten, da musstest du immer genau wie bei Windows deine Drecks-Applikationen erst runterfahren, bevor du neue installierst. Was?
Bei welchem OS?
Unter Unix.
Welchem?
Alle möglichen, seitdem du sozusagen mit Shared Objects arbeitest und seitdem der Kernel direkt aus dem Fallsystem deine Dinger ins Virtual Memory importiert. Du musst dir überlegen, wenn du das mit HFS machst, ist das nicht so. Nochmal, HFS ist ja kein Unix und OS X ist auch kein Unix. Nein, das ist ein Fallsystem. Wenn du zum Beispiel ein Solaris nimmst, ein gutes, altes Solaris, Solaris 9 oder so was, und du hast eine Applikation dort laufen, dann wird das Executable selber ins Virtual Memory eingeblendet. Und wenn du dann über die Datei rüberschreibst und das an falschen Stellen machst, während die Applikation läuft, crash das Ding. Deswegen musst du dort deine Applikation runterfahren, bevor du sie überschreibst. Das war schon immer so. Das ist bei diesen Virtual Memory Systemen so. Jetzt hat er natürlich Folgendes gemacht. Er hat dasselbe Binary erzeugt, wo er nur ein String geändert hat. Und das ist natürlich nicht tödlich. Deswegen kann die natürlich auch weiter laufen. Das ist nicht das Problem.
Aber sonst ist das so.
Clemens beißt mich, aber ich kann mich irgendwie an kein Unix erinnern, was ich benutzt habe, wo das so war.
Ich auch nicht. Seit Urzeiten. Das war bei Xenix so, das war bei SCU Unix so. Das ist bei ATT-Tralar, das ist bei Solaris so.
Das ist eher ein Bug als ein Feature, oder?
Nein.
Wenn du das neu vor Writing schreibst und das Ding läuft irgendwie gerade und ist irgendwie gelingt, dann schreibt er doch nicht in dieselbe Datei. Da schreibt er doch ein neuer Einhol.
ZFS sowieso nicht, weil der Copy-on-Write macht. Da schreibt es ja Wonders hin. Aber Klemenz, guck, wenn du bei Free bist, wenn du dein System updatest und auch der neue Kernel geschrieben wird, dann wird doch der alte Kernel nicht überblendet oder sonstiges.
Der Kernel ist nun mal ein Programm, was echt einmal geladen wird.
Die ganzen Lips genauso. Oder alle Prozesse, die bei so einem System updaten.
Ja, aber die werden bei einem Virtual... Du schreibst ja deswegen neue Lips. Die werden ja nur gelingt. Wenn du mal anguckst, wenn du eine Lip austauschst, wie z.B. eine OpenSSL-Lip oder sonst was. Die heißt ja nicht lippssl.so oder sonst was. Sondern die heißt ja lippssl-4711-0815-talala.so und krieg dann ein symbolic Link auf lippssl.so. Wenn du das bestehende Binary überschreibst, bestehende Shared Library wirklich überschreibst, ohne sie zu truncaten oder sonst was zu machen. Also wenn du einfach nur das File zum Schreiben öffnest, ohne Truncate, ohne nix oder alles, dann kannst du einfach mitten in das Ding reinschreiben. Das war schon immer so. Nein, glaub ich nicht. Weil Executables und Shared Libraries werden nicht geladen, sondern werden eingeblendet in das Virtual Memory.
Ja, kann ja sein, aber du kannst das doch nicht überblenden dann. Du kannst ja auch deine ganzen Lips und Programme, die schon laufen, kannst du auch löschen. Und das Ding läuft ja auch weiter, weil dem ist das egal.
Das liegt daran, dass bei Unix schon immer ein File löschen konntest, während das noch jemand offen hatte. Das ist übrigens die Art und Weise, wie man früher gerne temporäre Dateien erzeugt hat. Du hast eine Datei erzeugt, die geöffnet und geanlinkt, während du noch einen offenen Filehandel drauf hattest. Dann hatte das Ding keinen Namen mehr, dann gab es die Einhut noch im Memory und dann gab es die Einhut noch auf der Platte, aber das Ding hatte keinen Namen mehr, deswegen konnte keiner an deine temporäre Datei ran, außer dir.
Und selbst wenn du abgestürzt bist, war trotzdem die App weg beim Ende.
Wenn du abstürzt, werden implizit alle Filehandel geclosed und dann merkt er, dass er einen Link-Count von Zero hat und haut die Dinge auch von der Platte runter.
Ich könnte aber schwören, dass das, was Tim da berichtet hat, auf rebius.de nicht geht.
Nehme ich mal meine alte Solaris-Kiste und für dir das live vorwiegen, das im laufenden Betrieb machen. Das mit dem Hello World. Ihr könnt ja so lange noch mal ein bisschen was anderes diskutieren. Ich habe nämlich irgendwo noch eine Solaris-9-Kiste zu laufen. Moment, ich muss mir überlegen, wie hießen die?
Ich bin gespannt. Und hat Timme den Bug dann eingedingsen und haben die was dazu gesagt? Oder weißt du das Ende der Geschichte?
Nein, keine Ahnung, was da jetzt gerade statt dem Ding ist.
Das war aber jetzt irgendwie ein Cevo-Bug oder so, ne?
Nein, kaltet nicht für ein Cevo-Bug.
Du hälst das gar nicht für ein Bug? Egal, welche Plattform.
Oder ein Cevo-Verhalten.
Ich halte das schon für ein Bug, das ist schon auch ein Security-Problem. Du kannst den Leuten ja die Executables unter dem Arsch weg ändern.
Ja, wenn du Schreibzugriffe hast, Willkommen auf unserem Planeten, dann ist das so. Das ist ein gutes Zeichen. Das muss so, ja. Das Kind schielt nicht, dass Motto kicken. So, machen wir mal einen.
Hello.c Wobei eigentlich sollte es nicht so sein.
What's next?
What's next? Ja.
Schon auch, wir haben nicht mehr so viel Zeit, ne?
Ja, mein Flieger geht gleich.
Da ist die Frage, was wir jetzt noch wirklich abhalten, hacken wollen. Wie lange sind wir denn am Senden?
Dann lass mich kurz den Hinweis auf Unibox heißt das Programm machen. Das ist ein neuer E-Mail-Client, der jetzt irgendwie in Beta ist.
Another one.
Another one. Den hatte irgendwie jemand in den letzten Kommentaren irgendwie mal hinterlassen. Und da dachte ich, probierste den mal aus. Der, ja, also er sieht ganz nett aus. Und er hat die eigene Art, was ich ganz lustig finde. hängt alle E-Mails eines, danke, dass ich jetzt auch Echo hab, er hängt alle E-Mails eines Versenders und alle Antworten untereinander, so ein bisschen wie... Genau.
Aber die ist nicht accountgetrennt.
Ich hab jetzt nur einen Account konfiguriert. Ich weiß nicht, ich wollte eigentlich noch den Härtetest machen und einen Exchange mal konfigurieren und gucken, was dann passiert. Aber da bin ich irgendwie nicht mehr zugekommen.
Was die Freak Show-Nerds in ihrer Freizeit machen. Ich hab so eine Beta von Neumail klein und um mich jetzt mal so richtig auf die Nieren zu fühlen, ja, hab ich schon überlegt, ob ich mal einen Exchange-Server aufsetze, nur mal um zu gucken, ob wir damit auch klarkämen.
Nein, ich wollte keinen Exchange-Server aufsetzen.
Jungs, da guckt er. Im laufenden Betrieb eine Executable überschrieben. Das ist genau das, was du da gesagt hast. Solaris 9.
Vielleicht ist Solaris 9 jetzt auch nicht unbedingt...
Hallo, ich kann es jetzt auch mit Solaris 8 und Solaris 10 ausprobieren, wenn ihr mir noch eine andere Kröte gebt.
Das kann ich jetzt mal hier mit Davin aus. Auf deinem HFS Plus.
Das heißt, wenn ich bei Freebase den neuen Port installiere und die App in Apache zum Beispiel schon da rumliegt, dann crasht er mir erstmal weg, oder was? Nee, habe ich ja noch nie gesehen, das ist auch noch nie passiert.
Es hängt immer davon ab, was du mit dieser Datei machst. Wenn du sie vorher löscht, ich habe sie jetzt wirklich mit drüber kopiert, wenn du die Datei löscht, dann läuft deine Applikation weiter, wie ich eben beschrieben habe. Dann gibt es keinen Namen mehr dafür, dann gibt es noch eine Einnot dafür und offenen Filehandel und so weiter und so fort. Und dann kannst du sie einfach natürlich wieder in eine neue Datei mit demselben Namen anlegen. Aber wenn du eine Datei mit derselben Einnot, wie sie vorher war, überschreibst, überschreibst du damit, das laufende Executable. Weil das in Virtual Memory eingeblendet ist. Das wird nicht geladen, sondern wird nur gemapped. Kannst du dir hier sehen, ich hab hier mein Hello World geschrieben, was Hello World ausgibt, ne Sekunde wartet, und dann reichleife. Hab nur den String geändert und drüber kopiert mit Copy. Also nicht gelöscht oder so, sondern mit Copy drüber geschrieben. Und während des Executable-Liefs hat sich der String geändert. Das machen wir jetzt selber nochmal hier unter Mavericks.
Ja, mir deucht jetzt langsam aus meiner Erinnerung heraus, dass das, was ich meine, sich tatsächlich auf das Löschen der Einnot bezieht. Und solange die dann noch ist, existiert natürlich das Executable weiter und so weiter. Aber es kann sein, dass das direkte Überschreiben auch direkte Auswirkungen hat. Aber wie gesagt, deine Verstellung war auf HFS+, das ist nicht so. Also das verhält sich dann irgendwie anders beim Neuschreiben der Datei. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht hat das auch einfach was mit den File-Options zu tun, die dabei default sind.
So eine Kleinigkeit wollte ich zu Unibox noch sagen. Sie haben ein ganz witziges Feature und zwar, wenn jemand unter einer E-Mail-Adresse ein Gravatar angemeldet hat. Das ist so eine Webseite, da kannst du unter deiner E-Mail-Adresse ein Bildchen, ein Avatar Bildchen von dir erledigen.
Überall würde ich mit der E-Mail-Adresse anmelden, dann kann sie dir automatisch von diesem Dritt-Service dein Userbild anmelden.
Genau, und das benutzen die bei Unibox auch, um dir halt noch ein paar mehr Bildchen zu geben, wer dir jetzt gerade eine E-Mail geschickt hat. Was ich ganz witzig fand, war, da tauchten plötzlich Bildchen auf von Leuten, wo ich kein Bildchen hatte.
Das macht Postbox übrigens aber auch.
So, jetzt bin ich damit auch schon durch. Ich habe wahrscheinlich auch noch wichtige Sachen vergessen, aber ja.
Ich habe auch noch zwei kleine Ups, die ich hier erwähnen wollte. Zum einen Flux, das ist so eine App, die kann man sich installieren und die dimmt so mit später werden und mit dunkler werden der Außenwelt. Was?
Ab auf welchem OS?
Geht schon ewig. Flux, die App?
Nein, welches Betriebssystem? Wenn du absagst, sagt das ja erstmal nichts. Sollen die Leute wissen, dass es hier auch mal um Mac geht?
Also Flux-Applikation für den Macintosh. Für Mac OS. Und was die tut ist, man lässt die laufen, findet raus, wo man gerade so steckt und blendet so, je dunkler es draußen wird, sozusagen das Display auch wärmer, sodass man sozusagen nicht mehr so angestrengt vom grillen Display sitzt. Das passt sozusagen die Kontraste auch mit der Außenwelt so ein bisschen an und soll für angenehmeres Arbeiten auch in den Abendstunden sorgen. Ich hab das auch eine Zeit lang benutzt, dann hab ich es irgendwann mal wo es dann wieder nicht installiert. Jetzt ist nach langer Zeit eine neue Version rausgekommen mit tollen neuen Features. Also, sind jetzt nicht so bahnbrechende Features, aber so ein paar ganz coole sind schon dabei. Unter anderem kann man dann sozusagen sein Flux-Profil, womit man einstellt, also wie warm soll es werden dein Display sozusagen, wie später es wird und wann es dunkler wird. Kannst du ein Profil machen und das an deine Philips Hue LED-Glübirnen-Installation exportieren und dann dimmt sich sozusagen nicht nur dein Display, sondern deine ganze Bude gleich mit, in ein wärmeres Interface.
So, und kann es IPv6? Tim und ich haben immer geträumt von der Glühlampe oder der LED-Leiste mit IPv6 und?
Ich weiß nicht, Philips Hue würde hier nur erwähnen, dass du das dann halt auch fluchsen kannst sozusagen. Aber das benutzen tatsächlich ziemlich viele Leute und ja, es kann schon mal ganz angenehm sein. Also gerade eben, wie gesagt, abends, wenn dann das Display einen zu sehr anschreit. Und die zweite App, die ich jetzt auch noch wirklich ganz großartig finde, die heißt Capo. Die finde ich vor allen Dingen großartig, weil das so ein einzelner Typ ist, der die schreibt. Das ist halt keine große Firma, der macht das selber und hat einfach wirklich, der hat schon ein paar Apple Design Awards damit auch abgesahnt. Was die halt tut, ist, man lädt einen Song rein, man kann den Pitch unverändert verlangsamen oder verschnellen. Das heißt, wenn man gerade Musik, also zum Beispiel, wenn man will, Gitarre spielen lernen.
Link?
Das schicke ich dir gleich.
Der ist gerade dick gefeatured im App Store, der Capo.
Der ist auch, ja, super groovy, supermegagroovy.com ist die Webseite. Ich schicke dir hier den Link. Ich habe jetzt eben die neue, die ist 3. Da ist der Link. Was sie tut, lädst du den Song rein und er zeigt dir ein Spektrum an. Du kannst den Song verlangsamen. Du kannst die Noten rausfinden. Mittlerweile erkennt er sogar die Akkorde automatisch, sozusagen von dem Song, den du reinlädst. Das heißt eben, wenn du jetzt Gitarre anfängst zu lernen, du willst einen Song nachspielen. Es gibt keine Notationen davon oder keine brauchbare Überlieferung, wie dieser Song zu spielen ist. Dann kann man mit dieser Software nicht nur den Song verlangsamen, ohne die Tonhöhe zu verändern, sondern man kann eben auch die Noten rausfinden damit.
Ja, man kann die auch so reinpinseln.
Was steht hier dazwischen?
Ach, der Mute-Button von Dennis funktioniert.
Jetzt schließe ich das kurz noch ab. Der hat, glaube ich, auch die Version 2, war mal App Store Only. Und jetzt mittlerweile verkauft er die auch wieder über seine Webseite. Ich glaube, der hatte auch mal was dazu gesagt, weil er meinte, dass mit dem App Store das hätte wohl nicht so wahnsinnig prickelnd funktioniert für ihn. Und ja, die kostet halt 29,99 Euro, ist nicht ganz günstig, aber ich weiß nicht, ich hab die schon so oft benutzt. Und weil ich halt auch weiß, dass da so ein Typ da sein Lebensunterhalt mit bestreitet, habe ich die auch sehr gerne ihm überwiesen.
Also die neue Version ist wirklich, was das Management Summary ist, das Tool ist dazu da, um was zu tun.
Songs...
Einen Song rauszuhören, besonders wenn du Gitarre spielst.
Ja, Noten, Akkorde und so weiter. Hat halt zum Beispiel so Voicefilter, kann man sich die Stimme vom Sänger halt rausfiltern, damit man nur die Musik hört. Oder man lauter so Analyse-Helfer leihen, um sozusagen selber einen Song zu Reverse-Engineeren. Genau, es ist ein Song-Reverse-Engineering-Tool. Mit einem sehr coolen Interface.
Also Kapo kommt halt von dem Namen Kapo Dasta. Das ist diese Klammer, die man in die Gitarre tut, dass man die einmal über alle Seiten abbindet, sodass man dann höher spielen kann, ohne dass man jetzt umlernen muss. Es machen gerne so, wie soll ich sagen, so Fußgängerzonen-Gitaristen. Die machen gerne so Kapo Dasta.
Aber das gibt es auch überall.
Also bei Bands sieht man das selten, dass die mit einem Kapo Dasta spielen. Das sind eher so diese...
Singer-Songwriter.
Singer-Songwriter, genau. Weil du dann auch den Song kannst du eben transponieren und dann ist er für dich in der richtigen Tonhöhe, um ihn zu singen.
Verstehe.
Aber wenn du mit einer ganzen Band spielst, müsstest du ja die ganze Band hinterher transponieren. Das geht dann nicht so flott.
Kapo, sehr, sehr schöne Software.
Okay, verstehe ich das so richtig? Wir wollen dich nicht mehr so richtig lange machen?
Ich hab grad eben, dann ist es nötig mir noch mal eine FreeBSD-Kiste zu geben. Da haben sie es inzwischen so implementiert, dass du ein File, was geladen ist, nicht überschreiben kannst, nicht mal als Super User. Der sagt, ist busy. Was ja auch Sinn macht. Verhält sich wie eine Windows-Kiste. Wenn du versuchst, ein File zu bedadeln, was jemand irgendwie in Betrieb hat, dann ist dieses Ding busy. Bei USX passiert nichts. Ob ich extra nachgeguckt habe, der Einnot ändert sich auch nicht oder sowas, aber der lädt das irgendwie wirklich. Aber bei den Dingern, die das Virtual Memory mäßig einmappen, da kannst du das Ding einfach on the fly überschreiben, während es läuft. Deswegen crashst es auch, wenn du sozusagen mal mehr änderst als nur ein String. Und den String natürlich dann auch vielleicht in seiner Länge änderst, nicht änderst oder so. Dann geht das.
Ich habe noch zwei Kulturenweise ganz kurz.
Wollen wir die vielleicht nach der Technik noch machen? Ich hätte vielleicht nur so einen. Ich weiß nicht, warum wir hier diese bitteren, Dennis, kannst du zu dieser bitteren Chatgeschichte nachher noch was sagen?
Ne, weiß ich gar nichts von.
Okay.
Hab ich nicht aufgepasst.
Wer hat das eingetragen hier? Hab ich das eingetragen? Wir müssen mal dazuschreiben, wer das macht.
Ich hab immer dazugeschrieben, wenn ich das war.
Bei der Essensbestellung.
Da auch. Vielleicht warst du das.
Da ist es besonders wichtig.
Dann war ich das wohl. Müssen wir nochmal recherchieren. Ja, dann vielleicht eine Sache. Und zwar WebRTC.
Eine Real-Time-Clock im Web?
Na, ist mehr Communication als Clock.
Bei RTC?
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall eine Erfindung von Google, was mittlerweile aber auch seine Wege in ITF-Zonen, Randgebiete gefunden hat. Also da gibt es schon aktive, das ist W3C, jetzt bin ich mir gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ne, das ist glaube ich W3C, ne? WebRTC, kurz gesagt, ist so einer, ist ein aufkommender Standard des W3C, genau. W3C, das definiert wie quasi Audio rein raus und Video rein raus über das Netz. In Real-Time Peer-to-Peer zwischen Browsern stattfinden kann. Sprich Skype-Funktionalität im Browser, um es mal ganz einfach zu sagen. Audio, Video und Data, also Chat oder was auch immer. Also sozusagen Metadata. Screensharing. Screensharing, all diese ganzen Geschichten. Und ich bin diese Woche angesprochen worden, das nochmal zu testen mit Chrome und war recht überrascht, dass es an sich ganz gut funktioniert hat. Ich poste hier auch mal so eine Testseite in den Chat, wo man sich so treffen kann und dann kann man da so Sessions aufmachen. Ich hab da jetzt gerade so ein Freak Show-Audio-Ding laufen, weiß aber jetzt gerade nicht, ob wir darüber wirklich zu hören sind. Das vermute ich aber mal, weil wenn ich hier den Lautsprecher aufmache, dann haben wir diesen Echo-Effekt hier. Ich weiß nicht, der geht jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht ohne R. Ganz sicher, auf jeden Fall war das bemerkenswert, dass das irgendwie mit Video gut geklappt hat, so ordentliche Qualität ohne Flash, mit irgendwie direkt von Browser zu Browser. Ich hab obskurerweise nur, wenn ich das hier mit meinem Mac Pro mache, Probleme mit dem Audio, was immer so verzerrt. Also immer, wenn man was sagt, ist es immer so, aber nicht übersteuert, sondern irgendwie in sich verzerrt, was dann etwas merkwürdiger Effekt ist. Jetzt sieht man das, ich hab hier die Seite offen, jetzt connecten sich hier die Leute da irgendwie in diesen Kanal, mit denen ich jetzt hier so direkt verbunden bin. Müssen wir jetzt mal unsere Bandbreite ein bisschen im Blick halten. Ich werde das auch gleich wieder zumachen, aber im Prinzip funktioniert das relativ gut. Wo kommt das denn jetzt her? Machen die sich jetzt an? Warte mal, ich mach das aus. Das User Interface kann ich euch gerade nicht so richtig erklären hier. Auf jeden Fall, da geht irgendwie was. Und es gibt jetzt auch schon erste Dienste, die da quasi eine Heimat für anbieten, wie z.B. talktawk.com. Da kann man sich quasi so eben auch mal eben so eine Session, so einen Room machen und den dann auch irgendwie embedden auf seiner Webseite und da können sich dann Leute wie so ein Mumble quasi aber eben über einen Browser treffen. Leider ist hier irgendwie Audio, Port, Eingabe und Ausgabe einstellen bei Chrome mal wieder ein totales Problem. Na ja gut, ein Roulette könnte man, ja, also, damit könntest du sicherlich so ein Chat-Roulette auch machen, aber darum geht es jetzt erstmal mir nicht primär, ja. Könnte aber sein, dass diese Technologie bald so für Remote-Podcasting ganz relevant ist, weil eben Skype wird irgendwie immer schlechter. Das ist absurd, also die letzten Updates haben einfach am laufenden Meter irgendwelche Verkodex-Werbung.
Was sind denn da für Codex am Start?
Na hier wird vor allem wohl viel Opus verwendet. Bei Video Weiß ist es nicht ganz genau. Da ist es wahrscheinlich eher WebM, wenn ich mal sehe, dass das hier von Google kommt. Die sind da auf jeden Fall ziemlich weit vorn. Ich lese gerade hier, Firefox ging auch oder so.
Keine Ahnung, habe ich nicht getrenntet. Die unterstützen doch auch WebM.
Ja, aber dieses WebRTC an sich jetzt erstmal als Protokoll, unabhängig von dieser Codex-Frage, ist sehr interessant. Und für Podcasts ist das natürlich vor allem mit Opus sehr interessant. Weil ich hatte also hier einen glasklaren Sound, eine super niedrige Latenz und auch diese ganzen Auto-Cancellation und Echo-Cancellation-Effekte von Skype. Also wenn du so zwei standardmäßig konfigurierte, frisch installierte Skype nimmst und du machst darüber Podcasts und redest halt miteinander. Dann hast du immer das Problem, also erstmal hast du so eine Latenz, eine Nennenswerte, sodass man sich immer unterbricht. Und das besonders Dramatische ist dann, in dem Moment, wo dann beide gleichzeitig reden, aber es noch gar nicht merken, dass sie es tun, schalten dann beide Skypes den anderen weg, wenn man selber redet. Sodass man noch nicht mal hört, dass der andere redet, was dazu führen kann, dass sich zwei Leute zehn Sekunden lang anschreien, ohne es zu merken, dass sie beide gerade schreien, weil sie beide vom anderen denken, da wäre nichts.
Sowas hatte ich glücklicherweise bisher noch nicht, aber...
Ja, aber das ist natürlich tödlich. Und das hat jetzt hier zumindest Out of the Box besser funktioniert. Und Opus ist natürlich prädestiniert, da auch gerade diese Latenzen, also niedrige Latenzen, zu ermöglichen. Von garantieren will ich jetzt mal gar nicht sprechen. Aber es wäre auch mal ganz interessant, wenn hier webrtcexperiment.com das ist hier so eine Webseite, wo man das eben ausprobieren kann oder eben dieses erwähnte Talk, T-AWK. Und da kann man dann schön sehen, wie man da lustige Sachen machen kann. Das könnte noch mal ganz interessant werden. So, ich mach aber jetzt mal diesen Freak Show-Kanal zu. Warte mal, hier ist irgendwie, kann mal jemand was sagen? Sprecht man eure Mikrofone hier, die ihr da so seid? Hören wir Leute? Ihr sollt nicht was sagen. Die Leute, die da hier in diesem Kanal verbunden sind, wollen was sagen. Ich kann ja hier mal aufdrehen, dann haben wir bestimmt wieder Echo. Sag mal jemand was. Sagt aber keiner was.
Tropfsteinhöhle.
Jetzt trauen sie sich nicht.
Na egal, vielleicht funktioniert das jetzt auch grad nicht. Ich bin mir hier nicht so sicher, wie mein, du kannst aber diesem Chrom nicht sagen, benutze jetzt mal ein anderes Output-Device. Oder du sagst es und dann tut das nicht ins...
Ja nicht auf deinem Rechner.
Völlig unklar.
Ja, aber zu dem Opus hab ich noch was.
Zum Opus? Ja, was denn?
Und zwar erstens gibt's ja demnächst, soll Opus 1.1 kommen. Sie haben da so ein bisschen für räumlich Klang irgendwie 7.1 oder 5.1, so Verbesserungen, aber auch haben sie glaube ich den Codec so ein bisschen optimiert, dass er nicht mehr so viel CPU-Zeit braucht, weil es gibt ja auch Mumble Client auf dem iPhone und auf den älteren iPhones hat er so ein bisschen Probleme und dann kann man irgendwie den so ein bisschen downgraden, damit die CPU-Power reicht, aber ich denke mit dem 1.1 haben sie das gefixt. Und dann irgendwie habe ich hier ganz interessant gefunden, gibt's von diesem Monty, das ist der, der das alles schreibt, sozusagen The Brain hinter der ganzen Geschichte, auch wenn er bestimmt nicht der Einzige ist und ich viele vergessen habe, blablabla, der hat jedenfalls so ein paar coole Videos auch gemacht und zwei davon, ich verlinke jetzt mal hier die gesamte Seite, wo die alle sind, die Videos, aber zwei davon stechen heraus und zwar einmal 2492 Music Downloads and Why They Make No Sense. Das ist das, was hier der Typ mit Steve Jobs besprochen hat. Wie heißt der hier mit Heart of Gold, der Typ Neil Young, genau, der wollte auch so besser Audio Quality bringen und dieser Monty erklärt mal warum und weshalb und wieso eigentlich CD Quality, warum das alles da drüber eigentlich Quatsch ist. Und dann gibt's noch einen Digital Media Primer for Geeks und der ist auch ganz cool. Da wird einmal alles so schön grob und einfach erklärt und so, dass man es auch versteht und so mit den Containern und mit den Inhalten und den Codex und den Frequenzen und all sowas. Und die beiden, die sollte man sich mal reinziehen. Das ist wirklich, da lernt man was. Der ist richtig cool. Also der Typ hat es wirklich drauf. Und der macht es auch so, dass es nicht so langweilig ist, so ein bisschen macht es auch ein bisschen Spaß macht, die zu gucken. Ja, genau, da die beiden oberen und der dritte, den habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt. Das ist auch interessant und ich glaube, ich hatte es schon mal erzählt, für dieses Opus 1.1 Beta Release, da hat er auch so eine Demopage gemacht, so eine ewig lang, und erklärt alle seine Änderungen nur für Opus 1.1. Und wenn mal jeder so eine Release noch schreiben würde, wie der für diese Änderung, das wäre der Hammer, weil da lernt er auch noch was.
Diese Demopage hier?
Ja, die ist wirklich krass. Also er gibt sich echt Mühe, der Typ, und hängt sich voll rein.
Kannst du das nochmal ins Flowey rüber kopieren? Wo ist denn das?
Okay, Flowey hab ich gerade nicht. Aber ich hab's hier reingedinkt.
Dann muss ich das mal abspielen hier.
Kannst du machen, ja. Und dann kannst du also live hin und her schalten und so. Das ist schon...
Wo ist denn jetzt diese?
Was ist das jetzt hier?
Das ist das Original, ohne Opus, ohne alles. Ja, der Sound ist natürlich jetzt auch der gleiche wahrscheinlich zwischen Opus 10 und 11. Aber der 11er braucht halt ein bisschen weniger Bandbreite.
Warte mal, wo kommt denn das jetzt hier gerade rein? So, wenn ich jetzt das in Opus 10 mache, dann lädt er neu.
Ja, dann braucht er aber nicht mehr 200 sonst wie viele Kilobits, sondern halt nur noch 160. Achso, das ist jetzt hier, da bist du bei dem Allround Sound hier, Front, Center, Rear and...
Es loopt jetzt etwas Hardcore, aber das ist jetzt 170 Kilobit. Ja, und Opus 11?
128, 125.
Der nutzt halt die Ähnlichkeit irgendwie in den Channels besser aus, was er wohl vorher nicht gemacht hat. Wenn man sich das da alles durchliest, der erklärt alles wirklich von vorne bis hinten. Das ist total krass.
Das macht halt Spaß, mal so durchzulesen. Das würde ich mal relisen.
Da will man das Opus 11 schon nur deswegen haben, weil man die Release-Seite gelesen hat, auch wenn man damit gar nicht weiß, was. Aber so macht Software wirklich Spaß, wenn er wirklich von vorne bis hinten alles erklärt, alles schön transparent. Man blickt irgendwie durch oder man hat das Gefühl, dass man informiert wurde.
Ich stehe auch auf solche Dokus. Ich bin ja neulich mal wieder angefurzt worden, nachdem wir diese Mails-Förder-Diskussion hatten, was mir denn einfallen würde, so was noch wie Exim zu benutzen. Und Exim ist einfach eine geile Software. Und jetzt gerade wieder gibt es eine neue Exim-Version. Und die guckt man das Manual an mit Changebars und so, weißt du, wie man sich das so denkt. Mal so 450 Seiten Manual, wo schön alles markiert ist, was sie geändert haben und so was. Dann weiß ich genau, was man da hat. Ich bin da ein echter Fan von. Von einer guten Doku.
Und Opus ist eine coole Sache. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, dann arbeitet der ja auch gerade an einem Video-Codec. Dieser Dala, der ist ganz oben auf der Seite, die ich da verlinkt habe. Aber die hab ich mir noch nicht angeguckt, müsste ich mal machen. Gibt's jetzt auch schon seit einer Weile dieses Dala, glaube ich? Oder steht da ein Datum dabei? Steht jetzt hier leider nicht. Aber erklärt er auch, wie Video-Codecs irgendwie funktionieren, sollte ich mir eigentlich mal reinziehen.
So, so war am Ende. Brauchen wir uns den Rest irgendwie sparen. Data-Bäcker ist irgendwie verschwindet.
Das sind diese weißen Bücher mit dem roten Text.
Wollt ihr noch eine kurze Ansage machen?
Mich hat jemand gefragt, ich soll das doch mal, oder gebeten, ich soll doch mal das mit dem Data-Bäcker erklären. Ich weiß nicht, es war wahrscheinlich eine Diskussion auf Twitter, vermutlich mit dem Hashtag of the day oder so, mit Data-Bäcker-Witzen. Ich hab's nicht mitbekommen, ihr auch nicht?
Es gibt doch noch Markt und Technik.
Ja, aber das ist schon was anderes, finde ich. Also um das mal vielleicht den Leuten zu erklären, ich hab jetzt auch, ich suche gerade mal den Artikel hier.
Das ist aber die Younger Generation, oder?
Die nicht wissen, was das ist?
Data-Bäcker war doch so 8-Bit-Zeiten.
Da war schon 16-Bit am Start.
Nee, wir waren schon zu 8-Bit-Zeiten.
Data-Bäcker war ein Phänomen in den 80er-Jahren und auch noch bis in die 90er-Jahre hinein, aber die waren ja relativ früh dabei. Also 81 in Deutschland, Business mit Computern machen, das war schon was Besonderes.
Da gab es halt Bücher, oder?
Bücher, genau. Bücher und Software. Und zum Prinzip so die Zeit mit WoBiz, diese Läden, und zwar diese ganzen First-Kammer im deutschen Markt. Und Data Becker war halt einer davon. Wo war das? Düsseldorf oder was?
Düsseldorf, ganz zweite Woche.
Ja genau, Düsseldorf, genau. Da steht's ja. Genau. Ja ja. Backe, backe Daten. Der Kunde muss noch warten. Data Becker war ein Phänomen. Also viel von diesen Büchern war auch blöd so, aber sie haben es halt geschafft am Anfang mit dieser Intern-Serie. Ja, und vor allem vorher 64 intern. Das war sozusagen das Buch, glaube ich, was es für Data Becker auch losgetreten hat.
Das waren aber auch so 1000 Seiten Schinken. Ziemlich witzig. Wir waren so telefonbuchdick, ne? In weiß-rote Schrift.
Unglaublich schlecht gesetzt oder teilweise mit einem Matrix-Drucker ausgedruckt. Ja, gebündelte Fotokopien.
Genau, die haben das mit so einem FX80 gedruckt. Aber naja, billige Produktion. Ja, völlig ausreichend. Und vor allem, dieses C64-Intern war also einerseits eine relativ umfangreiche Beschreibung des C64, wie der so funktioniert. Also da hatte man wirklich einen guten Overview und konnte danach im Prinzip mit jedem Chip in dieser Büchse anfangen zu reden. Einschließlich SID und Grafik und so weiter, also Sound und Grafik. Aber der Knaller war halt, dass die Hälfte des Buchs aus dem ROM-Listing bestand. Also es war sozusagen ein kompletter Source-Code des disassemblierten Assemblers mit Kommentierung, wo sie halt Bescheid wussten. Also sie haben sich wirklich das komplette ROM-Listing erzeugt, also disassembliert, immerhin so 16 Kilobyte von dieser Maschine.
War das nicht mehr, 20 oder so?
Das ROM?
Ja, doch, doch, das waren relativ viel.
Nee, das eigentliche System war in 16 Kilobyte. Das ging so ab...
Aber da waren dann noch mal 8 Kilobyte Basics.
E00 und F00 war das.
Wir wollten schon zum Ende kommen, jetzt gehen wir nochmal so richtig aufs letzte Bild.
Ich wollte ja nur erklären, was Sache war. So dann haben sie irgendwie angefangen, diese Software auf den Markt zu bringen, die alle mit Mart endete. Datamart, Faktumart, ich weiß gar nicht, was es noch alles gab, so diverse Sternen Mart. Das waren immer so. Und haben dann irgendwie auch mit den ersten, die angefangen haben, Kopierschütze zu machen, auf Floppy-Discs, indem sie dann halt Code geladen haben in die Floppy. Also die Floppy war ja damals noch mal so ein eigener 6502-Computer. Also sie hatten da so einen Daten-Kopierschutz.
Und dann kaputte Sektoren geschrieben haben.
Kaputte Sektoren kamen später. Erst mal kamen so zusätzliche Sektoren. Sie haben dann sozusagen Software in die Floppy geladen, da den Snapper noch mal einen weitergebracht, in den, ich weiß nicht wie viele Tracks gab's, 40 und dann den 41sten. Und da dann irgendwelche Daten gelesen und so. Das war irgendwie das. Den hab ich gefunden sogar. Also Faktumat geht auf meine Kappe. Ich hab ja nicht viel gekrägt, aber das Ding hab ich geschossen. Das war schwierig. Und Data Backer war halt einfach lange Zeit immer so völlig gehasstlieb, weil sie irgendwie eine Menge Trash gemacht haben, aber dann auch immer wieder so die totalen Brüller rausgemacht haben.
Wir haben die damals ja nur Data-Drecker genutzt.
35 Spuren hatte die 1541.
35?
Mit dynamischer Größe, weil kleiner, weniger aus dem Meer und so.
Genau, genau, genau.
Der Amiga hatte 40 oder jeweils 80 Tracks.
Da konnte man bis zum 82. lesen oder so.
Ich glaube, das hatte ich auch schon, weil es gibt ja diese Simulationsseiten hier und das C64-Software-Project, wo sie die ganzen Disks noch mal scannen und so hatte ich, glaube ich, schon mal erzählt. Und da, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die Seite heißt, da gibt es auch eine Seite, wo sie die ganzen Kopiermechanismen erklären und das liest sich auch richtig geil, was die da mit Halbspuren noch und Drehzahl ändern, während das Ding läuft. Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, was die sich da haben einfallen lassen.
Ich habe mal für die Atari-Floppy mal ein eigener Drum gemacht, wo ich dann sozusagen diese ganzen Funktionen, die der Hardware-Controller brachte, diese ganzen Operationen, die ich auch über das Interface exponiert habe, damit man halt eben roh auf den Controller zugreifen konnte, um genau solche Dinge zu machen. Dann halt, hach!
Ja, Data Becker war der ursprüngliche, weiß nicht, der, was war denn, das waren die beiden Brüder, und vorher gehörte denen schon dieser, und das gibt es glaube ich auch immer noch, Auto Becker. Also Auto Becker in Düsseldorf, das ist da so der Gebrauchswagen, Höcker gewesen, und das lief wohl ganz gut, und dann haben sie da irgendwie mit Data Becker irgendwie ihre Kohle investiert. Interessant, ne? Also genauso wie der Heiseverlag, also ein bisschen vermessender Vergleich, aber auch beim Heiseverlag gab's ja so eine Cash Cow. Also der Heiseverlag ist ja im Wesentlichen durch Telefonbuch druckreich geworden, und diese ganze Kohle, die sie hatten, die haben sie dann halt in, ähm, ich komm jetzt mal durcheinander. Was ist, Franzis Verlag war Elektor, und L-Rad ist bei der CT, ne? Glaub ich, so diese Hardware-Bastel-Zeitung, und dann kam später schnell nach die CT und, ähm, X und wie sie alle heißen und, und, und, diese 64, Input 64 und dieser ganze Krämpel. So, und damit hat quasi Heise auch so sein, sein Datenimperium gegründet, weil sie einfach so eine Spielwiese für Digital-Journalismus sehr früh gestartet haben, weil das einfach ihr eigenes Hobby war, aber die Kohle dafür, um das alles zu stemmen und überhaupt den Heiseverlag erst mal so weit zu bringen, war halt Telefonbuch-Kohle, halt so Monopol-Geld. So, ne? Geld drucken im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und ich weiß es nicht, aber ich hatte immer so die Vermutung, dass es hier mit den Gebrauchtwagen irgendwie ähnlich gelaufen ist. Aber kam 64 intern bei Raus. Danke Data-Bäcker, das Buch war super.
Aber es hat eine gewisse Konsistenz, dass die...
Ja, es hat mich, hat mich......inspiriert.
Das ist ein wichtiges Druckwerk gewesen für mich. Das war wirklich eine unglaubliche Quelle. Ich meine, man muss sich immer klar machen, es gab kein Internet. Es gab keine Informationen über Computer. Man konnte sich nicht mal eben was runterladen, anschauen, was googeln, irgendwas. Sondern du saßt in deinem Scheiß Deutschland in irgendeinem Piss-Cuff. Und du konntest... Wenn du richtig geil warst, hast du irgendwann Ende der 80er Jahre mal ein Modem, wo du vielleicht aus irgendeiner CompuSurf-Mailbox mal eine Textdatei runtergeladen hast. Aber ansonsten warst du darauf angewiesen, regelmäßig einmal im Jahr zur Cebe zu rennen und da möglichst viel Zeug einzusammeln oder gute Bücher zu haben.
Ich hab damals das Amiga Hardware Reference Manual, erste Ausgabe einfach über einen Buchhändler bestellt. Hat zwar irgendwie Monate gedauert, aber die haben mir das besorgt.
Von Atari selber?
Von Amiga selber, ja.
Ich hab's aber nicht für einen C64 so was.
Übrigens neulich gerade beim Aufräumen die Schallszene vom Atari. Hab sie jetzt durch meinen iX500 Scanner durchgehauen. 400 und 800. Also nicht den ST Die hat mir Atari damals übergeben auf der Cebit. Ich bin da hingegangen, cool, hier basteln. Der so, komm her, gib dir mal was. Dann hat der mir echt so einen Stapel, das ist noch richtig so US-Größe. Letter ist nicht A4 oder so. Die hat ich irgendwo noch aufgehoben. Da dachte ich, das ist ja geil, schmeißt die jetzt einfach nur so weg. Ach nee, ich hause vorher noch mal durch den Scanner, hab mir noch mal ein PDF draus gemacht und hab sie dann weggeschmissen. Aber es ist irgendwie, ach ja.
Damals, mir hat ein Kumpel gesagt, du kannst da in München bei Motorola anrufen und sagen, du willst folgende Bücher haben und dann schicken sie dir die. Ich brauch dir so die Assembler, weil ich hab Assembler gekurrt, M68K. Ich so, ja, ne Quatsch, ich kleiner Pief, und dann hab ich anrufen, so ein bisschen ernst gesagt, ich brauch folgendes Ding irgendwie. Und du so, ja, alles klar, Adresse, das und das. Und ein, zwei Wochen später waren die in der Post. Also so billigen Papier, aber ich hab zuhause hier so eine Reihe an Motorola-Büchern zu stehen von diesem Zeug.
Ja, so wie Steve Jobs dann, als er halt bei HP angerufen hat, ich brauch einen Job.
Ich brauch mal ein bisschen Hardware. Hast du mal Party-O?
Ja, ich meine, denkt dir mal, wie du dich jetzt fühlst, wenn dich irgendwelche 16-Jährige irgendwie anhauen mit, ich find das total interessant und ich will da tief einsteigen. Da geht doch allen das Herz hoch.
Aber was ja immer noch geht zumindest, ist bei diesen ganzen Elektronikherstellern, diese Free-Samples zu bestellen. Das hat mich ja total geschockt, dass ich irgendwie mit so Elektronikbasteln angefangen hab. Dann wollte ich so einen LED-Driver mal haben und dann meinte irgendwie, klickt ihr einfach Free-Samples? Dann hab ich mir da irgendwie fünf LED-Driver bei Texas Instruments geklickt und die haben die mit FedEx 24 Stunden um den halben Planeten geschickt. Und ich hatte am nächsten Tag diese Scheiße im Briefkasten und dachte nur, what? Gibt's doch gar nicht.
Es gab noch Zeiten, da gab's sowas. Selbst auf der Cebit. Damals hatten sie halt eben nicht nur Busbanis auf der Cebit, sondern haben für die Hinterzimmer auch echt noch Leute mitgeschleppt, die Ahnung hatten. Also ich hab meine Erklärung für den Atari ST gekriegt von dem Chefentwickler von Atari. Warum weiß ich bis heute nicht, aber er fand das irgendwie cool, so ein Nerd zu erklären. Also das gab's damals noch. Ja, bevor Huckel jetzt umfällt, nur noch eine kleine Hausaufgabe wieder von mir für alle, die sich mal ein bisschen ärgern wollen. Alle Leute, die direkt von der Telekom IPv6 haben, wie zum Beispiel dieser eine Typ von dem Chat, den ich da erwähnt hatte, mögen doch mal bitte einen TraceRoute6 nach www.apple.com eingeben, sich das Resultat angucken, sich ärgern und sofort die Telekom Hotline zukacken, bitte.
apple.com hat jetzt IPv6?
Ja, hat doch Huckel neulich rausgefunden. Bei dir geht es, du hast ja auch einen Tunnel. Aber die Leute, die bei der Telekom hängen, die Telekom hält nicht nötig, bei so einer IPv6-Adresse von so einer Popelfirma wie Apple zu wohnen.
Aber es geht ja zu Akka Mai, ne? Also nichtsdestotrotz, aber...
Die Telekom bietet ihren Leuten nativ mit IPv6 an und hat keine komplette globale Routing-Tabelle drin, weil sie sich wieder mal zu fein sind, die Penner mit allen zu peeren, die da sind, und auch keine Default-Route zu irgendjemanden haben. Und mit so Akka Mai... haben wir halt keinen Bock drauf. Und bieten aber IPv6 ihren Kunden an.
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie von Akka Mai Geld haben und Akka Mai sagt, nee, das ist nicht.
Ja, aber nochmal, wir reden jetzt hier nicht über Geschwindigkeit oder besser oder Quality of Service oder was uns immer vorliegt, sondern wir reden einfach über...
Ob das ganze Internet erreicht werden kann oder nicht.
Genau, über Nicht-Konnektivität.
Das wäre doch mal eine neue Produktgeschichte, nicht nur die Geschwindigkeit, sondern sozusagen wie viel Prozent des Internets. Ja, also für 19,99 Euro gibt's Europa und USA. Und wenn du auch Afrika erreichen willst, dann zahlst halt nochmal einen Zehner dazu.
Afrika ist viel umsonst, da will ja keiner hin. Amerika kostet extra.
Ja, Afrika ist teuer und so weiter.
Amerika ist billig.
Keine Ahnung, dann halt das Ozeanien-Pack.
Oder das Diplomaten-Pack für hinter die...
Also, finde ich, sie gesagt, angesichts der Diskussion von wir ruten nur über deutsche Netze und was weiß ich nicht alle. Also, das ist ein so verlogenes Pack. Das ist echt ärgerlich.
Das haben wir jetzt gar nicht auseinandergenommen.
Ja, Huckel will jetzt unbedingt gehen. Deswegen gehen wir jetzt auch. Ich will noch mal einen Flieger kriegen. Aber wir können gerne da drüber nochmal ein bisschen renten. Das geht mir nämlich echt an.
Nächstes Mal.
Es geht jetzt zu weit sonst. Gut.
Weil wenn es anfängt, Bing Bing Bing zu machen, ist dann auch wirklich Schluss.
Dann gleich verwandelt sich... Oh, meine Kutsche hat sich schon verwandelt vor der Tür.
Wie sie hören? Hören sie nichts? Wieso nichts?
Hast du das Echo ausgemacht?
Weil der Profi immer wieder...
Drückst du jetzt noch mal zum Schluss. Eine kleine Punchline rein, ja.
Welche Sorte ist das hier? 60 Prozent? Gab es noch eine bessere? Nee, 60 war schon die beste.
Leute, wir sagen Tschüss.
Und das war's.
Genau nochmal Danke für die Schoki.
Ja.